typescript is a programming language
based on JavaScript that is becoming
increasingly popular in this complete
course hitesh choudhary will teach you
everything you need to know to get
started with typescript itache is a very
popular teacher who has created over 1
000 tutorials hey there everyone they
share back again with another video and
I know you are pretty excited about this
new series that we are going to get
started this series is going to be a
little bit fast paced so that you can
understand what typescript is and I
totally understand the excitement the
enthusiasm to learn all about typescript
that you want to have but right now the
entire world is stormed by JavaScript a
lot of people are loving it a lot of
people are hating it but regardless the
fact everybody is writing JavaScript and
there are plethora of tutorials
available on JavaScript including mine
and I am also determined to add more
videos in those tutorial series but
there is new kid in the town known as
typescript a lot of people are loving it
those who start writing the typescript
just claims that I don't want to go back
into writing JavaScript so what's this
all fun about typescript are we missing
anything not at all today we are
starting a brand new series on the
typescript and eventually as we go
further you will have the full knowledge
and full writable skills so that you can
transform from JavaScript to typescript
but before going further there I would
like to just give you an introduction
what typescript is and should you be
even writing typescript at all on the
first place there is a lot of hurry in
the market that I just want to jump into
typescript I don't even want to learn
JavaScript but that is not the case that
is not how it should be started it
should be started with JavaScript and
there is a reason behind it I'll walk
you through with that and I'll also walk
you through that why it is important and
why even you should be writing
JavaScript at the first place or
shouldn't be that is the big question
that we are answering so welcome to the
series on the typescript and we will be
running this series into a fast paced
mode I'll be pushing up a lot of videos
so go ahead buckle up and let's get
started with typescript
so typescript obviously you want to
learn it and everybody knows one thing
about typescript I'm pretty sure in case
you are living unless and until under a
rock you have heard about that if this
is a JavaScript the classic yellow icon
this is a typescript often called as the
typescript is a superset of JavaScript
that means everything that you can do in
JavaScript that is already available in
typescript and a lot more is available
to that but that is a kind of a true
statement but not accurately being
contextualized by a lot of people yes
you have an accurate statement that
typescript is a superset of JavaScript
but it's not like it is adding more
features to JavaScript no it doesn't
give you more of callbacks it doesn't
give you more of Arrow function it just
allows you to write JavaScript in a much
precise manner so that your code faces a
lot less error in the runtime if there
is any error it is already being
displayed to you while writing the code
at the kind of when you're just typing
them out in the your favorite editor
maybe vs code or something that is where
we want to just catch those error and
find that we shouldn't be doing
something like that so that is all your
typescript it is not going to give you a
new Loop it is not going to give you a
classes or new modules it is not going
to give you anything new in fact all the
code that you write in the typescript is
finally compiled into JavaScript not
only that even though your code reader
might be yelling at you with some
squiggly line about typescript code
still you are allowed to compile that
code in the JavaScript and it might run
with errors but it might run so there is
a strong thing that you need to
understand that it's not like typescript
is the ultimate way of writing the pure
JavaScript and it is not going to give
you any core key Behavior it might still
throw you around off somewhere and that
is exactly what we are going to learn in
this series so first yes I understand
that you know this statement that there
is a JavaScript there is a typescript it
encircles the entire JavaScript in this
series I'll walk you through all the
details and depth of the typescript so
don't you worry about that I'll cover
that up but first and foremost should
you be even learning typescript that is
the big question typescript is not about
Reinventing the entire JavaScript
language it is not it just is asking
that you write JavaScript with a little
bit more accurate Behavior don't let you
just do anything just try to write a
JavaScript in a more precise manner so
that errors are less and I honestly
would say you shouldn't be using
typescript if your project is just too
file long and there are in each file
there are just five or ten lines of code
it is not come people say that every
single place you need to write TSX or Ts
for typescript I've seen a lot of people
who use typescript but all the places
they use any which is a keyword we'll
talk about that later on if you are
using typescript you need to use the
super power of typescript to make your
code much more powerful and much more
error prone and if you are using just
typescript for the fanciness of writing
TS you're probably not using it
correctly after watching this series
you'll be watching typescript in a much
more powerful manner so typescript is
all about type safety nothing more
just this word and I'll be repeating
this word probably a million time in
this entire series that what is this
type safety typescript is all about type
safety nothing else so what is this type
safety let me give you a couple of code
examples so type safety is nothing the
JavaScript allows us to do some odd
behavior for example I can go ahead and
just add two with a string of two which
I shouldn't be allowed to do and it
gives me a odd result of 22. this is
happening because the type safety was
missing on the very first place it
should have stopped me from doing an
addition of number with string now it
doesn't stop you it tries to do its own
behavior which I have discussed a little
bit in my other videos but let's just
say right now stick here so this
Behavior shouldn't be allowed that is
all a mismatching of the type if you
have been consistent with your type this
error shouldn't be there and typescript
allows you to just stop this Behavior
that's all it does for example let's
just say you have null you are allowed
to add a two value to the null and on
top of that there is undefined and you
are allowed to add a 2 to undefine and
get another thing like two and none not
a number this is all not the quirky
behavior of JavaScript but rather your
way of you haven't been concerned about
the types of JavaScript there is an
explanation in the documentation of
JavaScript that what behavior is going
to kick in or what behavior is going to
superpower Empower that but apart from
mdn we haven't read the documentation of
JavaScript which are being the language
specification given by ecmascript they
are all right here but the idea is I
shouldn't be reading that much on the
first place I should be focused on
building my application with the type
safety and that is where the typescript
comes into the picture so in this series
you're going to be mastering the
typescript so subscribe to the channel
and we're going to be walking through in
fact rolling coasting through this ride
of type safety with the typescript I
hope you are all excited a lot of videos
are coming in get subscribed and let's
catch you up in the next video hey there
everyone they share back again with
another video and before we even move
further in the typescript even its
installation process I want to make this
absolutely clear that what typescript is
and what it isn't in this video I'll
focus on what typescript is not and this
will help you to understand a typescript
in a better way and the perspective of
the typescript is going to change a lot
of people believe that typescript is a
new programming language which honestly
is not a 100 true statement there is a
little bit difference in understanding
the typescript so let's get our vision
clear first and then in the next video
we'll move on the installation part and
the environment setup so that we can
start writing typescript but before that
let's clear our perspective about what
typescript is in order to understand
what typescript is you need to
understand is the simple statement what
typescript does for you the simple idea
behind the typescript is static checking
that's the only job and yes that's the
only one job that typescript has got for
you
the static checking is something which
is present in many languages especially
the languages such as Java or maybe even
golang a lot of languages are are built
in with the static checking and what
does the static checking means that
whenever you're writing the code the
parser of the language or the the entire
syntax of the language is constantly
being analyzed by The Ides but not in
the case of JavaScript whatever you
write is just okay for the JavaScript
and when the code executes in the
browser or is or in the engine like node
environment or anything that then only
the errors of JavaScript are being
thrown at your face and at that time you
just say Ah that's wrong and you need to
rerun the code itself but it would be
really a great help if there is a static
Checker which checks my code as I try to
write it for example I'm trying to
access an object which is not yet
defined if something can analyze my code
and can give me a hint that that object
doesn't exist in the or in the object
properties then obviously it's much more
easier for me for example when we are
trying to add a few numbers and then the
one of the number is not a number maybe
a string then if somebody helps me in
giving me a squiggly line that hey that
is not going to work so that is great
for me and again the level of the detail
that which one is going to stop you from
doing something and not stop you that's
all about the static checking so just to
repeat
typescript is just for static checking
it just analyze your code and help you
to understand that you might be running
into a potential error without even
running the code and getting the errors
at the runtime itself that's all it does
so I hope you understand that the whole
job of the typescript is simply to
analyze the code that's it that's all it
does now on top of that I'll also walk
you through with the example as well
that it just checks and gives you hint
about that yeah you might be doing
something wrong but yes it is still
possible that your code might be giving
you squiggly lines or errors and still
you may export this entire code into
JavaScript and that might run absolutely
well and I'll walk you through with
couple of more missed things uh kind of
a misheard Concepts about typescript
that hey with the typescript you write
less code and it does build the
JavaScript code for you so that is way
more code in fact reverse is the true in
the typescript you write a lot more code
compared to JavaScript and sometimes
even I have seen 50 lines of code are
being compiled into just 10 lines of
JavaScript yes but it is worth it I'll
walk you through with that as well so
first how the development process works
you write all of your code in ts.ts
format which is the simple typescript
when you're building components like
react or something I have seen people
use a simple extension of dot TSX which
is also totally fine it has nothing to
do it is just a mixture of typescript
plus uh the jsx kind of a syntax so this
is kind of a same component thing
basically your HTML is baked into the
system I'll walk you through with that
as well but the whole idea behind the
typescript is you write your typescript
code and that code is being transpiled
into JavaScript and there are a lot of
fancy words here it is compiled it is
transpiled we'll work through with that
I'll give you a brief overview of what
is the difference between them what is
the meaning of it and how it is working
you can just simply say at this point of
time the typescript code is being
converted into JavaScript that is a
rather safe word to use right now and
then your JavaScript and one thing the
most important thing to learn and to
know for for this video is typescript is
a development tool yep it is a
development tool your project still runs
in JavaScript the code that you produce
or you send to the production is still a
pure 100 JavaScript code so typescript
is just a layer on top of JavaScript as
I told in the earlier video it's a
superset of JavaScript but rather it
would be accurate to say that it's a
development tool it helps you to write
better code with less problems with a
more scalable and maintainable code that
is easily understandable and produces
and the chances of producing the error
is much more less but it by no means
that's a standalone language in itself
it's something which is a wrapper around
the JavaScript and yes there are new
keywords here like Union and interface
and a whole lot of them we'll walk
through with that but understand this
very important thing that it is honestly
a development tool which helps you to
write better code this might be a
surprising for a lot of us but this is
how it works okay giving you some
examples on that we'll be writing a ton
of hands of code we'll be be setting up
our own environment as well but I'll
walk you through with those so this is a
typescriptlang.org
a free code environment that is
available to all of us and we can see on
the left hand side we run the typescript
and there are a lot of versions of it
and on the right hand side it just
produces a JavaScript code for example I
can just go ahead and say Hey I want to
do a simple
console.log and I want to just say I
want to print my name all right hello
world that's how it got started and you
can see that the JavaScript part that is
coming out it's exactly the same in fact
let me just go ahead and declare a
simple user so let's just say we are
going to call this one as simple user
this is an object and in this object
there is a property something like a
name which is going to be my name and
let's just say we also have another
property which is age and let's just say
age is 10 factitious of course and you
can see that this is exactly what is
producing now what typescript allows you
to do if I just let's just say I want to
have an available email and that email
comes from user dot email now notice
here there is a squiggly line the error
was given to me here that hey this this
property doesn't exist so typescript
smartly just go through with your code
and tells you that email was not
available there but notice here most
important thing here is although this
property was not there but there is
nothing which is stopping me to produce
the equivalent JavaScript code yes that
is the most important thing in fact this
might be a little bit surprising to you
and the initial first look that let's
just say if you go ahead and say that I
have a simple number one which is three
and let's just say if we have a number
two which is uh three and if I go ahead
and say hey let's just call this one as
sum that is going to be equal to number
one and we're going to go ahead and say
number two now notice here if I go ahead
and do a simple console
DOT log and I go ahead and say hey give
me a sum you might be thinking that
JavaScript or typescript especially is
going to just disallow you to do these
kinds of things you can see right now
nothing is doing that if I run this code
the code is transpiled we get the same
things as 33 yes there are ways to avoid
this I'll walk you through with that but
here we can see in the playground it is
working fine so it is very important to
understand in depth about typescript
that what is allowed what is not allowed
how we can enhance a mode of type safety
in our JavaScript code and that's
exactly what we are going to learn in
this video so again always remember it's
a development tool it's yes there are a
lot of keywords and everything that is
new in this stuff but it would be rather
much more accurate to call it as a
development tool instead of just a
standalone language because this
language is too much dependent in fact
entirely dependent on JavaScript it's
just a wrapper around it so let's go
ahead in the next video we'll be setting
up an environment so that all of us can
write some typescript on our own
environment and you can just set this up
let's go ahead and catch up in next
video hey there everyone hitesh here
back again with another video and
welcome to another video in the
typescript series now I'm a firm
believer that if you show people the
code and try to explain the concept
within the code and the execution of the
code it's much easier to explain I've
tried it out tested it out with over a
million student and it works nicely the
another consequence is that if you don't
try to write the code and instead you
just use the pen and pencil which is a
great way of learning but it takes much
more time it requires let's just say 40
minute videos or a one hour 40 minute
video but what I've noticed is take
people directly on the code try to write
the code execute the code and explain
the concept just right there it brings a
more functionality to the teaching
pedagogy as well as it's much more
easier to understand and that's exactly
what we'll be following in this entire
series instead of just putting you all
in the theory of pen and pencil which is
a good good way again of teaching the
stuff but I'm a firm believer of taking
you onto the code editor as quickly as
possible let's go ahead and work with
that so in this video I'll walk you
through that how you can install
typescript on your system and there are
a couple of ways how you do it now the
way how we are going to start with the
typescript and the way how we use it in
the projects are two different
installation of the typescript the first
one is a globalized system install that
we are going to use this will be helpful
for you to understand the concepts of
typescript but when you're going to use
typescript in your project maybe react
project or angular project there an
additional typescript config file is
required so that you can address what
kind of settings you want what kind of
things you don't want so there will be a
two different installation first of all
we are going to focus just on the core
system-wide installation so that you can
create basic files understand what is
the new thing in the typescript how you
can understand it and then we are going
to later on move into the project
section where we are going to see how we
can config the typescript settings so
that it can help us to produce a better
code I hope that is all clear for this
now let me take you on to my computer
screen and walk you through with that
the first thing that we're going to do
is obviously create create a new folder
and we're going to call this one as
simply simply let's just call this one
as typescript and why not typescript
YouTube because that's what we are doing
up here okay so typescript YouTube is
here inside this also I would like to
create a new folder and let's call this
one as zero one uh this is getting intro
so let's call this one as zero one intro
so this is the four
everything up here now before that we
need to install typescript so
installation of the typescript is pretty
super straightforward now let me walk
you through with that all you have to do
is first open up your terminal
and by the way all these instructions
are also mentioned on the typescript
website we are going to study that in a
minute let me open that up just give me
a second so let me go ahead and open up
the typescript so
here it is okay so here it is the
typescript website officially and all
the things are available here and we can
see that this is online where npm there
are lots of ways how you can actually go
ahead and install that let's go on to
the download section and here it says
that hey you can install the typescript
by saying npm install typescript uh this
is a way but we won't be using this one
rather we'll be actually installing it
globally so that we can use it wherever
we like once we are done with that uh
Global installation we have understood
the basic concept then in the project
we'll be using the same npm install
typescript as a Dev I told you this is a
development tool that's why it's usually
installed as a Dev dependency so things
will make much more sense as we move
forward so you get that it's pretty easy
and same and again it's exactly same for
Mac Windows Linux whatever the system
you're using in case you are on Windows
I highly recommend to use git bash which
is way better shell or to use Powershell
so there's a shell available known as
git bash for Windows I highly recommend
people to use this shell it gives you
the same command that I'm using like
CDLs and all Linux friendly commands
again nothing much to do nothing a hard
and fast requirement now the very first
thing that we need is nodes so make sure
there is a node installed in your system
if you just say node Dash V it should
pop up some number it doesn't really
mean that exact same number should come
up to you any number is fine if it is
giving us an error then go ahead on to
node website and install node pretty
simple next next I agree click OK all
those kind of stuff should be okay node
also gives us a utility of npm and we
can check out what version of npm node
package manager is given to us and we
have to install that as well once we're
done with this then we have to Simply go
ahead and install the typescript and
then for installation it's pretty simple
npm install and we're going to install
typescript that's all what we need now
this is what we need but we want to
install it globally so that we can use
wherever and anywhere we like throughout
the system and that is why the dash G
flag works now this is going to work
absolutely fine in case you are on
Windows make sure you right click and
open up your git bash as an
administrator in case you are on Linux
or Mac make sure you append this with
sudo in some cases it is required as
soon as you hit sudo you need to enter a
password and that's it let's go ahead
and do this this is going to ask a
password that's it and mine is already
installed so it didn't took much time
but this is all what we got so now
typescript is available in our system
and if I just open up this one here
this actually gives us a unique command
which is TSC typescript now there are a
couple of other ways of installing it
with node node package executor and a
whole bunch of other thing but the focus
here is that it gives us an access to
the command which is TSC this is the
whole which is going to allow us to
install not install but actually execute
the typescript file so I can go ahead
and say TSC and I can hit a dash V to
find out the version of it as long as it
gives me any number of version that is
totally fine throughout this course
we'll be focusing on the core foundation
and fundamental of typescript so any
version Beyond this or even this version
is absolutely fine in case you are using
any previous version that is also
absolutely fine nothing should be
worried these are core Foundation these
are the things which never change in the
language itself all right pretty basic
installation but I have explained each
line by line I hope you appreciate that
if you appreciate that make sure you hit
that subscribe button I have noticed
that 70 of my audience doesn't do
subscribe button so go ahead and please
head that out okay now this is all done
so we have a new folder up here let's go
ahead and fire up a vs code as well so
we're going to go ahead and say vs code
Visual Studio code
should be taking just a minute to get
started and this is what we have this is
a previous iOS Dev version that is
already installed so we're going to just
remove this
get started with the intro and there we
go yes of course I trust this okay
now in this intro all we're going to do
is write the very basic hello world but
in typescript we'll be able to compile
that into JavaScript so that we can see
how that works so we're going to go
ahead and call this one as
intro dot TS and again make sure you
write this as TS you can also write it
TSX but that's for a component level
thing when we want to use or install jsx
execute jsx in the same file if you
didn't understand that that's totally
okay make sure you write dot TS which is
an extension of typescript now vs code
will try to give you a DOT TS
automatically as a typescript in case
you don't have that go ahead and install
some packages for icons and stuff pretty
there are plethora of icons available
you can go ahead and look for icons
material icon to what not everything is
available
now all right now let's go ahead and see
that how we can actually write some of
the code and convert them into
JavaScript so the classic let's go ahead
and do a console log and let's go ahead
and write name make sure you write your
name that would be fantastic one this is
a classic code of JavaScript that has
nothing to do with uh with the
typescript at all let's go ahead and
create a couple of variables so we're
going to go ahead and say let's call
this one as number or let's go ahead and
have a user so same example that we have
talked through previously and let's go
ahead and say that this is going to have
a name let's say this is my name and an
age that is going to be 10 pretty good
and let's just say what more we have uh
email well let's just not put email
let's just have this much only and
further down the road we also want to
have a console log of something so let's
go ahead and remove this one and say we
want to print out user dot name now this
is a cloud a classic JavaScript nothing
to do classic typescript nothing to do
with JavaScript but this thing whole
thing it cannot be executed at all
in the typescript format if you put this
into production or any application it's
not going to work this is where your
installation of TSX or the typescript
comes into the picture so what you can
do is you can simply say TS
TSC type script and once we have this
typescript then all we got to do is name
the file in this case intro.ts as soon
as I hit this enter notice this has
automatically created an intro.js for me
and the code is exactly same yes the
spaces were removed and it tries to
align it this is all what typescript
does it converts your typescript into
JavaScript no matter what project you
are using this is the exact
implementation of it now the only
advantages as I told you right now it's
giving us a squiggly line that it says
cannot redeclare the block scope
variable and all of that so that's the
basic we'll go through with the more
detail that it should be alert or it
should be a const whatever it should be
why is it giving us errors and hold
those details we'll study about that in
depth the only advantage that we get is
if I go ahead and do an email it gives
me again squiggly line that property
email does not exist on type so the
whole idea behind typescript is it saves
me from some errors which I will
eventually fall into if I'm writing just
code JavaScript and again I told you one
more time this is just a Dev tool this
is a development tool a wrapper around
JavaScript to make your life easier and
safer now again there is nothing which
is stopping me to execute this code if I
go ahead and run this file again this
command again notice it gives me an
error but still the code works it says
user.email so yes there will be errors
but these errors doesn't stop you from
producing your JavaScript as well again
there are a lot of settings for that as
well so again you get the idea how this
is being done one more thing I would
like to mention here is
onto the playground so if I go ahead and
click on the playground on the
typescript website you will notice that
there is a tab which says settings now
in the settings you can see there is a
lot of settings that are available for
you and on top of that there is a TS
config this is the configuration file
that we make while creating a react
project or another project in this there
are a lot of options that you want to
include jsx or maybe you want to include
the es next module what is your target
maybe es2017 2019 es next whatever your
target there's a lot of Declaration lot
of output formatting how you want to
make your code purify do you want to
have an error not error strict checking
and all of that yes we will understand
them when we'll be creating our TS
config file for the project but I just
wanted to give a brief overview that it
does exist and you can see a lot of
examples one thing that I forgot to
mention in the last video is the same
thing that a lot of people believe that
with the type script you like you write
less line of code and you can just click
on example and let's just say you want
to have an example of built-in utility
types and you can see that these are so
much of the line of code But ultimately
it generates only this much of lamba
code if you remove the comments you can
see this is the only code that we were
able to generate in JavaScript and we
are writing so much in typescript so yes
this is the case we write a lot more
code in typescript but it's a safer code
quite a lot quite a lot in just one
video so that's it for this video let's
catch up in the next one and try to get
one by one the details and the
nitty-gritty of the typescript let's
catch up in the next video hit that
subscribe
hey there everyone natash here back
again with another video and welcome to
the typescript series so in case you are
new along from learning from me or in
case you have watched other videos then
you probably know this so whenever I
start a series I go slow in the very
beginning it might feel like it's too
slow but eventually I pick up the pace
with the tutorial so that it's easier
for everyone to follow and we are
exploding typescript and one more big
thing in all of my videos I encourage a
lot of people to learn from
documentation surely you can just keep
on watching my videos but the ultimate
knowledge that I can give you is how to
read the documentation so throughout
this series I'll walk you through that
how you can read the documentation get
better at the things so that you can
learn things on your own and we'll be
also coding along with that so this is
going to be our very first official kind
of hello world and we're gonna see what
impact typescript can add when we write
a simple hello world program nothing
fancy just getting started very Basics
very slowly so let me talk you through
and let me bring you up on my screen
first so let's first understand about
the types so as I've already mentioned
typescript is all about types and we're
going to study a whole lot of types so
the obvious question is what are kind of
types that are available in the
typescript and trust me there are many
many of the types are available for
example you'll be seeing me talking
about numbers and strings and Boolean
but these are not the only types yes
they can be divided into primitive type
or the other types or modern types I
honestly say that don't do this kind of
division between the categories and
types they are all just types and try to
picture them through just one screen
that all of them are just types and just
to name others there are null undefined
and there is a special type known as
void and there's also objects and arrays
and tuples and couple of more types as
well which are available in the
typescript language and once you
understand and master what are the types
which are available and how to utilize
them that's all the typescript that is
all the typescript is all about but what
I have noticed in a lot of code bases
that people you use typescript but a lot
of time this keyword I have found
floating around like here and there if
you're using any as a keyword that means
you are intentionally making your code
more vulnerable or more like a
javascript-ish so that we don't have to
worry about the types if if there are
situation where you're using any that
means you are not probably not many not
much sure that you should be either
using it or not and to surprise a lot of
you there is even a type known as never
an unknown yes these are special type
given to us by the typescript and I
would like to walk you through with this
documentation
so this is a documentation which talks
about the unknown and any and object and
void and undefined there's a lot of them
and if you look at the stable summary
this is an abstract row what is allowed
what is not allowed and strict checking
all of that now we'll come back on to
this table and chart we'll understand
the meaning of it that how any impacts
are the code that you're writing or how
unknown an object and void Define all of
this impact this is your very first look
of how to jump into the documentation so
instead of that let me just click on the
get started and this is what it's saying
Ts for new programmer in fact if you go
at the very top of it you'll find the
docs tab the docs of the typescript and
even all of the language are designed by
different people so they are very
different for all of the other but they
follow some of the specification that
this is what the guidelines I'll follow
in the documentation so this is the
guideline that we'll be following
through in this entire tutorial and you
can see there's a lot of cheat sheets
and all these things like decorators
enums are available we'll be going
through with all of them the first I
want to bring your attention is just
some simply the basics not the handbook
but the basics so once you click on the
basics you can notice that there are
things available so if I click on
everyday types you can see there is a
primitive type and a lot of tutorial
goes through with that which is good
that there are strings and numbers and
Boolean but not only that if you look a
little bit lower down there's array
there is any which is notoriously known
for not being used and there is no
implicit any then we have a whole lot of
functions and all of them so JavaScript
and typescript are closely related we'll
come back onto this one all I want you
for this tutorial is just go through
this don't read the example just go
through how many types actually can you
figure out and find out so on this page
how many types or how many keywords you
can find out just list them in the
comment section that would be really
helpful for other people who are coming
in so for example we have object we have
Union and a whole lot of thing
eventually we'll be covering them up
Don't You Worry on that part now once
you've gone through with the type we
will be writing some code in this
tutorial one thing more I would like to
put picture in your mind while learning
the typescript the first one is
situation so at what situation the
typescript serves best although you can
design your variable or declare your
variable any given time but imagine to
think that typescript is helping you out
in figuring out what data is about to be
processed or what data is about to be
coming from any resource or what data
your function is going to send out so
just two example I have taken as a use
case scenario here a function accepts
two number now what happens in the
regular JavaScript code is once a
function accepts the number then you
check the type of these values and you
want to be make sure that these are
actually number because I want to
perform some operations on that
what typescript helps you out is you
don't have to explicitly check that hey
if the function which is accepting and
what is coming as a data is it really
number is it my it might be a string or
it might be a void or nothing might be
coming in so typescript allows you to
get away from the situation so extra
line of code that you don't have to
write the similar situation is a
function returns a string so obviously
the situation that comes in the
JavaScript that suppose you're using a
function and you're expecting that the
data coming out of that function is a
string but that not might be the case
maybe some other programmer has written
this and he might have thrown out a
number and that could be a problematic
situation so when you're working with
the team and you're using typescript you
are absolutely sure that from this
function I always expects that a string
is going to come out and that's where
when you're working with the team the
typescript actually makes a life a lot
more easier yes there are a lot of rules
and protocols that we have to follow but
this helps us to actually not fall into
a lot of such problems so so we're gonna
first walk through with the very basic
syntax in this video we'll be getting
through read through couple of errors
that we already are having and then
we're gonna slowly pick up the pace
about reading the documentation and
learning more about typescript so the
syntax is pretty simple we use let const
whatever the keyword you want to use for
declaring your variable then you simply
go ahead and use a variable name after
the variable name you put a column and
Define its type now all the types almost
all the types in typescript are
lowercase there is no uppercase there is
no camel casing or lowercase so number
strings whatever you want to name or put
a data type on it then all it's a
lowercase then optionally you can pass
on a value or can just declare a
variable let's go ahead and give it a
try by writing some of the code because
I still believe that writing the code
makes much much more easier things and
also we can see there are some squiggly
line already in my code which is not
looking good so we need to learn how we
can actually get rid of this error
temporarily and then later on once we
are going to learn about the typescript
config it will help us to under standard
more so again have patience okay so
let's go ahead and close this out
because I'm not interested in this one
so intro.ts nope not interested let's go
ahead and create another file and let's
just call this as variables
me dot TS and again this me is just a
fancy word so don't you worry on that so
let's go ahead and declare a simple
variable name that just says hello world
so let's just go ahead and say Hey I
want to have a let and let's call this
one as greetings
and in the greetings we're going to put
up a column and then we're going to
write a simple string and then once I go
ahead and do this I'll optionally pass
on a value now this alone is a good
statement there is nothing wrong in it
you have created a variable and you have
defined that only string type of value
can come into it but optionally we can
also go ahead and put up some value in
it so go ahead and write your name so
I'm going to write mine here go ahead
and write yours once I go ahead and do
this I want to do a simple console log I
can go ahead and simply Say Hey I want
to have a greeting just like that
greetings save this and this works
absolutely fine in this case
now let me walk you through that this is
all good and we can just go ahead and
use a TSC Syntax for this so TSC and
this one is
variables.ts me it is obviously going to
generate a tsjs code this is all good
and notice here it doesn't change
anything also it gives us a squiggly
line which says cannot redecure block
scope variable greetings what this all
is about we will have a dedicated video
on it right now to just get rid of this
error we're going to go ahead and say
exports then a column and that's it this
is going to remove the error temporarily
and will give us a peace of mind that
hey don't worry about these quickly
lines but I promise you we'll come back
onto this one later on right now this is
all good
now this alone statement of putting a
colon is really really fundamental to
this one you click on greeting and
notice it says that the greetings is a
string this is a peace of mind that yes
I'm declaring a variable which always no
matter what happens is always going to
accept the string later on some other
programmer who is working on the same
project gets this variable and try to
assign it a number as six this
automatically stops me and saves me an
error that hey the type number cannot is
not assignable to type string because
it's a number you cannot do this if
anybody tries to declare let's just say
a True Value into it it says hey that's
also not allowed you should not be doing
it that is what the safety that
typescript actually gives you not only
that if I go ahead and remove this and
if I try to put up a DOT you can see all
the methods that are being suggested to
me like pad ants and all of that these
are string Methods these are not methods
which are meant for number for example
let's just go ahead and declare another
variable up here which actually gets a
number so let's just call this one as my
num and that number is four or six
whatever that is and I go back up here
and I say hey I want to use my num Dot
and I'm going to use two
upper case you cannot do it accidentally
this might happen not from you maybe but
from person who is using your code base
and is collaborating with you on the
code it says that hey property two
uppercase does not exist on type number
not only that it also allows you to have
more safety for example there is a
greeting and I know that two uppercase
or two lowercase exist and this one I
can go ahead and run this one but
accidentally maybe I'm not using
suggestion maybe I'm using way more
other code reader and my I might have
done this lowercase and I can tell you I
have done this I have done this a lot of
typos in the past but typescript
actually allows me to give a suggestion
that hey property to lowercase does not
exist did you mean to lower case so it
also helps me to get my indefined method
and as you train it more it actually
gets uh suggestions from your own code
base as well so that is really really
impressive and amazing so so far we have
gone through with the very basic we'll
take it slow and steadily so right now
all you have to learn is colon and a
string that's how you should be
declaring the variable now eventually in
the later on videos you'll realize that
sometimes we don't even need to just use
this column it automatically infers the
value and stops you doing mischiefs like
adding uh later on number to the
greetings we will work through in that
but right now this is all you have gone
through with your very first idea of how
typescript Works a little bit intro to
the documentation some assignment that
you have to do in the comment section
and I'll catch you up in the next video
where we'll explore a little bit more in
depth of typescript let's catch up in
the next one and one more important
thing very very important thing you guys
forgot to hit that subscribe button go
ahead and do that I would be really
thankful for that let's catch you for
the next one hey there everyone this
year back again with another video and
welcome to the typescript series now
through this series I not only want to
talk you through that how to write
typescript but I also want to get all
the best practices that you should be
using while using the typescript so
we'll be jumping through the
documentation we'll guide you briefly
about what is there in it and this video
is not going to be too much intense
we'll just talk about numbers and
booleans we have already talked briefly
about the string and then I'll talk
about the type inference which is mostly
should be used but it is less being used
so let me walk you through with that so
here we are on to the documentation page
and as we scroll up here a little bit we
see that the Primitive types that we're
discussing the string which we have
already covered and the rest two are
numbers and booleans so we need to cover
them up now these are mostly used as
primitive types and string represent the
values like this and then the numbers
now interesting thing here which you
should get from the documentation
directly not from any YouTuber or from
any blog article but rather from the
documentation directly the JavaScript
does not have special runtime value for
integers so there is no equivalent of
intent float and this is usually a lot
of time an interview question as well do
how do we Define especially the integers
or float in typescript we don't we just
call them numbers and that's how it is
being defined and that's how the value
is inferred I'll come back onto the
inferred part a little bit so let's
write some code and take some example
out of it so that we can understand more
part of it now we don't need to create a
simple new file for this one because
this is already very simple and there is
nothing much we are doing let me just
remove this part that we don't need and
we'll just go up here here so the two
things that we're going to talk about
the first one being simply number and
remember there's again there's a little
bit more to it let me walk you through
with the a simple example of the
typescript remember this is being called
as that we have this number not numbers
there is a special question around it in
most of the interviews remember this is
a number now how do we Define number
it's pretty simple let's just say we are
defining a user ID so this is going to
be a simple user ID and that ID simply
can be let's just say uh three three
four four six six so this is what we
have in the case of numbers we're going
to go ahead and put an annotation here
colon and then space and then number
this depicts or this annotates that this
user ID is number and should always be
number now advantage that we get with
that is simply when I say user ID and I
put up a DOT all the values or all the
methods that are available in JavaScript
related to numbers only those values or
those methods are being fetched to me so
for example to exponential to fixed
Locale string all these things there's
nothing much on the numbers in
JavaScript and that's why only these
values or numbers are being used that's
the basic that's the number and again it
doesn't really matter if you just add a
0.2 or 0.3 after it it is still going to
be the number that's all that's all it
is there is not too much of in depth
about the numbers yes we'll go through
in that later on now apart from this
there is also a Boolean that we have to
use
now let's just say for example you're
using some values let's just say is
logged in so that is something you want
to track and let's just say user is not
logged in so that is how it goes on
false and then there is something known
as Boolean that we have to infer now
obviously you get all the values and
methods that are there for the Boolean
so later later on if I go ahead and say
is logged in I put up a DOT then we
don't have much on the Boolean it's just
the value of what is the value of this
particular variable true or false that's
all the methods that we have now here I
want to bring your attention to
something known as type inference now a
lot of people when they get started with
typescript they are very much excited
about putting up annotation with every
single thing numbers and strings and
Boolean but here what is we are doing as
not so good practice what we are doing
here is we're making it too obvious this
is the numbers and just after that we
are putting up an equal sign and putting
it as a number now this is too obvious
to do now obviously there is another way
of doing or dealing with that thing is
for example maybe you are not dealing it
like that and maybe in the very next
line you put up and say uh that hey now
user ID is going to get a value let's
just say it's some value and a decimal
value this is still not a good practice
because you are doing two obvious thing
and you are trying to overuse your
typescript don't do that this is not a
good practice at all there are some
places where these values or these
annotation can be avoided you can just
simply avoid to have a type for example
in this case just a previous case where
we were having this equal sign
now in this case whenever I use number
let's just say I go ahead and say number
and I use a DOT
not number actually my bad the user ID
and I and then I use a dot let's just
say to fix and this is the method that
I'm using now if I hover on to the two
user ID it's obviously telling me that
it's a number and whenever you are
actually defining any number and you are
just immediately assigning a value it
typescript is smart typescript can
actually infer that you are actually
trying to put a number in it and you
don't need to do this but hey what's the
point we were obviously doing the same
thing in the JavaScript as well but no
my friend there is a difference with it
here typescript is smart enough to
automatically detect that you want to
place a number in it so that's why the
value automatically is going to be
assigned so it is too redundant to just
write a type in front on it and don't
you worry there will be future videos
well I'll walk you through where this is
compulsory that you should be using it
as a good practice and where things
where you can actually avoid it so in
this case this I prefer as a better code
compared to anything else like put up a
colon because it is too obvious maybe
you want to have two with safety have it
no problem at all but in this case types
of typescript is already smart enough it
will still detect it that it's a number
and if you try to do something which is
not really great something like you try
to sign a value it will still give you
some errors that hey you're doing
something that you shouldn't be doing it
is a type of string it is a type of
number which I already deduced and you
are trying to assign a string onto it so
yes all these values still come up it so
remember in order to write better code
it's not just always you follow these
columns and I see a lot of people just
follow these columns and these types
just in the start of the file that hey
everything should be named and filed no
this is not how typescript work and this
is not the good practice of the
typescript that should be worked
typescript is a little bit more of a
complex subject and that's exactly why
we are exploring this one up here now
again you now you understand about the
type inference that JavaScript that
typescript is smart enough to get all
the values and if you are just assigning
immediately yes this is still a
typescript you don't need to put call on
every here and there in the entire
typescript file in order to get output
of that we can simply go ahead up here
and simply say TSC
variables.tsc uh variables me dot TS and
this still will guess uh get a get us
all the values remember again
the syntax of colon Boolean is a
typescript syntax so whenever a
JavaScript compiled file is going to
come in it's never going to be a colon
or the value I hope you get the idea I
hope you got the best practice as well
that you shouldn't be doing too much
obvious thing yes there is a special
place where you put columns and the type
of it I'll walk you through with that so
now that we have gone through a little
bit with the documentation along with me
let's go ahead and explore typescript a
little bit more in the next video hope
you have already subscribed doesn't feel
look really good to again and again
asking but hey 70 of you is not
subscribed so go ahead hit that
subscribe and let's catch up in the next
video
hey there everyone that I share back
again with another video and welcome to
the typescript series now before we move
ahead in this video hit that subscribe
because 70 of audience is not subscribed
anyways let's move into the any keyword
now this is mostly the usual keyword
which people used to get away from the
syntax of typescript I've seen many
people using typescript but still
exhaustively using any this is not a
good practice and I'll walk you through
from the documentation that it is
written there it is not a good practice
first let me give you a brief scenario
overview that where people actually use
it and where you shouldn't be using it
so let's just say you're trying to
declare a variable and you don't know
what to place inside this variable so
you just call it as hero right now you
have no idea right now that this
variable is eventually going to turn
into a string or a Boolean or anything
as a matter of fact what you do after
some time you declare a simple function
which calls it as simply get hero and
this get hero just returns you a hero so
let's just say a hero is being returned
as a thought or now later on you decide
that hey I want to have this hero and
this hero will get the values from by
calling this method as get hero and we
run this method now if we go ahead and
simply hover over this value we can see
that this is being inferred as any which
is really a bad case you really want to
avoid these cases now right now this
typescript file has no idea what to
infer the value and I'll walk you
through the documentation that the
official documentation says that when in
such situation where typescript cannot
find out that what value is going to
come up later on in the future it puts
that as any which is a kind of a get
away from doing the things and that is
exactly happening up here that it is
just saying that hey this is any it
could be uh this could be a simple
string right now still it is any but
there is nothing which is stopping me to
return a true and this is still
accepting the value which is not really
good case maybe just imagine you have
declared these values and you are
getting these values but there is
another developer who is working on the
API call and instead of just giving you
a string based on which your entirety of
your program is dependent he has just
returned here true or maybe just a
status code this is not good this
actually breaks the consistency of the
code so in this case we have this string
so the ideal case would be remember in
the earlier time I told you that in the
earlier case in such scenario the
automatic inference of the values like
string and Boolean is not good in these
a special scenario I would love to have
the simple string that hey now please
infer the value as a string so whenever
the values are going to come whether
through an API call or whatever you're
doing it should always be inferred as
string now if I go ahead and another
programmer who is writing this now if it
goes as and says true automatically you
get an error that hey it was supposed to
be a string but now it is being returned
as a Boolean which is not good so you
shouldn't be doing that now let me walk
you through with the documentation
because that is the most important part
of this video so here's the
documentation and you can see in the
document annotation there is any and
there is also no implicit any yes the
any actually is a gateway and it tells
you that any can have actually anything
at all that you want to have so that
whenever you don't want a particular
value to cause the type checking so
that's when you use any now notice this
very carefully any is not a special type
that you are assigning it's not a string
it's not a Boolean any is simply a
marker in the typescript which just
simply says that hey I don't want to do
the type checking for it basically turn
off the type checking for that
particular value you don't want that
otherwise while you're using typescript
the most important line is just here
you usually want to avoid this because
any isn't type checked use the compiler
flag no implicit any to flag any
implicit any any as an error so one more
thing we have learned that there is a
setting in the TS config file that we
can go for no implicit any that will
allow us to not fall into such thing
which is any so I hope this video gives
you a clarity about when to use any when
not to use any yes there might be one or
two cases but really you don't want to
use any in any of your code it is not a
good practice you are avoiding all the
strictness that typescript brings to
your code so I hope this video has given
you a clarity about any but the most
important another thing here is the
function shouldn't be defined like this
the function should have more value so
that stricter check or definition that
hey you cannot return a Boolean value
you should always be returning a string
value so from the next video onwards
we're going to study about how functions
are defined using typescript let's go
ahead and catch up in the next video
till then hit that subscribe and I'll
catch you up in the next one hey there
everyone headaches here back again with
another video and welcome to the
typescript series I'm pretty sure that
you have already heard about the
functions either in JavaScript or
typescript but I'm pretty sure that a
lot of you don't know what should be the
mindset behind using the functions in
the typescript there are a couple of
ways that should always be running in
your mind and don't worry we will not be
dragging this topic around for a
thousand videos there will be just two
videos this one and the next one and
we'll be covering end-to-end functions
in that so after watching these two
videos you'll be all comfortable with
handling any types of functions in
typescript so let's get started I've
created a new file up here which is
saying simple console log and let's go
ahead and try to create a function we'll
be creating basically three or four
functions which will give you eventually
the whole idea and the picture and
scenario which you should be worried
about first of all it's really clear
that first function that I want the goal
behind it is I want to add a two value
to it so obviously I should be taking
input as a simple number and let's go
ahead and try this out so let's just say
if I go ahead and say hey I want to add
a two so I'll be taking input as number
and that's pretty much it and at the
time of returning it I'm going to go
ahead and say hey whatever the number
you are taking just go ahead and add two
to S pretty simple nothing wrong in that
now if I go ahead and work on with that
if I go ahead and try to add to this I
can go ahead and say hey I want to add 2
to the value 5. nothing wrong in it
absolutely they say but here comes the
problem the problem in the typescript
the problem which comes up in the
typescript and by the way please excuse
my system it has been heavily loaded for
the live classes and a whole lot of
other things so it might run a little
bit slow so we have to wait a little bit
to see the errors now notice here the
first important thing is in this add to
function if I hover this we see any and
any is a problem in typescript whenever
there is an inference of what should be
the data type it is usually good in the
case of variables but in the case of
functions not so good so in this case
notice here the function add to accept a
number which is any which is problematic
the reason why it is problematic is
because I can simply go ahead and come
to here number and can I simply go ahead
and assign values like to uppercase
which I shouldn't be allowed to do and
right now I'm allowed to do so and even
if I run this file because my system is
a little bit slow today so if I go ahead
and run this one
I'm allowed to do so although this is
creating a problem that hey this is a
duplicate function so obviously this is
the error we will talk about later on
right now let's go ahead and Export this
save this and there we go so I can run
this code again and this produces a fine
JavaScript no problem at all but I
shouldn't be allowed to do this because
if I just go ahead and convert this 2
into an uppercase that becomes a string
not a good idea so that is one problem
that I'm facing another problem that I'm
facing is if I go ahead and convert this
five like this it still works shouldn't
be working there the whole idea of the
typescript is to have a stricter type so
that we make less mistake and the fellow
coder who are working with us makes less
mistake so in this case let's go ahead
and work on and try to fix that now the
fix is really easy I can go ahead up
here and can say that hey whatever the
value you are going for make sure that
the value that comes to you is always
going to be the number now automatically
typescript is giving me a problem that
hey hey whatever you're trying to do
this is not good this is this is not
allowed so please don't do this always
pass on a number to us so now this kind
of a 5 in the strings is not allowed and
go ahead and stop that now since you
have written the function definition
with the number being accepted like that
I cannot do Mischief things like I can
go I cannot go ahead and say Hey you
cannot go ahead and say hey to uppercase
and go like this no no you are not
allowed to do whoever is the creator of
this function or designer of the
function in your entire group has said
that this function needs to take input
as a number so that is why we're 100
sure that we when we add a 2 to is it is
possible in operation we don't need to
do extra check we don't need to run the
conditional that hey if the number is a
number then go ahead and do it otherwise
return an error message that hey please
pass on the number no you're not not
supposed to do all of that so this is
all good okay this is the basics of it
let's try to wrap this up with one more
type of the things so another thing
another function that I want to have is
a really a simple method in which I want
to just have some string so let's go
ahead and have this one so let's just
say you are you were not aware about the
two uppercase methods so you want to
just go ahead and say I want to have a
function which says get upper so what it
does is convert any string into
uppercase values similar to that you go
ahead and say hey give me a value I go
up here and say Hey I want to return
whatever the value you get I'm going to
go ahead and put a two uppercase onto
this one to uppercase now again
I got no suggestion first of all that is
bad probably my compiler is slow that
could be an acceptable case but here in
this case since this value if I go ahead
and look onto this one this is any any
is again wrong and if I go ahead and say
hey let's just say get upper I go up
here and say hey this upper is going to
get a value something like this
obviously this is problematic here right
now squiggly lines are there it is
telling me hey dude you're doing wrong
you need to pass on one compulsory
argument so I can go ahead and pass on
four it's happy and you know why it is
Happy it shouldn't be happy it should be
mad at us because the value should
always be strings so in this case the
type annotation is really really strong
I told you in the earlier videos in the
case of variables it's optional it
infers the type pretty nicely so there
is no problem in the case of function it
is really compulsory let's go ahead and
move on and now it gives me a problem
that hey dude whatever you're doing with
four nope you shouldn't be doing that in
case you want to convert this in
uppercase either pass me on 4 like this
that is acceptable that is doable or
just pass on like this that is also
doable that is how you are using I'll
convert that okay moving on quickly and
fastly don't want to drag down the
tutorial okay
let's just say I create another function
which is going to be simply a sign up so
I'm going to go ahead and say sign up
user so let's just sign up the user now
for this one particular one I'll just
define the definition like this and I
want to have couple of more parameters
in this case at the time of sign up of
the user let's just say I'm going to ask
him for a name and I'm going to go ahead
and ask him for email and I'm going to
ask him for password pretty common thing
you have seen this thousand time now
while this is particularly bad in this
case because I can simply go ahead and
say hey I'm going to go ahead and as
have a user sign up if I go ahead and go
like this obviously it complains that
hey there are squiggly lines so that
means you have to pass on but all of
them these are marked again as any
although there are three parameters this
time but they are being marked as any so
I can go ahead and say hey one two three
you should be all happy because it's any
and that defeats the purpose of having a
typescript so in these cases also
individually and this is the syntax how
you do it this one is a string and this
one is also going to be a string and
since everybody is a string let's change
this one so this is going to be is paid
so just to have a flavor of it this is
going to be a Boolean so in this case we
are going to go ahead and have a Boolean
value pretty simple pretty easy so this
is now right now in our function body
there is nothing in it but you get the
idea you have watched the JavaScript the
code part and everything you can write
that this is a series more about
focusing on the typescript so now we see
this quickly line complaint but other
guys are not complaining and this is the
one thing I absolutely like about the
typescript so fix one error at the time
this is updated in the recent version of
it so I go ahead and say Hey you need
name I'm going to go ahead and give you
a name uh probably my name then it says
hey this is also incorrect uh argument
is number but it should be a string so
let me go ahead and change this one so
let me go ahead and say hitesh at
lco.dev and this one also needs to be a
Boolean so is it a paid user nope it is
a freebie so there we go now it is all
good and okay now one more thing that I
want to cover in this video quickly is
another method and then I'll tell you
about the problem so let's go ahead and
actually use different kind of function
this time and arrow function so let's
just say we're going to have a simply
let
and this time login user and we can just
go ahead and use the arrow function the
definition remains same so I won't be
writing anything inside the curly braces
but the value which we are worried about
is how to take the input let's just try
to have simply email and is paid let's
just say these are the things so I'm
going to go ahead and worry about email
probably a name Also let's just say name
email
and again is paid we are using same
parameters now this is good this is good
there is no problem here but let's just
say I only want to pass on two values
obviously these kinds of cases will come
up here so in the name I can go ahead
and say hey this is going to be a string
the email is going to be a simple string
and the paid is going to be a simple
Boolean but one syntax that might
confuse you how can I pass on default
values let's just say in the case of
login user I want to use this and I want
to Simply pass on just two things maybe
name and email so name is going to be h
and the email is going to be H at the
rate h.com I wish I got that domain uh
but I don't want to pass on other values
now when I save this one notice here
login user it is not giving me any
complaints as of now uh let me go ahead
and try to run this one
and there we go I told you my system is
little slow today but just giving the
idea that yes this is paid is a
compulsory thing it needs to be there
and one way you can have an avoidance of
this one is simply by providing a
default value the syntax goes first you
annotate it colon and then the data type
and then you simply go ahead and say hey
this is going to be false by default and
now the system is happy not because it
is slow it is truly happy I can go ahead
and run the code and I can see that hey
this was all okay and this is the brief
overview of it and yes it generates the
equivalent of the same exact almost same
code but notice here uh some code was
generated a little bit more in the login
user this is the most important part
where we should be focusing a little bit
now obviously this is generating a VAR
as a keyword we can update the TS config
and learn about that later on please
ignore that as a moment and right now we
can see that there is a name email and
is paid and we are looking for a
conditional check if is paid is void
then it is zero otherwise false you get
the idea typescript help us to write a
little bit of a cleaner code as a
stricter code in that case so this is
all about it but one thing still is
remaining which is hey if you look at
this example closely add to is a number
that is great and fine and maybe we're
holding that value and further doing an
operation so for example let my value
that is going to be holding by add to
and I'm expecting that the value is
going to be added to 2 so 7 value but
what instead of this I go ahead and
return not just like that so let me just
comment this out and I go ahead and
return a simple something like hello
nobody is stopping me doing that so we
need to learn that okay this is
completely stored and completely fine
and yes my system is not slow this
actually is allowed right now so we need
to worry about one more thing about the
functions which is how can I return more
accurate value and that's going to be
coming up into the part two of the
typescript function go ahead hit that
subscribe button I'll catch you up in
the next video
hey there everyone today is here back
again with another video and welcome to
the typescript series so in this series
we have already discussed a tiny bit
about the functions in the last video
and as I promised this is going to be
the final video on the promises and
you'll have enough of the knowledge of
how to handle functions now the
typescript revolves all around the types
and you will be learning a lot about the
types as we go further it's not like
just these are the Primitive types these
are the types that's all you go ahead
and do with that it's more about the
philosophy of how you use the types
where it is necessary where you can
avoid them and all of that that is what
we are going through with this series
remember typescript is just a superset
or a wrap around the JavaScript that
allows you to write better JavaScript so
I hope you have watched the entire
series or playlist and in case you
haven't yet go ahead hit that subscribe
button and let's go ahead and get
started with that so taking you again on
to my computer screen so this is what we
have done in the last video now while
discussing all of this in the last video
we noticed that we were returning
instead of a number just by adding to it
we were returning hello and this was not
giving me any problem at all and this is
a point of concern for me especially try
to always imagine whenever you're
learning typescript always imagine that
this is not just you who is writing the
code this is a team of 20 or maybe 30
developers who is writing the deity of
the code you define some function maybe
somebody wants to add his own
functionality of the function and now if
he's going to do such things like return
hello obviously this will break your
entire application because there are
probably 1000 use cases of this simple
method which are dependent of returning
a number to it but since you changed
that and you're returning a string that
can crash your entire application it is
a little bit debug to handle the things
in 20 or 30 or maybe 40 developers of a
team so that is why typescript is being
used in the function so obviously this
is making a problem but typescript is
not giving me any error or at all so
that is why we have learned about that
at the time of taking the input we can
annotate it with by whatever the type
you want to accept and similarly you can
just put a column and can say that hey
this is add to this is supposed to
return me a number now as soon as I do
this this will allow me to not do such
things which is just a Mischief activity
that hey instead of returning a number
why are you returning as simple hello
which is a string you shouldn't be doing
that so I can comment this out and I can
remove this comment and I can say that
this is happier now much more happier
this saves me ton of time and my team's
time to make right and write productive
code and make better softwares okay
moving on let me talk and discuss a
little bit more about the functions and
then we'll I'll redirect you on to the
documentation to understand that yes
there can be more with the functions but
this much of the knowledge is enough
good enough okay
moving on so let's just say first and
foremost let's talk about some of the
functions which are going to be like
this and again we'll talk about them
little bit later on right now just want
to give you a brief overview of this so
for example let's just say there is a
simple function which says get value
there is nothing wrong in it and in this
one you simply say hey give me a my
valve just like this and this could be
anything number string doesn't really
matter let's take our example with the
number itself now you're doing some
conditional check maybe just with the if
condition something like this if my Val
is greater than 5 then I would like to
Simply go ahead and say hey I would love
to return something like true maybe
there's a use case scenario for you in
this one otherwise if that's not the
case you are going to go ahead and say
hey return a status code maybe you're
building a web application which says
200 okay now in this case obviously our
first theory is not really applicable
because if we go ahead right now you can
see if you get hover on this one this
says hey this is giving some hint that
it can be either a true or can be a
string but we are not implicitly
mentioned explicitly mentioning uh that
it can be a simple let's just say if I
do head and string then this gives me a
problem if I go ahead and say hey this
is a Boolean then this gives me a
problem so we haven't yet learned about
the type where we can return more than
one type so just want to give you a
brief overview that these kinds of
scenarios will happen these are part of
functions but we have to learn a little
bit more about typescript in order to
handle these situation not really
complex it's just a union type and we'll
discuss on that in a separate video so
just giving you that yes this could
happen this is one of the case Okay
moving on uh there are a couple of more
things that you can do for example that
may take another example so that you can
take these code file as a note one so
let's just say there is simply a hello
and this is a simple method or let's
just use a arrow function method third
because I think you would also love to
know that if here we can put up a colon
and number what is the syntax of doing
the same thing in the arrow functions as
well so this is how our basic Arrow
function works we have written that many
time so inside here we take all the
parameters like for example you want to
take a string as parameter you can do
that just after these parentheses you
can put up these column and can say hey
I'll return a pair string as well now as
soon as I do this this actually gives me
a problem that hey functions whose
declare type is neither wide nor any
must return a value so this is giving me
a problem that hey you're not returning
me a value so your code is actually
wrong so in this case if I go ahead and
return even an empty string this is just
working out so this is the basics of how
you do it in an arrow function I hope
you are getting this I hope you are
enjoying this if yes hit that subscribe
and a like would be really awesome
otherwise let's continue There is no
problem at all okay one more thing I
would like to discuss about this is uh
some some values something like this so
let's just say we have some Heroes and
you know what Heroes I'm about to use
you know me I'm a big Marvel fan and a
DC fan also so let's just say we have a
Thor we are gonna go with Spider-Man and
we are also going to go with uh Iron Man
so we have a list or an array in which
there could be numbers there could be
string or something like that now one of
the great advantage of using the
typescript is it knows really so much
out of the box for example this is a
common scenario we do this in like
thousand times in JavaScript if there is
an array we go ahead and loop through it
by using a map if I go ahead and use a
map I'm actually looping through each of
the hero and then I go ahead and use a
callback and I can probably say simply
hey I'm going to return a simple uh
string something that's going to say a
hero is oops
hero is and then let's use a variable
which is going to be something like this
and let's just go ahead and have a hero
so this is a really simple code nothing
magical out of the box but if I hover
over to this Heroes and this map
function even here you can notice that
this is giving us so much of the
definition and Advantage I don't have to
call anything it automatically predicts
that hero is going to be a type of
string because this array is of type of
string but if I go ahead and duplicate
this and let's call this one as let's
comment out this one
and instead of having a Thor let's just
go ahead and say that this is one this
is two
and this one is three so typescript all
I wanted to show you is typescript is
smart enough if I hover over this it
automatically changes this hero to a
number so it is aware of the context
that is coming up in here right now if I
go ahead and comment uncomment this one
comment this one it automatically
switches its thing into Strings so the
hero is a string in this case so I can
avoid an additional step that hey
whatever the values that are coming up
from this one I don't have to explicitly
annotate that this needs to be always
string perfect syntax I can go ahead and
work on with that but as you know the
the context switching of the typescript
is really smart and we can rely on this
one so there is no problem in that so in
this case uh yep it's good I'm happy
with this one but the one thing which
you should be really careful is what is
the return type of this method so in the
map it is expecting that hey you are
returning up this string here but
instead of this there might be a case
where you want to return in every case
too that is also allowed and that is
also valid that's why the map has such a
detailed information that is given to
the typescript that hey what is the
value you want to return in this case it
could be 2 or it could be a previous
value in this case especially I would
love to return that what is the type of
the value that we are returning in this
one again we could do it like this and
then we can say hey the values that I'm
returning is going to be simply a string
there we go this is much more of a
readable and reliable code so when I go
ahead and say hey in every case I'm
going to go ahead and do one it stops me
from doing this so good practice that we
should all follow that hey don't do such
thing yes you can avoid that input it
will automatically deduce what is coming
up from the array but this is a better
syntax especially for when you're
writing the code in the team so this is
a better syntax okay
this is the basics uh now coming up on
to the final part of the function where
we actually will move into the
documentation this will actually Force
us to move into the documentation so
let's just say there is a function we
are defining and there are two types of
function the first one is simply saying
console error so the idea behind this
method is whatever is being passed waste
you just go ahead and log it to console
so let's go ahead and log it to the
console obviously we have to take a
error message so let's go ahead and call
this one as error message
that is a type of string that is being
given to us and we are just going ahead
and saying hey just go ahead and print
this error message into the console log
a very common scenario which you do
while building the web application and
the initial phase now if I hover this
one it says Hey the console error the
message it's taking is in the string
format but the colon after this is void
that means it's not returning anything
so yes this could be the thing but
another this is not a good practice
especially if you're using typescript
the good practice is to explicitly
mention that hey whoever is using this
function he knows more about the
definition of function that this is
returning a void that means it's not
going to return anything ever so
accidentally it just says that hey if I
go ahead and say I'm going to return 1
as error message now you don't you
shouldn't be doing that and again this
might look like hey that's very easy
it's easy because you are just alone
coding right now watching a YouTube
video but imagine when you'll be writing
code with along 15 developers or maybe
50 developers alongside with you okay
the same thing could be replicated one
more type another method that you will
be handling a lot or writing a lot is
handle error so this handle error
obviously this is handling the error
this is not going to be returning a void
because it handles the error so let me
go ahead and copy some lines from the
documentation directly because this is
something which is coming up from
documentation I'm not making this up so
just like we have all these things in
the documentation under the more
functions this is written as never some
functions never returns a value neither
it's void because void is means return
nothing but there is never as well which
never returns a value that simply means
the function never returns a value I
know this is very close to the void but
this is specially made so that you can
handle some kind of error because this
is kind of a intentional crash that we
are doing to the function for having
this so in these kinds of cases I can
just copy this line and I can go back
onto the code and instead of the console
logging the things I can just go ahead
and say Throw new error and whatever the
error message I am just passing on I am
handling this gracefully so if I go
ahead and put this as a void which is
not a good thing if you want to make
your errors more robust and handling
part of it just use never which is again
recommended in the guidelines of the
typescript if I hover this again it says
the return type is never and error
handle is declared but its value is
never read that's fine but you get the
idea from where this is coming up again
I'm not pulling this out from the thin
air or out of a hat like a magic this is
mentioned in the documentation the never
type represent value which are never
observed in the return type it means
that the function throws an exception or
terminates execution of the program so
forceful termination of the program
never also appears when typescript
determine there is nothing left in a
union union will talk about that later
on that's a subject later on but you get
the idea how to read the documentation
and how to find out the actual Source
from where this is coming up I hope you
are enjoying this the valuable series up
here and again I'll wrap this all the
source code from now onwards I'll put
them into the dashboard as a community
session which is a free segment here at
ineuron you can go ahead and download
them so you can have that and again the
most important part is not just the
source code that I'm giving you the most
important part is the mindset that I'm
trying to give you with these videos so
you can write better piece of softwares
that's it for this one let's catch up in
the next video if you really think that
just by adding typescript you have
removed all the bad behavior of
JavaScript that is not the case my
friend there are some still odd
behaviors even in typescript maybe in
the future version they will go away but
still we have a lot of misbehaves or
JavaScript still existing in typescript
I'll show you one here hey there
everyone hitesh here back again with
another video and let's go ahead and get
started with the typescript series
before that hit that subscribe button
and the bell icon as well I would be
really really happy with that now that
assuming that you have hit that
subscribe icon come on guys 70 of you
haven't did that okay I assume that you
have hit that now let's go ahead and
walk through with the objects now again
I won't be consuming too much of the
videos like I won't be releasing 14 or
15 videos on just objects on typescript
we'll walk through with the most
important part of it enough that you can
get started with that so there will be a
couple of videos on object let's go
ahead and get started with this one and
I'll walk you through how objects are
there and what are the places where it
can misbehaves a little bit and your
code might actually get compromised with
that so let's go ahead and walk you
through with that so how does the object
works the objects are really simple we
use them all the time in JavaScript as
well so maybe you want to make an entry
in the database you collect all the
values in the object format and you pass
on this object to maybe a back-end
controller it modifies all the things
and adds an entry in the database that
is the most common use case scenario for
example let's just say I want to create
a simple user so this is how go ahead
and create an object of a user and I'll
just add more values to it so for
example if I go ahead and say hey this
is the name so whenever I'm adding a
value or a user to my database I'll say
hey this is a name then we got an email
so let's just say hitesh at lcr.dev
another email and I'll also say that if
this is active or not so I'll say if
this is an active account or not means
people are regularly using it so this is
a basic object and yes typescript syntax
is exactly same and that is where you'll
be using it most but this is not the use
case of the object designing an object
like this doesn't really make sense and
you won't be using it too much the use
case of the object is through the
functions you have to actually pass on
these objects into a function or you
have to return some objects through the
function that is the most common use
case that we use while developing any
application so let me walk you through
with how these are done so for example
let's just say we are creating a method
which says create user and this is a
simple method now since this is a forgot
the keyword so function so this is a
very basic method that we have now this
method expects that you will be passing
me some of the user so the very first
syntax is you pass me an object and I'll
Define that at least give me a name and
that name is going to be a type of
string and give me another one which is
let's just say is active or
is Google auth
what should I do is paid here's paid
okay let's let's go with that and that
will be a Boolean so this is the very
basics of it that we have got let me
just go ahead and move this up there we
go so this is the most basics of that we
have now well whatever we return the
value we'll discuss on that you can
return an object obviously that is the
most basic part and the obvious part of
it now what it allows us when you have a
definition like this then the method
becomes a tiny bit more secure so for
example when I say hey I want to create
a user I want to use that typescript
actually stops me for doing that and
looks like it is not stopping me
probably my
system is a little slow so let's just go
ahead and say TSC and I'll say my
objects let's go ahead and run that and
there we go we saw an error that create
user cannot be used like this so let me
just go ahead and try that hey why are
not let's try go back up here and come
here no no error threads but you get the
idea that this is actually stopping me
from doing all these things and how can
I actually get rid of this by passing on
an object ah by the way why this is
stopping me to doing so because probably
I forgot to export so actually we can we
always have to do we'll come back on to
this part that why we are actually doing
this because this exporting of the
objects is really helpful in this case
as well I will definitely
have those values so please cancel that
and we'll be exporting that probably
this will start giving me the errors
there we go we got the errors I'll
definitely discuss this part as well as
we move into the react part or maybe
angular part of it that how this
actually works will surely take care of
that now right now the important part is
that when we say create user it stops me
from doing this so there we go we can go
ahead and use an object now it's
complaining me that hey the object that
you have defined that is exactly the
same which is I'm expecting from this
method to give me but the syntax or the
following must have variables are
missing or properties so in this case I
have to say name and the name is going
to be let's just say I'm creating a user
with the name hitesh that is fine but
still I'm missing one which is is paid
so I'm going to go ahead and say is paid
and we'll be saying this is a free user
on the platform so this is a pretty
obvious behavior that we have and this
is now probably trying to have my code
in a much better way so this is the most
basic of it and you can actually add a
lot more things on top of this maybe you
also want to Define and while the syntax
which actually makes people a lot
confusing is what happens when a
function actually returns an object so
that is the most confusing of all so
let's just say you are not creating a
user you are creating a course in this
time so let's just call this as create
course now this is obviously a function
so let's go ahead and say function and
this is an object now this is a return
type and
there we go and this is actually a
definition
there we go now this is a bit of a weird
syntax we forgot a colon there now what
this is saying is that hey
um this is a function name this is a
function parameter where you pass on
this is a return type and this is a
definition so yes uh there is a lot
there is a lot confusing up here the
reason why it's complaining is simply
because you have promised that you will
return an object and you are not
returning anything so obviously you have
to go ahead and return this one this one
is happy now but in case you have a
special syntax that I should be
returning some things like this so you
can actually go ahead and make it like
this so any course that you are having
is going to have a name and the course
should have a price again fictitious
scenario and this should be a number now
obviously this will complain this is a
better definition of function in case
you are having that hey this should
return me obviously always and always an
object which should have these two
properties so whenever I'm going ahead
and returning anything from the function
it promotes a good practice and less
error that hey you should be returning
the name for example this course name is
react.js and the price is going to be
let's just say uh 399 something like
that whatever the price is so this is
the basics of it and now you know the
syntax and the weirdness this is the
only thing which I have seen a lot of
people get confused about that what
happens when an object returns an object
yes I do agree this is a little bit of a
weird syntax because we have parenthesis
then Colin and then this is an object
and the definition and it gets a little
bit more confusing when you have the
object in this format because it's
returning these things and then so these
kinds of definition makes people a
little bit confusing now what is the odd
behavior regarding the objects which
comes up in the typescript okay that is
that is something really bad okay let me
show you where the bad syntax actually
comes up
so notice this
that this is a name and this is a it is
paid so my function is saying that Hey
whenever you create a user you give me a
name and is paid that is obvious but
let's just say while creating user I
also want that email should also be
there so I can just go ahead and say hey
let's give it an email and the email is
going to be H at the rate h.com
something like that now this is not
acceptable and there's a long big thread
on the stack Overflow by the way on this
Behavior so obviously this is not
allowed because in the definition we
have strictly mentioned that this should
be there yes there are ways I'll walk
you through in the upcoming videos there
are ways how we can actually make this
email as optional if you pass them
that's good if you don't pass it that's
also fine but what is the odd behavior
is that this is an object so I can just
cut this out obviously this is
complaining so let's just say I go ahead
and say hey let a new user we create a
variable and we simply assign that as an
object obviously we do this lot of time
in the JavaScript as well that whatever
and from wherever we collect the
information like payment information
comes from a different model or
controller or maybe a Google
authentication also gives us some
information so all these information are
combined an object is being created and
whenever we call these kinds of methods
we just pass on this value here so for
example a new user is being passed on
and you might have noticed this time I
was able to pass on much more
information than what is expected in the
function definition previously it was
giving me error but now this is all okay
so yes not all weirdness of JavaScript
is gone but there is a better way of
defining the functions and the methods
we'll learn about that when we'll walk
through with the interface and all of
that that are the beautiful most
beautiful part about the typescript
we'll walk through with that so I hope
that now you know some of the weird
behavior of this one this is a common
method in case you have watched my mind
course or any other backend development
we have done this many many time this is
still not stopping me to do any bad
behavior so that is wrong of typescript
it should stop me but I'll walk you
through with the optionals that there
are better ways of handling situations
like this but I think that's going to
come up in the next video so in the
meantime time hit that subscribe and
I'll catch you up in the next video
hey there everyone today is here and
this is a short video all I want to do
in this video is introduce you to the
type aliases and give you a moment so
that you can read some documentation on
your own so that whenever you find out
some tutorial who is talking about
exactly same thing you can say yeah this
is coming up exactly from the
documentation as well and again the
whole idea behind making the short chunk
size bite size videos is so that if you
feel you can consume more than one at a
time instead of pushing out at 12 hours
or 15 hours of content at one given
point of time again let's get started
with the type aliases now type Alias is
a topic which is really really simple
and you don't have to worry about
anything at all I'll walk you through
with the documentation as well we've
already gone through with some of the
scenarios which where we can use it and
this is all what you'll see if you have
watched the previous video this one will
just come like a breeze so moving up
here we have saw that we can actually
create a simple variable which is a user
and we can kind of use that as well but
in the JavaScript we don't actually
create a variables just like this if you
want to support anything like that we
actually go with a different method let
me walk you through because coding is
actually much easier when I show you by
writing the code itself so let's just
say our goal is still same we are
creating a application in which we
onboard a user and user has some of the
properties that we want to go through
with that and maybe this is not just a
one function which uses all the set of
properties but there are like probably
eight different functions which uses the
same of properties now what they do with
that property is that's not our concern
our idea is that whenever somebody takes
up this entirety of eight function
whenever they takes any parameter they
need to get all the information of the
user itself that's the whole idea okay
so let's go ahead and create that the
way how we do it we create a type of it
and yes it's a keyword in the typescript
and we simply go ahead and Define a user
like that really simple it looks like
almost like a constant but this is a
type Alias that we go for now once we
have this user we can Define all the
properties that we want to have but we
don't Define the exact value of it we'd
rather Define what kind of value is
going to come up into that so for
example this one is going to be a simple
string and not a comma
and let's just say email is also coming
up that is also a type of string and is
active is also there which is going to
be a Boolean value so now just assume
there are more properties of it and we
have actually created a type for it now
the advantage of creating a type like
this is it could be really a long and
lengthy one is whenever there are
methods like create user
get user details modify the user we want
all the information to be passed on so
let's go ahead and create a simple
function like this and once we have this
one this is the definition of it now
what I want is if anybody pass me a user
it should adhere to the type of user so
I can go ahead and say hey this should
be a type of user so what we are doing
internally is kind of creating the data
types here or the types in the
typescript so just like we write
something like a number maybe a number
or maybe we can go ahead and write a
simple string similarly now we are
actually allowed to pass on user now
just a side tip yes you can do something
weird things like this and you'll see
this in some example in tutorials stuff
like that that hey you can call the
string and that string could be uh you
can type Ali as a string as
not string actually my string has a
string so wherever you are using now the
string type you can go ahead and
actually say my string again I don't
know why there are so many examples
about that on internet I I find it weird
but yeah it is actually technically
allowed so but I won't see a really use
case of that that why would you rename
this definite default string or Boolean
or something like that maybe there is a
case where entirety of a team don't use
Boolean word and just use the Bool maybe
you want to do that but again there are
use cases for that so now we can see
that there is a user and there is a user
we are not returning anything so anytime
somebody uses a create user he just goes
ahead and say I want to use user he will
be complained that hey there is
something that you need to pass on one
argument that should be of type user so
in this case I cannot just go ahead and
say hey this is my object it will
complain it doesn't match the type of
user so you have to give me all the name
email and is active so let's just say I
give it a name the name is going to be
an empty string then it says hey it is
an email which is also going to be an
empty string and then it says hey give
me is active as well which could be true
or false if I pass on all the values it
is absolutely happy now similar to this
we can also say that Hey whenever you
create this function you obviously
should return something and that return
type of value should also be user so you
get the idea how this is going ahead
further that anybody who uses this
function this function needs to return
that so you have to go ahead and say hey
return and then you have to not only
return the object you have to actually
return all these values so whatever that
values are and whatever your logic says
you have to return that otherwise it
will complain so it's a really good use
case of how the type can be used now in
the real world scenario whenever let's
just say we we are creating a user for
our LMS then obviously this is not it
there are a lot of things that you have
to pass on now what you do with those
things totally up to you your logic but
this is a common thing which is being
used now let me walk you through with
the documentation as well because
documentation obviously always helps to
understand this so into the everyday
types if you look for it here on the
left hand side there are type aliases in
interface yes they are quite confusing
almost like same to each other but this
is the example that are given in the
documentation about type aliases so it's
common that we want to use same types
more than once just I told you maybe
there are eight functions eight
functions which are using the same type
of user maybe there are 15 values or in
the object or the user so in that case
it can be really really useful all the
internet is filled up with these kinds
of examples where somebody is trying to
create coordinates great example nothing
wrong in that so he's creating a type of
point and whenever somebody a point is
defining you have to pass on x and y
coordinate same example let's just say
we are sending print coordinate you have
to provide PT which is of type point so
it is compulsory whenever somebody is
using print coordinate he has to pass on
all these values and we do not have to
again and again make our function
definition too lengthy that hey you have
to pass on this uh eight different lines
so imagine if this would be Point
instead of the coordinate into two
values it could be a let's just say 16
values and in your function what could
definition would be look like here
really crazy so it's better that in one
file we Define all these types when then
we import them and whenever the function
definition comes up we just call them
hey you need to pass on a value which
should be a point type or maybe a user
type
or maybe something else
so uh there are a lot of values and yes
we haven't yet studied about these or
types or a union type and all of that we
will do that very soon I highly
recommend you at least go ahead and go
through with reading this this won't be
taking more than two to three minutes to
you but you will develop a habit of
reading the documentation so I think the
type LS is all done now let's go ahead
and move on to next video some quirky
behaviors and some real small topics are
there I would like to cover them up in
the next video let's catch up there
all right so in this video we want to
study about just three simple things the
first one is a keyword which says read
only the second one is just a question
mark yes literal question mark and the
third one is a use case scenario that
you will be using a lot with the case of
type not with just ordinary object this
is the most use case scenario so
whenever you'll be looking in the
project being designed by other person
or GitHub repository you're trying to
understand the code you'll find these
kinds of situations a lot so scenario
based let's go ahead and get started
it's pretty easy hit that subscribe and
then we can move forward
yeah this video is powered by AI until
unless you hit the Subscribe it doesn't
move forward so yeah you have to just
kidding let's get started with that so
the same example we are into the my
objects and let's just go ahead and
Define a simple user so we have seen
that I've commented out all the code
that we can actually go ahead and use
and uh type and this is a type that can
be multi-used into functions or maybe
anything else that you're defining so
let's just say there is a name that is
going to come up as a simple string type
so name String and you also have email
that is also a string type and you also
have probably is active so to track that
whether user is logging in into three
days or maybe whatever the parameter is
so in this case now a couple of things
that you'll be using is in case you are
oops my bad sorry okay so that you'll be
using let's just say you are using
mongodb to save this user into database
so you want that nobody should actually
be able to touch this underscore ID
which is a common thing in mongodb so
this is a string now at the time of
creation obviously you will be your
mongodb will be creating that but you
want that nobody should be able to
manipulate that further down the road so
you can go ahead and Mark this as read
only yep that's a keyword you can just
put it onto any one and now you won't be
able to change that so that's a pretty
simple one a really easy one now one
thing I would like to mention here which
is crucial that notice here this ID is a
simple string so for string you won't be
able to change that for or let me just
give you a walkthrough of that let's try
to create a simple user for that let's
just say there is a function which says
create a user and then it says hey just
give me a user
so when at the time of creating this
user let's just say we call this as U
which is type of a user and that's
basically it so nothing big deal this is
a really simple function now whenever
there is a uh which is obviously a type
of user you can access all these values
up here or you know what let's not
create a function actually let's create
a variable because it's easier to show
you this example with the variable so
let's try with variable so let's just
say we call it as my user which is going
to be of type user totally fine and now
in order to make sure that this is a
user type we have to actually assign all
these values this is going to complain
because it's not able to fulfill all
these values so I'm going to go ahead
and say hey let's give it an underscore
ID which should be a type of string so
let's just say this is one two three
four whatever that is also we have to
provide a name let's just go ahead and
say this is H Mr H and then we have
email which can also be H at the rate
h.com I wish I would have that email and
uh still complaining because one more
parameter or one more property needs to
be there which is is active let's just
say this is not an active user okay
false and what is still your issue so we
have ID name email and string why is it
complaining it says false is not
assignable to type my bad should be
saying that this is a Boolean okay uh
honest mistake there
all right so we have gone through with
this now what we can do is I can just go
ahead and say hey my user is about to
change its emails so we can access the
email and I can say hey now your new
email is something like H at the rate
gmail.com you are totally allowed to do
so but in case you want to access
something like my user dot underscore ID
you should not be allowed to change that
so you if you just try to sign anything
to it then obviously it will complain
that this was marked as read-only you
should not be doing this so this is one
of the use case of Whenever there is a
read-only keyword that is coming up but
maybe you also want to have some of the
things like user has registered by UPI
or maybe some credit card details so
obviously we know not every person has
credit card so we are gonna say credit
card details this is going to be a
simple number now obviously not all the
user bad number there we go so we
obviously know that not all users are
going to have credit card details we
also allow allow some users to come on
our website and have free access to the
platform so this could be marked as
optional so all you have to do is come
up and put up a question mark here now
this will not complain if you pass on
that detail that's great it will be
utilized otherwise you can just put a
question mark yes I do agree when you
first time are learning about the
typescript this question mark before the
colony is a little bit weird syntax but
over the time it will get over so this
is the really easy use case that we have
in the card details and all of that so
you get the idea this will not allow you
to complain and by the way a little bit
more to surprise you not surprised you
actually give you more in depth of the
detail let me comment this out so that
we can successfully actually compile
this into typescript so that will give
you a lot idea so TSC this one is my
objects and if I go ahead and run this
this creates an object file but I hope
you can see that now we are exporting so
much so we are exporting es module ID is
there and all of these details are there
notice here there is nothing which which
is depicting in the JavaScript that hey
you are allowed to modify this ID or not
but the moment I uncomment this code now
this is giving me an error now notice
typescript will stop me from doing a lot
of things in my object notice here there
is nothing still and we have we are
working just on the properties or the
config file of the typescript that will
allow me even in the future it will
allow me to stop producing that code but
there is nothing in the JavaScript which
actually stops you that so this is a
pure function or a feature of the
typescript itself so just make sure you
remember that part okay now one more
thing I would like to mention since we
are talking about the credit cards so
this is a scenario we'll build just
based on the credit card
so there are something known as or there
is something known as a mix and match of
uh these types so let's just say we have
a type and first thing that you want to
have is a card number so let's just say
you define that hey card should have a
number and this is how I'm going to
store the number so you just say give me
a number
or I'll say yeah number is number is
actually a keyword so let's call this
one as
a card
number all lower case here and this is
going to be a string it couldn't be
anything and then also you know that if
you are storing the card details the
card number alone is not enough there is
card date as well let's assume that
somebody is storing that date or I'll
call this as card date just to be sure
that is also being stored in a string
format so there are many cases where you
want to Simply store this card number
card detail or card date but you also
realize there is a CVV number
so yes this is a fictitious scenario I'm
making up because there's just one
detail it's easier to explain but in
real world use cases there is this is
too much a big offer type that you have
created so you save a lot of time so in
that case you can go ahead and say that
hey I'm creating a new type and all you
have to do in this type is you can mix
and match of the two above so let's just
say we are saying this as card details
so obviously now we have to compile this
card details with all the things so card
numbers expiry date CVV all is coming up
I know these two are about defined so I
don't have to redefine the things I can
go ahead and say that hey this will be
of type uh being created from the card
number
and then I can use an ampersand sign to
combine them together Ampersand is to
use all of them together not just or
like get this one or get that one and is
for combining all the things so combine
card number and also combine card date
and also I want to give one more because
we didn't caught up with the CVV so I'll
just put up an end and create an object
here we'll say that give me a CVV which
will be of type number
so now if I go ahead and create any
variable or maybe any object using card
details I have to adhere with all the
values up here so this is really really
easy and again right now you're looking
at from the perspective hey there's just
one value here there's not big deal I
could have defined it but imagine the
scenario where project is coming up from
a long list of coders they've already
created couple of types which are doing
absolutely great you just want to
utilize them yes I do agree this object
is a little bit Overkill and not a good
practice at all nobody would advise you
to do such things on the go it looks
very hacky but just wanted to make a use
case this up till here is definitely a
use case where you define a new type
based on the combination of previous two
type so remember both examples are here
the first one is a good example the
first two where you use existing types
which defines another third type by
using the existing functionality there
is also a hacky way of doing the things
which is not a good practice but still
we can do it if we want to so that's it
a really simple way of handling the
situations up here and nothing much of a
big deal so now you know a little bit
more about the typescript than you know
before starting the video so for that
hit that subscribe button and let's
catch up in the next video
arrays in typescript don't have much but
yes behind the scene there is little bit
more to the arrays and if you look and
come up here into the arrays you can see
that's it that's all the array is all
about in the typescript really short
really simple paragraph that we have on
the array but there is a little bit more
of syntax that we can discuss and we
just need one video to understand arrays
in typescript and this is that video so
hit that subscribe button and let's go
ahead and move forward to understand
arrays in touchgrad really simple just
two types of syntax and pretty much
basic let's go ahead and get started
with that I'm pretty sure you have hit
that subscribe I am very sure you have
promised that at least I hope so anyways
let's go ahead and get started with that
let me minimize this and I have created
a new file of course call it as my
array.ts and let's go ahead and try to
create an array so one of my favorite
thing to do with the arrays is have a
lot of superheroes so let's just say if
we have a lot of Super Heroes this is
the syntax how we go ahead and do that
now I've seen a lot of people who go
ahead and go like this that this is an
array and okay maybe you've gone through
this if I hover this this says hey this
is superheroes which is an array of type
never Ah that's interesting what happens
when I try to go ahead and push some
values into this one so if I go ahead
and say hey let's just push a superhero
into this one and let's just call this
one as uh let's push in Spider-Man
spidey it gives me an error that says
hey you are not supposed to do that you
are not allowed to that the string is
not an assignable to parameter type
never Ah that's interesting so remember
we discussed a little bit about the
never in the past so never is something
which is supposed to never execute or
end the things it's it's really one
another use case of never so this is not
how you should be defining it so always
just like we were able to put up a colon
and number we should be actually
defining it like this but this will
still give you an error because now you
have mentioned that hey no matter what
happens uh this superhero is a type of
array but an empty array it should
always be empty because this is what the
definition is saying of your Superman of
your superheroes it says again a string
is not a type it should be never again
so the way how we Define it is simply
saying the superheroes is going to be a
type of a string array yes that's the
basic syntax and yes that's that's all
to the array you can go ahead and say
hey this could be a number this could be
a string yes there is also a type where
you can Define that it can have both
numbers and string we'll discuss that
later on there's a separate video for
that but you get the idea you get the
point this is how you need to Define it
and now you can push any values to it
really simple really basic we can have
more of this let's just say instead of
superheroes uh we want to have something
like superheroes or maybe something like
a hero power where we Define all the
numbers uh this can be a simple number
and I can just go ahead and say I would
like to add hero power and in that I
would like to push on some numbers so
two is absolutely fine so this is the
very basic syntax of how you do it but
there is also one more way which you'll
find in a lot of code bases that that is
also being written let's duplicate that
let's comment this out
so another way of defining this exact
same thing and again there is no good
there is no bad in this case they Define
and represent exactly the same syntax
behind the scene the working is exactly
same there is no like efficient way or
bad way the syntax of Declaration is
really simple you can go ahead and say
array then in the diamond brackets you
can just go ahead and Define number or
any other data type that you have for
example it could be string it could be
number whatever you like to have this is
all the simple basics of it now it's not
like you can have the numbers this is
where the type actually comes up really
handy for example if we have a type of
user you can go ahead and my say that my
user has a name which is a type of
string and also say that this is is
active so our user in the database is
defined of just two values which is a
number a string and a Boolean and not
just numbers and the string you can
actually Define it as simple Boolean as
well and you can say that hey I want to
have all users so let's just go ahead
and Define a simple const call this as
all users because a lot of views are
about to come now just like we Define
something like an array of numbers or a
numbers array and initialize it with the
empty value you can also go ahead and
use something like user now it is very
obvious that whoever the value is going
to come up or whatever the value you
want to push into this array at line
number 10 all you got to do is add the
data type which follows this which is a
type so let's try to push that so we'll
be saying that all users let's push a
value to this one if I go ahead and push
it like the empty one empty string if I
try to push that save this this
obviously will give me error at the
runtime right now sometimes system is
slow so it doesn't give me that values
so let's go ahead and say okay we want
to push an array into this one this is
going to give us a value which is not
really good so let's try to have this
one and again we need to pass on an
object I'm pretty sure this will give me
an error as soon as possible so there we
go now we got there so empty objects are
not allowed because this needs to kind
of follow the protocol that's a correct
word protocol but this is actually this
should be of type user that's all I'm
saying so user has two property the name
which is which can be an empty and is
active that can be simply a true true if
I can write that
so there we go now we are able to push
the values into it so really simple
there's nothing much too complex about
it just two types how you can Define
them really go ahead and do that now
also there is one more way that you
should know about it because maybe you
are using some ml models to it and
there's some complex data type so in
that you are defining numbers or numbers
because when you take a picture the
picture is actually an array of all the
rows and values from python or some
stuff that you actually work on with so
in that case say let's just say you have
a number of array and then further down
you also want to have an array then you
can go ahead and just Define an array
just like this and further down I can go
ahead and come up some values something
like this so this is a coordinate or
maybe a simple pixel values how much RGB
values are there so let's just say 255
comma 255 comma two five five so yes
that is string the way value how you can
add it if I try to add a string it will
complain that hey that's not the data
type string is not a string should not
be there it is supposed to be an array
of array so this is the syntax just
remember that it's really easy numbers
and then we can have array inside that
is so really basic and simple as we will
deal up more with the array just like
you are now feeling more comfortable
with the with the simple variables and a
little bit push values you'll feel more
comfortable with the arrays as we go
further but this is it this is really
the basic as you can see into the
documentation as well there's nothing
too much to Define about it and if I go
ahead at the Top If I go ahead and
search for array there's array there is
a generic object type the array type and
there is a read-only array type as well
so if I go ahead and look for this one
the array type you can see that this is
all the arrays of type string and we can
have the arrays something like that pop
and push the values and numbers and
there's also a read-only array that you
can Define so values read only array
type of string will definitely go
through with these kinds of things later
on I just wanted to make sure that there
is nothing too much in the array just
the basics is here and I think this
video is good enough to get you up and
running and started with typescript and
arrays in typescript let's catch you for
the next video
hey there everyone atheish here back
again with another video and welcome to
another video of the typescript series
we are trying to aggressively move into
the typescript world and I'm trying my
best to push as many videos as I
possibly can so another video in the
typescript series in this video we'll be
talking a bit about the union type and I
really am not looking forward in the
series that I just go ahead give you
what is Union type and that's it I
really want you to write better code in
the JavaScript and that's the whole idea
of the typescript series so I also try
to introduce some of the examples that
we use in the production and that can
help you to write better JavaScript code
with more contextual understanding some
people don't like it some people just
say hey give us the syntax and that's it
for that you could have read any article
or documentation but this is the real
knowledge a lot of people don't like it
probably they haven't written any
production level code but again this is
the way how you should learn with the
contextual understanding and by the way
I've also got a new mic after thinking a
lot I ordered it I am pretty sure those
who are hearing it in headphones or
probably in a good speaker can easily
notify and understand the difference
that we have moved from last video to
this one great one so here we go we have
got a new file which is myunion.ts Union
is a really one of the Fantastic thing
in the typescript which allows you to be
into a situation where you are not
pretty sure what type of data is going
to come in it might be a number it might
be a string but you are not sure it can
be either of the two now instead of
using any I it is highly highly
recommend that you try to use Union type
Union is like a combination of two or
three or more types of data that you can
include into a variable or an array and
whatever that is and this is the only
video you need to watch about the union
I haven't broken down this video into
five different videos in just one single
video it will help you to understand a
lot of context and yes it will help you
to avoid any into your typescript code
so let's go ahead and work on with that
that how it actually works and yes some
of the examples uh are just code based
assuming that you're building any game
or maybe a banking application in
JavaScript so let's just say if we have
a simple score this is how it goes and
you're saying that my score is going to
be 33 that's fine nothing bad nothing
bad no big deal but you are not sure
that whether this is always going to be
a number or it might be some of the
cases that it might be a string as well
I don't know why but it can be possible
so in that case so far we have been
going through and put up an annotation
that hey uh we want it to be a simple uh
number all the time when you do this
this is all fine but you can use a pipe
sign which is just above your Enter key
on the right side and you can use a
string as well
now it is recommended that you try to
keep it very strict as much as strict as
possible because there is nothing that
is stopping you to put up more data type
or in fact list down all the possible
boot uh the data type that is available
in the typescript but use it wisely use
it carefully it can allow you to do such
things which can be really useful for
example here if I go ahead and say hey
this is core
is going to be now 44 that is totally
Allowed no problem at all it can also
allow you to do some things like score
is going to be 55 but this time is a
string 55 if I go ahead and do that no
problem at all if I go ahead and remove
this and I save this yep there is a
problem there is a squiggly line here
that says hey whatever you're trying to
do this is not good so you shouldn't be
doing that but again this is how the
basics of it work hi I noticed that 70
of you haven't subscribed to my channel
it would be really a great motivation
for me if you hit that subscribe button
so go ahead hit that and now let's carry
on with the video now this is not just
the basics of it you can actually use
this Boolean type of this Union type not
Boolean Union type with your own custom
derived data types as well for example
you are building an application which
has a multiple hierarchy of user and
admin and you want to define a strict
type for that so for example let's just
say we have a type of user that we are
defining and user always comes with a
name that is going to be a string and
apart from this we will be having uh
let's just say an ID which is going to
be a number no problem at all let's go
ahead and duplicate this code as well
oops command d
ah come on didn't install the shortcut
for that probably not okay
so this is going to be an admin so let's
go ahead and say this is admin but
instead of having a name this admin has
a username now it could be string it
could be another data type but whatever
that is it's totally allowed to have
this this is a type that you have
defined it's not a literal type that we
see like numbers and Boolean this is the
type that you have defined so we have
two types now let's go ahead and create
a variable for or maybe an object
whatever you like to call this one let's
just say I am defining my name as a
simple uh user but it could also be on
some days an admin or maybe on eventual
future it could be admin we can go ahead
and simply say that oops we can go ahead
and say that hey you since you are a
user you'll be having a name so let's
just say name is going to be my name and
you should also have an ID which is
number so let's just say this is your ID
so there is no problem no problem at all
but eventually in the future I can go
ahead and say that hey now with is going
to act as an admin so he should have a
username instead of this so I'm totally
allowed to just redefine the things for
example I can go ahead and say hey now I
have a username maybe an HC and I also
have an ID maybe I'm using a same ID for
some purpose so 334. this is totally
loud and typescript is not giving you
any problem for that but on the other
hand if you go ahead and try to remove
that hitesh cannot or can never be an
admin then obviously we see that there
could be an error here but if I go ahead
and hit the command Z that it can be
admin or it can have multiple types of
data then it is really really useful now
this kind of a thing could be really
really useful for writing the functions
because sometimes there are situations
that function either accepts multiple
values or sometimes returns multiple
values so the syntax remains same we
have discussed quite a lot about
function but let's just go ahead and
have a simple more discussion about it
let's just say this is get DB ID so you
want to get some database values or some
database ID from here and uh don't know
somebody's passing you an ID there is
more uh like calculated ID in the
database that you are storing so this
could be a simple number uh that
somebody is passing you but it could
also be a string so there could be
multiple ways of how the things can go
up here now in this case if somebody
gives me and I do a simple console log
and I say that
DB ID is and then I simply go ahead and
use this and I say hey just print ID
and here we are making uh some API
calls and you're doing a complex
application and something this is
totally loud this is all good there is
nothing wrong in this one and when we
use this one uh this method now get dbid
I can go ahead and pass on a three here
or I can go ahead and pass on a three
just like this it is accepting all the
values but the problem the problem here
comes up with uh something when you try
to do some manipulation with this one so
let me go ahead and
comment this out first copy this and
comment this out and we'll actually go
up here and paste this up
now notice here uh what I am I will try
to do is I'll remove this one and the
above one I've kept for your purposes so
that you can see what is happening but
let's just say I take this ID and I just
apply at two uh upper or to lower case
lowercase like this uh why the squiggly
line that is the point why is quickly
line because I have told you this is a
string if I go ahead and remove the
number squiggly line goes away but if I
go ahead and put up a number and the fun
part about the typescript is it knows so
much so it if you hover this up it says
property to lowercase doesn't exist on
type string and number so it is treating
uh it is treating it not just as a
number or as just a string it is
treating it as a new data type that
could eventually end up into a number or
a string so both of them are a possible
use case if you remove a number then
it's fine that hey these kinds of
methods do exist but you need to do a
really strong check because right now
notice here the parameter ID could be
string could be number could be really a
problematic so if I go ahead and say
that hey I'll just cut this out I'll
first verify that what is happening so
I'm going to go ahead and say use an if
Clause that if ID or the type of
ID is
equals to let's just say a string
then I go ahead and do this then no
squiggly line and if I go ahead and say
ID dot uh
maybe what what the values of or I can
just go ahead and say ID plus two so it
is totally allowed because it's a number
so it says cannot be applied to type
string so I've already checked it for
string but it could be a number here so
I need to verify that whether this is
actually a number so we can perform the
operations so here this quickly line
goes away and we can check it out
similarly that it could be a number and
then in case of the number then go ahead
and perform the numbers operation but in
case of this is how the lowercase is
then go ahead and just use that so
really the same line of code but if you
go up here the IDE here is or if I hover
on this one notice here it just says now
it is 100 string it's not maybe because
you have put up an if condition and
based on the if condition I'm 100 sure
that if you are reaching this line
number 30 that means you have already
verified and ID is 100
string here but if I go ahead and try to
put it up as number then it knows that
this kind of a block is going to get
enter only in the case when the ID is
actually number so you get the idea that
how this is being done needs to be a
narrowing down of what the number type
is that is basically your union
narrowing and again there's there could
be a lot of discussion around it but you
get the point that you need to check it
and verify the type if you are writing a
better code in the functions of this one
so really a vague example of how to get
the IDS but you get the point of how the
union type is there it's not just simply
a word that hey just add a pipe and do
it it's more about how you implement
those pipe in your code
now with these unions we also can
actually have a small discussion about
the arrays because this is where
actually it becomes a lot more fun so
for example let's just say or let me
just go ahead yeah const is fine so
let's just say we have a data and in
that data we have seen that already if
you want to have all the numbers so we
can just simply say hey we do have
number and this is going to be a number
of array or array of numbers and then we
simply go ahead and say that hey I'll
add up a values like I'll be adding 1 2
3 and let's just say I add a value of a
4. then it's a problematic because you
cannot have strings because it's at a
defined only for numbers so this is
definitely not allowed you cannot do
this and if I go ahead and say that hey
this is going to be a string then
numbers are not allowed you have to wrap
each number with the string so then it
is allowed but and let's just call this
one as data two but if you want to have
both of them then it's an interesting
one so data 3 I don't want string I want
numbers as well so I'm going to go ahead
and say hey pipe and number
and you see no error here uh like there
is a small error but I'll walk you
through what this is this is a classic
mistake that a lot of new typescript
developer does because this is now
saying that hey this is can be either a
string or a number so notice here a lot
of people come up here and say that hey
this and this removes the error this is
a classic mistake this is a classic
mistake the interpretation in terms of
arrays in typescript this is is that it
can be either all the numbers or can
either all the strings so it cannot be a
mix match of let's just say three this
is still not allowed this is not allowed
so it can either be all numbers or all
string the syntax or the way how you do
it is actually you remove this and you
wrap this up inside a parenthesis just
like that and there we go
now you can have both types in your
array you can have strings and you can
have number as well or probably you can
add more as well maybe for some crazy
reason you want to have all the values
as Boolean as well let me just go ahead
and word wrap this there we go now you
can go ahead and add even a true
whatever you like again this is a very
very uh not thing to do but yeah a lot
of people does that and also I've
noticed a lot of people just when these
kinds of situation happen they just go
ahead and do any which is not going to
give you any error but the whole idea of
using the typescript is not just that
here you remove all the squiggly lines
it's about how you are actually making
your types more strict that is the goal
behind that so I hope you remember that
and there is also one more classic
situation let me walk you through that
you can actually allow some of the
numbers to be very strict something like
there's a pie and you want that it
should always be 3.14 and then you try
to allocate the value of you can only
allow to have a 3.14 so later on if you
just try to have a value of a 3.145 or
maybe something it's not allowed so this
is a literal type of assignment that yes
this should only have this value or
something like this this is not a useful
case let me give you a useful case
scenario where this could be really
really useful maybe you're designing an
application for an airplane so let's
just say there's a seat a lot allotment
and you want to have only three types of
value to be coming into this one so you
can go ahead and say there's going to be
an aisle or it can be a middle
or it can be a window
so this is really helpful and useful
case scenario so later on if somebody
goes its head and say seat allotment is
going to be uh I'll that is fine but if
somebody tried to override that with a
seat allotment of let's just say
somebody is giving you a crew seat which
is specifically meant only for crew then
it's not going to allow so yes there are
use cases that it can be only three
types really fast really quick uh can
make your application really secure and
less prone of the error so you get the
idea how this is being used yes we can
have a little bit more discussion about
the union we can go further but I think
all these use cases will help you to
write better code into the JavaScript or
typescript let's go ahead and catch up
in the next video
hey there everyone at this here back
again with another video and welcome to
the typescript series so now let's move
into the typescript segment which is
available only in typescript and not in
in the JavaScript world and this is
known as tuples and tuples there are a
lot of names which people call it I
usually call it as tuples and yes this
is almost similar that is available in
other languages that you might have
heard and seen such as python but here
this is not that much well implemented
and that is the reason why I wanted to
talk a bit about tuples in this video
they are great they are fantastic I'll
tell you a special use case where it can
be used and I'll also tell you where you
should not be using it and where you
should be cautiously using it because
there is a good thread in the stack
Overflow which you should really keep an
eye on which points out some of the not
so good things about the tuples and you
should be worried about that so first
let's see what tuples is and in Broad
category it's just an array a kind of a
specialized array that is given to us by
typescript with some restrictions on
onto it so let's go ahead and catch up
with that one so let's just say there is
a simple user that you want to create so
how we do that we go ahead and say hey
this is going to be a user and maybe
this user is going to be a type of
string an array or array of string and
let's just call this one and let's
initialize this one as simply saying
this one is going to be HC simple like
that
or just a string both are the same so
this is okay this is no problem at all
but let's just say you want that it
should be a string and a number and a
Boolean but in a very precise order that
is the most important thing in a precise
order you don't want that right now if I
go ahead and do this this is obviously
problematic because it's just a string
and if I go ahead and say that hey it
can be either string or a number but an
array so I go ahead wrap this up and I
say and say that hey this can be a
string or it can be a number
number there we go now I can go ahead
and say HC and comma 1 that is fine but
I also can go ahead and say uh one comma
at C that is also fine but there are
cases there are special situations where
you want a specific thing into your
array to be pushed on uh maybe that's an
usually that's a usually an API call
because the API structure data is always
in a very specific format if something
comes up first in the narrate that
always needs to come up at the zeroth
position and something that needs to
come up at second position that always
comes like this so there is no
restriction right now in front of us and
as you know this typescript is all about
putting more restriction in front of us
or on top of that so let's go ahead and
duplicate that so I'm going to go ahead
and come on let's go ahead and duplicate
that
not like that looks like I'm forgetting
the shortcuts okay all right uh there we
go so the one way of doing that is
actually converting that into us into a
tuple so let me go ahead and do that and
how we do that you can go ahead and
simply previously we're writing
everything outside of the array now if I
go ahead and say that hey this is going
to be a string and then it's going to be
a number and then probably it's a
Boolean
so this is all what we have as a user as
of now why are you yelling uh it's
redeclaration uh yeah probably because
in my other files also I'm writing a lot
of users so let's call this one as a t
user or small T user for Tuple user and
we're exporting why are you yelling at
me no worries we'll be saying hey you
are T user so it's never being read so
that's fine now let's go ahead and try
to declare that so we're going to go
ahead and say hey T user and how can I
add value to it I can go ahead and say
the first element Should Be Strings okay
let's just say let's first user or first
value in the array string then we can go
ahead and put up a number let's try one
three one any random number and then I'm
gonna go ahead and say true so these are
the three values that I've added up here
it still is having an issue and again my
pad
come on
let okay now all good so now notice here
there is a strong pattern here that says
a string then a number and then a
Boolean so I cannot reverse this order I
cannot just go ahead and say hey true is
the first element then we are going to
put up some number and then I'm gonna
put up a string here this is this is not
why the Tuple is there Tuple is to make
sure that even not just what is inside
there even the order of the array really
matters in the case of tuples and
especially very helpful in the case of
API calls or maybe there is some
database array which in which the
specific order is there maybe some likes
are there into your array and each of
these likes are being inserted based on
when somebody liked so in that case you
can go ahead and use that and a very
vague example but yes Tuple is all about
restricting you so that you have an
order of the data okay let me go ahead
and walk you through so let me first fix
this so there we go this is all happy
and another case where you can use it a
classic example which you'll find
everywhere is RGB because that actually
makes a lot of sense in case you want to
have an RGB B then this needs to be a
number obviously we have something like
two five five two five five two five
five so all the three values should be
numbered we don't expect that there
should be fourth number uh probably for
an alpha or the opacity you are not
bothered about you want strictly like
that so if you define a type like this
then obviously you have to go ahead and
have two five five and let's just say
one two three and then one one two so
this is a guarantee that always these
numbers are going to be there for
example somebody puts an opacity and say
that hey we want an opacity of 0.5 then
this is not allowed because this will
say hey this is not how it is declared
this shouldn't be like that and if you
remove this you can see all happy now so
one of the example up here but it's not
like it's all easy and all useful and as
I told you you can you don't have to
just put up a reference just like this
you can define a type like this as well
for example we have already studied type
quite a lot so let's just say you're
going for a user and that user you say
that always comes up with certain things
like there is an ID and there is an
email that comes up so now you have
defined anything who is following or is
a type of user needs to be exactly like
a tuple or Tuple and there it's going to
be a simple number and a string always
and always it is compulsory so for
example let's just say we go ahead and
say this is a new user which is a type
of user and if we are going to follow
this if the type is being defined then
we cannot just go ahead and add anything
into this there should be an ID and
there should be an email so let's call
this one as example at google.com so
this is really important you cannot just
go ahead and say that hey this is going
to be a true now you are following a
type here which is Tuple and this is not
allowed but there is something really
wrong about the tuples so for example if
I go ahead and use this one this is
absolutely fine I can even go ahead and
change this one so new user and I can
just go ahead and say hey at first
position uh of course I cannot go ahead
and do something like this that at first
position there can be a number uh not
allowed to but make sure you are
cautious about that that you can
actually override that uh so yes this is
totally happening depends on what
version of typescript you are using so
you can actually manually put some
restriction by your code but right now
there is nothing which is stopping me to
override these values so it's not a
guarantee that the values will never
change it will change you can change it
and that's well now other thing which is
really controversial about the this
entire thing is let me go ahead and
comment this out or we can actually
leave it no problem I can actually go
ahead and say new user and if you notice
it carefully just an array it's just an
array with the Restriction that first
value should be number second value
should be string or you can say zeroth
Value First value you get the idea
since this is an array I'm actually
allowed to use all the methods of an
array and now I can go ahead and say
true and you might have obviously
noticed it that new new user is now not
following the protocol that we assigned
it and by the term protocol I mean to
say that what restriction we put up what
kind of a guarantee we put up with the
tuples here that hey it should be number
then a string and nothing else but with
these methods I'm actually allowed to do
so not great not great but I can
actually show you something really
interesting up here so there is a nice
article here on the JavaScript uh
section of the stack overflow
so typescript array push method can't
catch a tuple type of array and it's
really long ago one year 11 month not
long in terms of a programming language
career but in terms of what line what is
this and this is a good question
somebody tried to rephrase it nicely
that tuples are known for their length
and where the elements may have a value
So when you say number and string it is
guarantee that you will have only two
length uh but first number at zeroth
Position will be number and a string but
you can use push and push was just an
example I used here you can use unshaped
shift and that messes up everything and
even there's a link to the article that
hey how this is going on this was closed
by Microsoft that hey this is how it is
that's a great read if you try and give
your five minutes of your valuable time
then it's a really great thing to read
about why this happens and all of that
so uh really there's there's a lock and
there's a great answer about the
read-onlys and stuff as well but as a
matter of fact yes this is all there but
the fact is that still this is possible
so make sure if you are using typescript
and you are using tuples and are too
much reliant on that this is not just
this is something that can happen to
your code base so I think this is all a
good overview of the tuples and I think
you'll be cautious about that and let's
catch up in the next video
hey there everyone face here back again
with another video and welcome to the
typescript series and in this video we
are going to talk about enums some
people like to call it with its full
name I'm not gonna do it I always love
to call it as just enum the full name is
just mouthful I just love to call it as
enums let me know in the comment section
what is the full version name of the
enums and how do we call it I would be
really happy to see that how many people
actually can put down a comment in this
one okay moving ahead enum's really
crazy really awesome and I'll tell you
the reason why I call them a little bit
crazy at the end of the video so let's
go ahead and create a new file and talk
about them really simple there is
nothing too much and this video is more
than enough for you to understand uh why
there should be enums and why is it
helpful so let's just go ahead and say
enums my enums.ts a new file is there
and let's go ahead and do that now why
enums exist now enums exists that there
are certain times when you want to
restrict somebody's choice or with the
values that are offered here for example
in an e-commerce application as somebody
is putting up an order so you want to
really restrict the order uh status here
so order can be uh in the wish list or
it can be delivered it can be shipped it
can be returned there is a lot of things
similarly in case of uh plain ticket
booking especially the airplane there
are only three types of seats which are
regularly available so I'll middle and
window you don't want to assign them
crew tickets or something else like that
there can be thousands of cases like
that the whole idea is how to restrict
the user's choice and one easy way is to
Simply declare some constant uh so some
something like I would love to do is
let's just say I'll I'll call this one
as zero I'm going to go ahead and simply
have a constant with the middle and
that's going to be one and then I can go
ahead and say this one is window and
that is going to be two so there's
nothing wrong with this and in later on
case if you have a simple if else
statement you can just say if the let's
just say there is a variable there is a
seat and that seat is going to be simply
you can go ahead and check up that if
that is equals to uh aisle or something
like that you can go ahead and do that
yes of course this variable doesn't
exist but you get the idea that how this
is being done you can evaluate to either
zero or something like that you can go
ahead and say that hey I'm going to
evaluate for zero something like this
but what if somebody changes this
variable not a good idea to be honest
this is not a good code yes there could
be constant but in the case where you
want to have three restrictive options
in that case enums actually serves you
really well
declaring the enum is really simple you
go ahead and put up an enum and then
we're going to go ahead and put up a
simple C Choice really simple and then
we're going to just put up the C choice
for example there is going to be an
aisle there is going to be a middle and
there is going to be a window
now anybody who wants to use it can
actually use it let's just say we go
ahead and create a variable that hey
this variable is a c choice so let's
just say that HC seat you're trying to
define or give me a seat from this one
so I don't have to actually go ahead and
do this I can just go ahead and say hey
C choice and I say dot and only three
options are available this makes my code
a bit more reliable so like that and
maybe later on there is an international
flight so there could be four seats in
the one so I don't know what to call the
fourth one but let's just say we call
this one as fourth so I have to do
nothing I can immediately I have moved
my flight into the international one and
I can put up a DOT and all these options
are given to me so there could be a lot
of database cases where you want to
provide more options maybe you're
designing a navigation bar or a menu bar
in that you want to have more options
whatever you want to do you can actually
go ahead and do that now the most
important part with this one is how we
can have this one now as you notice when
I hover this one it says it's an inner
member and the seat Choice dot isle is
having a value of zero and this is by
default and there are a lot of ways and
notice this carefully there are a lot of
ways how you can Define this one default
is always the first value gets zero then
the subsequent value gets an increment
number so this means if I don't like
that hey I don't want to start with 0
maybe there is some special code in my
airplane that I don't want to call that
zero I want to call it as 10 you can go
ahead and do that now automatically for
whatever reason you are evaluating it
this is 10 and obviously the next value
is 11 then 12 and then the 13. so this
is totally allowed and you can go ahead
and do that maybe right you want to get
started with any number like that so for
some reason the middle is now 22 yes
that is totally allowed it's not like
you always have to go into the
increasing order but notice here window
always get 23 and this get 24. so you
get the idea that you can actually put
up a strict number and rest of the
values will follow up or maybe you don't
want to call this one as like this so
you want to call this one as 44 maybe
whatever the reason is so you get the
idea how this is being done let me go
ahead and remove this and another way of
how you can do it is you can actually
put up some values so for example you
don't want to call it as IL you
literally want to call this one as IELTS
so you can go ahead and do that now as
soon as I do this
notice here it says that hey enum must
have an initializer why is it having an
issue shouldn't be having an issue
oh no worries it just is asking for a
value so now we are moving ahead since
we have actually mentioned that it's not
numbered numbers are automatically being
calculated now I need to go ahead and
put up values for all of this one
because I I've broken the pattern that
it's not there again I should be
consistent
and
this one also needs to be window
and window and this one and again it's
not really compulsory that you put up
all the values as you can put up hey
this is zero so again the once you start
putting up the numbers not the numbers
the strings as a value then you can you
always have to go ahead and provide
values for all of them uh but
surprisingly let me show you one more
interesting stuff uh I'm pretty sure
that might be bothering you a little bit
let's just say I just want to say that
that is I'll but this one is three uh
notice here this one says hey that is
four and again a comma and this one
automatically goes five so these are a
couple of ways of how you can Define
that there is a lot of ways how you can
read the documentation and find out that
hey you can assign numbers and strings
and all of that now the good thing about
this is uh how the values are
interpreted previously we saw that IL is
always interpreted as an number value
zero but what would be the inside the
value of HC seat that is the most
important in this case it would be a
literal string so if I hover this one
notice here or in this one this one is
obviously a type of seat but if I go up
here this is a literal value of Il and I
can match that up with anything that I
like so this is the most important thing
about the enum really simple you can
Define functions around it you can
Define constants around it variables
whatever you want to do it the most
important part is this one how to define
them now there is a little bit more to
it this is a little bit crazy thing to
have it so let's go ahead and this is a
great example so we're going to just
copy this one and we'll save it so that
you can have a reference around it and
let me open up my Chrome so let's just
go ahead and paste it because it is also
equally important that we see that what
kind of code is being produced when we
write this kind of typescript into the
JavaScript just we can actually compile
that at any given point of time but this
is rather easier so you can see as soon
as I declare this enum and if he is
being designed or being created for me
and if you don't know about iffy go
ahead and watch my playlist of
JavaScript it's still one of the most
valuable series on the internet and
notice here this is an iffy immediately
invoked function is executed here and it
gives me a c Choice notice here a lot of
code is being generated for me and then
I'm able to allow to get this one a lot
of people don't like it and that's why
you're gonna see a lot of discussion
around it on the GitHub of typescript as
well as on the stack Overflow and one
solution that has been given is just use
const and once you actually do this this
doesn't generate too much of the code
because see a lot of people don't like
that typescript generates too much
insane amount of crazy code for the Java
because sometimes maybe you want to
directly jump into JavaScript fix some
stuff typescript is great but sometimes
it's not that perfect it's not matured
at some cases in that cases
having too much of crazy JavaScript code
is not good for you so in that case you
can just put a const before the enum and
this will not generate any crazy code
this will just generate whatever is
necessary for example in the case of
file if I go ahead and just say call it
as 2 the value is being assigned as 2
here and if I go ahead and put it I'll
that I'll is a constant being created so
yes uh although you are using this one
and you will be given options of
choosing from restricted options but the
final JavaScript code that is being
generated for you is still a really
clear clear and simple so again the
motto behind having a typescript is
having a restriction while writing the
code but the code that is being produced
by the JavaScript should be clean and
beautiful and that is why there's a lot
of discussion and a healthy discussion
around the community which is good and
which is not and I think now you're
capable enough to take a participation
in that that whether you like this iffy
style of code and what is this uh the
previous style of code we're declaring
the constant so and again don't forget
to put down in the comment section the
question that I asked you in the earlier
of the start of the video and that's it
now you know a lot about the enums and
let's go ahead and catch up in the next
video hope you have already hit that
subscribe let's catch up in the next one
hey there everyone fish here back again
with another video and in this video
we'll talk about interfaces in
typescript now interfaces are pretty
cool in typescript and yes I would 100
agree they sound exactly similar to type
that we have already studied in the
typescript so they almost are identical
and that is why it is required at least
two or maybe three videos to finally
understand where the interfaces are and
why these are being so much used into
the world of typescript now before we
move forward make sure you hit that
subscribe Button as well as forward
these playlists entirely into your
WhatsApp group into your college group
so that everybody can take advantage
that would be really really beneficial
for me and you both of us let's move
ahead and talk about interfaces so let
me take you on to my screen we have
created a new file my interface.ts and
yes you'll find a lot of similarities
between that so yes I do understand that
part and we'll take care of what is the
differences between them the versus part
and all of that but right now let's go
ahead and just talk about the interface
so yes it starts with the keyword
interface and let's just say let's try
to assume a scenario you're creating a
new user and this user has some of the
properties like maybe email maybe a user
ID maybe there is a Google login maybe
there is a database ID as well and you
are trying to start a trial for this
user for whatever the services you are
you are actually selling and also you
want to give him some discount code as
well so this much of the scenario will
help us to get an entire overview of how
things are going to be there so I think
that's a good scenario to understand the
interfaces Bit by Bit And Pieces by
pieces so moving further let's just say
we call this one as simply user feel
free to call it whatever you like and we
have a user so let's just say user
starts with an email that is going to be
a simple string and we'll be saying that
you should also have a user ID and that
will be a number
all right and yes I do agree you might
be saying hey let's go ahead and create
a type of this and then call this like
that and yep that also exists and that
also works uh but we are not here for
type we'll go through with the
differences between them in the next
video but right now let's just jump back
into interface that yes now interface is
more like a scenario or kind of a like
interface doesn't have those
nitty-gritty and details of how it will
work but these are basic overview of
that whenever you're creating a user
these are the field which are compulsory
these are the methods which are
compulsory now how you implement them
that is totally up to you but interface
yes Loosely you can say it's smooth like
a class but yeah lose form of class very
broad overview a very superficial view
it will ask you it will force you that
there should be a method it the name
should be the same but it doesn't say
what should you do inside it it just has
a basic protocol things that hey this is
uh I expect this is or what it's
supposed to do but it helps a lot in the
code and especially in the long and
really bulky code that this helps helps
a lot so let's try to create a user so
let's just say we create a user hitesh
and let's just Define that that this is
going to be a type of user as soon as I
do this this creates a problem that hey
if they should be a type of user empty
parenthesis nope that's not going to
work because you are messing up uh email
and the user ID so if I go ahead and say
email ID is going to be let's just say h
at the rate h.com and of course we need
a user ID that will be 2211 whatever
that is okay this is great this is
really valid maybe let's just say user
is also trying to log in from the Google
and he does have a Google ID so we'll be
saying Google ID Google token whatever
that is but I'm not sure it might be not
as compulsory there is a email and
password login as well so you can
obviously use these fields which we have
used in the past as well so this is now
optional you pass it great you don't
pass it nobody's going to stop you and
there are also read-only fields which we
have already seen in the past so read
only can be something like a DB ID so
there is a database ID you don't want to
change it it should be number it's not
optional so obviously you have to fill
it so we're going to say that DB
ID and that one will be a number so I'll
be saying to do yeah that that's the
database ID now the advantage of the
read-only is same as what we have
studied in the past hope you have
watched that video so for example if I
go ahead and say email
that email is going to be let's just say
I
changed my mind and I say it's going to
be etch at the rate hc.com I wish I
would have that domain but if I go ahead
and try to manipulate any of the
read-only values for example dbid and
change it from two to three three it's
not allowed you get the idea this is
really basic we have seen this and done
this in the past as well now what makes
interfaces really interesting is the
definition of the functions and there
are a couple of ways how you actually
Define it let's start with the trial
user so we're going to say there is a
start trial and you want to provide a
method for that so start trial and there
are a couple of ways how you define the
method the first one is the boring one I
don't like it much second one I like
more so the first method is you define a
name and then you say hey this is going
to be a method there can be written type
of void or string whatever that is let's
start with the string so now as soon as
you create a user type of hitesh you
need to provide a method here as well
that needs to be there so let's just go
ahead and say start trial something like
this and this needs to be a method that
is compulsory you can just go ahead and
say hey for because it's it's not
allowed it will pop you that Hey
whenever you're creating this this needs
to be a function which returns a string
as well so it's really easy to Define
that so what we can do is we can just go
ahead put up a colon and say hey this is
going to be a method and there we go now
only compulsory part onto US is to
return a string so we'll be saying
something like trial started that's it
and that's pretty much it that's all it
is right now and yes of course there
could be more logic inside it but this
series is not about logic building this
is more about getting friendly with the
typescript now there is another way of
doing this which is something that I
like more because it's much more clear
to understand I'll be saying let's just
say trial and what you can do in this
one is you can just put a parenthesis
just here and this makes more clarity
actually to me that this is not going to
be anything this is going to be always
in method and then after that you define
what type of data is going to return it
might return nothing it might return any
uh badly any but you can just go ahead
and say string now if I go ahead and try
to return something like two it will say
hey what are you doing you shouldn't be
doing that you should be returning a
string so yeah that is one of the way
this is my favorite way but again let me
know in the comment section which is
your favorite way maybe you like it more
this is more something that is making
sense to you now last but not the least
is remaining is the discount code so
let's just say user wants to get a
coupon so we're gonna say get coupon
these days it's a very sales tactical
world so get coupon and coupon should
have a name so let's just say we are
saying coupon name and that name is
going to be in the string and the return
type is going to be a number
number there we go
now obviously we have to put up this
method now get coupon and there's
something really interesting in this one
which typescript allows you to do is
first let's get coupon and then again
this should be a method which is going
to return a number so let's just say we
are going to go ahead and say return uh
10 because you get a 10 off but notice
here uh right now you're saying hey you
should take a parameter of string right
now it's saying hey user.get coupon so
it should be a method so right now it's
not popping us anything but in in
technicality you should be providing a
name which is a compulsory one you
should always get that and I'm pretty
sure by doing a little bit of The Tweak
settings and stuff it will yell at us
now interestingly you should always
provide a coupon name and let me show
you something interesting I can just go
ahead and say name and then I can
provide something like this there we go
something like this and this is allowed
this is totally loud you don't need to
match this name with whatever the name
you are providing it is just a reference
that hey you are providing a coupon name
which should be a string and you should
always provide that that is the whole
idea you can go ahead and provide a
value as well which should be a number
and now it is expecting that there
should be two values that you should
pass on here now right now it is uh
are not giving you anything but you can
just go ahead and say off and if I go
ahead and try to put up something like
string like this notice here it says hey
you're not allowed to do so you can
totally avoid it or if you're passing it
up let's just say you have to give a
number so that is 10 because it's a 10
off so you get the idea that how this is
being done and again uh these are all
compulsory parameters that we're passing
on right now and this gives a brief idea
of how to define interface again use
cases always helps us to get things more
readable but again interface is not done
yet we need to have a little bit more
discussion about interface you can
easily get it confused with the types
but yes these things makes it a little
bit more powerful and one thing to note
here one thing very important to note
here start tile is a method which
returns a string it doesn't force me
that how you are starting the trial and
it is also making me compulsory that
whenever you're using the sitesh
creating that there should be a method
start trial and you should return a
string no matter what logic you put up I
really don't care so this interface is
always like in like an interface like
for example your operating system is an
interface for Hardware it doesn't allow
you that when you click a button how
does it happen you don't know and you
don't care about it you just know if I
click on this something happens if I
double click on a folder it opens up how
it does behind the scene what methods
are being called you don't care so that
is an interface and that is exactly the
same interface in the typescript as well
let's go ahead and catch up in the next
video
hey there everyone face here back again
with another video and let's continue
our discussion for the interface in the
last video we saw the interfaces and yes
we found a lot of similarity between
interfaces and the type as well but the
method that we are having here is a lot
more difference we haven't discussed
them earlier but this makes interface a
little bit unique as well and in terms
of more uniqueness interface also comes
with an extension and some people like
to call with fancy words like you can
reopen the interface and all that that's
nothing it's just adding more properties
into this let me walk you through it
will make all of the sense of what is
reopening of the interfaces uh really
not a big fan of the word reopening the
interfaces it's just adding more values
to the interface itself so let me walk
you through them so for example in the
last video we worked on really having
giving this user an email user ID Google
ID read-only IDs and couple of methods
as well but later on maybe this is not
something that you have defined maybe
this is a library that you are bringing
in from GitHub or maybe somebody else
has written a package and you like this
package a lot but there was only one
thing missing that this interface
doesn't have
um a simple this has a Google ID but
this doesn't have a GitHub login ID
maybe so you're going to give that so in
that case you can just go ahead and
again this usually doesn't happen like
this like once you're writing interface
after that this is something that is
stored in some files and these are files
being brought by other developers or
maybe other libraries so you can go
ahead and just find out where that
interface is and you can actually go
ahead and write this user again it is
totally allowed and now here we can say
that I want a GitHub ID or GitHub token
as well so I'm going to go ahead and say
give me a GitHub token and that will be
a string now with this you have you can
also make this optional in case you want
to but let's just say this is compulsory
for us we are taking an input from the
GitHub now all I have to do is make sure
I add one more property so I can go
ahead and say Hey I want to have a
GitHub token and that token is going to
be a string so I'm going to say let's
just say GitHub and of course with a
comma
so this is all good and you realize that
yeah you don't have to touch this entire
thing but you also get the entire
functionality in your variable or a
constant that you have declared up here
so this is why a lot of people love it
and during the interviews if there is a
typescript specific interview uh people
like to call it as reopening of the
interface yeah I found it a bit mouthful
as well but I think that's great now one
advantage also that you get with
interface is inheritance that is
something really great so for example
you want to create an interface and you
know that you want to call it as admin
now obviously you can go ahead and
Define the admin whatever you like maybe
you like a role or something
but one great thing about the admin is
you can just go ahead and say extends
and extends extends is a keyword and
then you can use and you can say that
hey I'm going to go ahead and extend it
with the user so immediately you get all
the properties that are there for admin
but you also have that so you can now go
ahead and call this one as admin and yes
that will also work but since it's an
admin there should be some role as well
and it can be simply a string then you
have to add it but maybe you are
defining a role and there are some
literal values you have a literal value
of admin maybe you have a TA maybe you
have something uh what else maybe a
learner
learner
ah come on if I can type that that would
be great okay uh Learners so now you
have to obviously give a role as well to
if you are extending this so let's just
say we have a role and in this case uh
since this is a literal value I can just
just go ahead and say admin this will
not be correct this needs to be exact
value then it will be correct so you get
the idea how you can have it and by the
way you can just put up a comma and you
can just have another interface if you
like that you can go ahead and call that
we don't have another but you get the
idea how this is being done really super
simple super easy and that makes uh the
whole of the interface so you can extend
it you can inheritance it you can reopen
and inject the values into it but also
word of caution if your interface is you
are naming it make sure any package or
library that you have installed don't
have that interface of the USB messing
it up entirely so make sure you don't do
that and again I would like to bring in
the documentation of the typescript as
well so this is the small documentation
and yes they also bring down this
question that what is the difference
between Type alias's interface there's
nothing too much I recommend you to read
this paragraph up here so here they make
interface and here they make type it
says extending the interface goes like
this you can simply say extends and then
provide the name here that's fine in the
case of type we have already studied it
that there's an ampersand and then you
go with this weird way which I'm not a
big fan that's how you do it and if you
want to add a new field you can open
this up anytime and do it and a type
cannot be changed after being created
this will obviously give an error so
these are coming up directly from
official documentation and this is where
you should be trusting the most official
documentation so I hope you get the
brief idea of how these things are being
done and I think now you have an entire
knowledge about interface and again read
a little bit more of the documentation
they will give you more idea but
throughout the documentation you'll find
this point X and Y yep they are great
example but I think a more realistic
example could help you to understand a
little bit more so that's all about
interfaces and let's catch up in the
next video
hey there everyone thanks here back
again with another video and welcome to
another video in the typescript series
in this video we have so far we have
already gone through with the basics of
typescript how it works the basics idea
how to generate a Javascript file with
it but now it's time that we move a
little bit One Step Closer towards how
it is being written in the production
and there's not too much of drastic
difference it's just a setup and setup
depends on are you using react angular
view whatever you're using anywhere
you're using a writing typescript
JavaScript that's the same place where
you can use typescript as well now again
if you're if you have been into so far
of the video series and you are still
asking me that hey Tesh is it going to
be a series about typescript for react
or typescript for view my friend you
need to watch this series again
typescript is not for react or view or
angular it's just a whole ecosystem
similarly like if you ask me that hey
JavaScript is it meant for react only or
is it meant for jQuery only I would say
you don't understand JavaScript if
you're asking that JavaScript is only
used in react similarly if you ask
typescript is only being used in angular
or react that means you don't understand
typescript still so go ahead watch the
video again and I have already cleared
the mindset of it in this video we'll be
creating a similar typescript scenario
where we'll see that how probably in the
production you can write typescript and
maybe you're creating a basic
application which just includes
JavaScript itself but you don't want to
write core JavaScript you want to write
more of a polished and a protected
JavaScript that's where the typescript
comes in so we'll watch through with
that scenario and maybe later on we'll
see that how this can be introduced with
react and other types that you can
introduce so let's go ahead and try to
shrink this up and we'll be going with
typescript YouTube let's go into zero
three and we'll be calling it as uh pure
TS yeah that not a great name but brts
that would be great okay let's go ahead
and open this up now the way how you do
it is actually we have already installed
typescript so TSC is already there so we
need to actually initialize it and this
is the first time that you are using a
typescript like this so make sure you
actually are following along with me
this is a setup really super easy but
make sure you go ahead and follow this
up we have already got TSC which is a
typescript compiler for us which is
globally installed in this case so dash
dash init and you can see there are a
lot of options available the one that we
are going for is dash dash init what
this does is it creates a simple
typescript config file in case you are
using typescript with react or something
and you're using pre-boiler template for
that it gives you a lot of options like
that if I open up this TS config you can
see that there is a lot of options for
compiler projects what to disable what
is the Target right now it says es 2016
and there are a lot of es versions that
you can Target a library there's a whole
lot of options we are going to talk
about some of them uh what is your root
directory what is your output directory
and JavaScript what to allow what to
emit uh what does the output file or
output directory looks like there's a
lot and as you can see there's a strict
there's a lot of options and there could
be a dedicated video just for these
options and by the way these are the
same options that you find on the
typescript website so if I open up this
typescript website and I go at the very
top of it and I say uh the playground so
these options actually are just here so
when we say TS config yep these are
exactly all the options that are
available to us so yep these are the
options we'll probably talk about them
in some other video right now uh just
generating a TS config is good enough
really we have not done anything it's
just a TSC dash dash in it so really
simple and really basic now obviously I
want to start a node project here so I'm
going to go ahead and say npm init
and I'm going to put up a dash y so that
it doesn't ask me too many of the
questions so it generates a node
package.json file again remember
tsconfig.json is for tsconfig typescript
configuration and package.json is for uh
basically install any node package
manager or npm or something like that
we're going to create a couple of files
so that we can actually work with that
so we're going to go ahead and say
index.html and it's really simple to
fill this up so we're going to go ahead
put up an exclamation hit the tab it
just fulfills everything that we need
and here we're going to go ahead and
load a script file and we'll be saying
now what happens is you can directly go
ahead and mention your typescript file
but what happens in the case of
production is actually you have two
folders so let me go ahead and say mkdir
the first one is source and the second
one is dist so dist is a short form for
distribution these are the two folders
that you usually find now source is
where you write your code this is a kind
of a common standard throughout all the
projects whether that's angular or react
or anything and distribution is
something which gets on to the
production and that is being served to
the end user so here into the source we
can just right click and create a new
file and we can just go ahead and say
Hey I want to create a new file into the
source this is going to be
index.ts because that's where you write
typescript
and the distribution is where
automatically the index.js is being
created you can go ahead and manually
create that or we can just go ahead and
create a new file something like
index.js usually you don't create it it
is automatically being generated so
we'll be working on that so this is the
file index.js which you have to link up
so all you have to do is create a script
inside the body and we say that hey go
into the distribution and index.js this
is where all of your code is going to
come in now technically you never ever
write anything inside this test index.js
this is supposed to be generated but
this is the index.html where you
actually Point towards this file and
rest everything that happens into your
into your web page happens through the
typescript itself but who is telling
typescript that hey compile this file
and produce it inside the distribution
folder inside the index.js right now
nobody nobody is telling that typescript
that hey go ahead and do that so we have
to go into the TS config and tell it
that hey this is how it's it needs to be
done and if you just go ahead at the
very top and you keep on scrolling you
you see there's a lot of things up here
but there is something known as output
directory if you scroll a little bit
around line number 52 or just search for
it this is where the output directory is
being mentioned that hey where is your
output directory hit control slash or
command slash if you're on the Mac and
this will uncomment this one so this
will say that hey where should the
output of this file and this should go
up and we're going to mention that hey
my output is going to go into the dist
file here and I can just go ahead and
say slash dist and I can actually go
ahead and say dot slash
it should be there suggestions are not
there but anyways you get the idea how
this is the dist is going to come up
here now so far how we have configured
is it's going to scan the entire
directory here
wherever the TS config is from there all
of the directories the distribution The
Source everything will be scanned up and
we'll search for any TS file it will be
combined and wherever the compilation
happens after that the final output
directory is going to be dot slash dist
where the index.js or whatever the name
of our file is the same name file will
be created uh yes there could be a lot
of more options but we'll just go for
this one as of now okay all right let's
go ahead and now try to use some of the
options so for example in this one we're
going to go ahead and say hey I want to
write some console.log because that's
how we start and we're going to say
typescript is here
now as soon as I save this notice here
there is nothing so we need to compile
this typescript file so let's go ahead
and do that I can go ahead and say TSC
and then I can go into the source and
then I can say index and I can run this
and this obviously creates everything
inside the index.js itself this is not
what we want we want it to compile it a
little bit better so we're going to go
ahead and remove this this is definitely
not something that I want I want
index.directory to be created inside the
index.js so I'm going to right click and
delete this one because this is not what
I want now apart from this there is
something known as with the TSC there
are a lot of options here there's one
option Dash W which says I want you to
run into the watch mode so this is going
to keep on running the things and there
is any change in the typescript this is
going to just keep on watching it and
notice here now the console.log comes
here so there are a couple of ways when
you compile it with that it doesn't look
for the TS config but when you actually
put it into the watch mode then it keeps
on watching and also watch it based on
the TS config.json and try to run all
these things there so this is right now
our best friend yes there are a lot more
configuration options we'll talk about
them but right now this does my job now
just to prove a little bit more to the
point I'll stop this one I'm going to go
ahead and right click and delete this
file even which is in my distribution
folder I'll move it to the trash we
don't have that file now I have still a
typescript file which says console.log
typescript is here uh still something
like that and I go ahead and run it into
a watch mode and it starts compiling it
gives me index.js file which uses a
strict and gives me a console.log so
that is great now all I have to do is
start this index.html so I have to use
some server for that so that it loads it
up because right now if I open this up
there is nothing wrong I can go ahead
and open this up no problem at all but
there's a difference between just double
clicking opening app file and call
calling it as like a server running so
that everything that's there runs on the
localhost so there are a lot of packages
for that there is no shortage of
packages I'll close this one and that is
why we have installed this package.json
so let's go ahead you can use nodemon
that is a little heavy but still will do
the job and there's also npm install
there is something known as light Dash
server and yeah that is my extension
actually helps me to find out if there
is a package available for that or not
and that actually automatically loads up
your index.html you can go ahead and
click on this index.html by the way this
is another way you can just do that or
you can just right click and open it
with the live server so both of the
options are there live server or light
server whatever you want to use let's
just open this in the live server first
and there we go this is live server if I
open up this into inspect and
into the console
there we go I see that uh typescript is
still here that is going to load up but
another way which a lot of people love
to do that I think this live server is
still good enough that is again an
extension you have to install but in
case you don't want to for some reason
then you can go ahead and say that hey
into this package.json I can have a
Simple Start script
and here you can just go ahead and say
Hey I want to start light server now
they will do the exact same stuff so you
don't have to worry
there we go
all right so now all we have to do is in
this case uh we are not going to be
running it through the index.html so I'm
going to right click and say stop live
server
and now the live server is stopped so
that I can run the live light server
mouthful confusing as well I can go
ahead and say npm start and that also
does the same thing it just opens up
localhost at 3000 previous one opened at
a 55 0 0 and but again the same thing
whatever suits you whatever you think is
the best one uh just go ahead and use
that they both does the same job they
both does the same job and in case you
don't want to install any packages light
server or something like that go ahead
and just install an extension by the way
this is how I installed it I just go
ahead come up here and I say live server
by earthwick day uh live server uh seems
like I am offline seems like my network
is should be working on that shouldn't
be like that
okay when offline please check uh
probably there is something wrong in my
network connection uh but yeah this is
the one so live server this is the one
by earthwick day that I used again
repeating this again if you're using the
live server just come up onto index.page
link up your uh JS file right click and
open with live server in case you don't
like for some reason a live server you
can use light server in that case you
have to move into package.json and I
have to say npm install Light Server
create a start script and there we go
and apart from this we will be opening
up a new terminal and we'll be saying
hey TSC just go ahead and keep on
running into the watch mode so that
whenever I make any changes in
typescript you first and come and
consult to
tsconfig.json and then whatever I write
here you just go ahead and just follow
that so if I go ahead and put up a
duplicate I'm going to duplicate that
come on looks like I forgot copy that
paste that so typescript is here and
we're going to say typescript is amazing
save that I prefer not to use a light
server I don't think that's necessary I
think I'll just go ahead and say right
click and open with live server I think
that is much more awesome and I don't
need to install any packages so I'll
just right click and say inspect
and I'll say console and yeah everything
is coming up one more thing I would like
to do here is inside this head I would
like to open up a style because I know
this is painful and we'll be saying the
entire body should have a styling which
is going to be background color is going
to be let's try a little bit of the
grayish I think let's
let's go ahead and use three one three
one three one so save that and yep I
know you are much more happier now so uh
dark mode is is the way how to go
forward so you get the idea how to do
this this is a basic setup of how we can
do it uh surely in the upcoming files
we'll talk more about how the TS config
Works uh but right now we'll still talk
more about the typescript and then we'll
talk about the typescript configuration
so I think now we are equipped perfectly
to actually put up a typescript into
production how this is being done surely
there are more settings but this is a
good start so hit that subscribe for
that and let's catch up in the next one
hey there everyone hitesh here and
welcome back to another video in the
series of typescribe hope you are
enjoying this series it's a little late
ah well over one o'clock in the night
still all pumped up to make more videos
so in the last video we saw that how we
can simply put up a server of typescript
and we can actually keep on generating
the files in the JavaScript and we have
set up almost like a production grade
not exactly but very near to the
production grade server where we can
write typescript now through that server
now previously we've been writing just
the alone typescript file but from this
moment onwards we'll be start writing
things as typescript and we'll be
learning classes with them shortly we
can go ahead and run these classes via
the previous method as well you can just
create an ordinary file and go ahead we
do that there is no problem at all but I
just wanted to show you that yes this is
also another way so we'll be just uh
closing all the files so index.html
don't need package.json tsconfig.in
index.js definitely will be needing that
because we'll be creating some of the
files so we're going to go ahead and let
me also close this one because we don't
need it right now so how do we create
classes in typescript now the syntax is
almost similar but there are some
subtleties which helps you to avoid some
of the like fall throughs where you can
fall eventually so let me walk you
through it's really simple easy the
keyword is same class and let's just say
we are creating the same user that we
have been trying to create so far in
this course so there we go that's it and
let's just say you want to create a
Constructor just like we do in the
JavaScript classes so we do have this
Constructor and you can take any
parameter into this one so for example
you might want to take email and you
also want to take a name into this
Constructor then we simply go ahead and
say hey this dot email is going to be
email and apart from this uh this dot
name is going to be a name so this is
classic JavaScript so far at least but
this is not typescript and that's why
you see a lot of squiggly lines appear
on the email and all a lot of that but
this is yes a valid JavaScript there is
nothing wrong with that so far but what
helps you uh in the typescript part is
over obviously the types of the data and
that's why typescript exists types for
that so you have to clearly mention that
hey email is going to be of type string
and the name also maybe it's a number
but in this case that's a string but
again we have discussed whole lot about
the types and this is now the syntax
familiarization but this is still
complaining and you might want to just
go up here and say hey this is going to
be a string but this doesn't actually
solve the problem it says hey this is
not the property email does not exist on
type so in order to avoid this kind of
thing this is not the syntax which is
given in the documentation of typescript
the way how they recommend is to
actually make sure that typescript is
aware of the email in advance so this is
really simple you just go ahead and say
hey there could be an email which is
going to be a simple type of string and
there can also be a name which can be of
any type but in this case we are going
for the string so these two values will
come up
and when we take these values from a
Constructor it just says hey uh just
take these values and fill them up into
this line number two email so this dot
email means I'm referring to the email
which is mentioned at line number two so
this is really simple that's how you do
it now creating a syntax or creating an
object from this class is really Sim so
for example you go ahead and create a
hitesh and that's going to be simply a
new now let's go ahead and user
obviously this is not correct because we
have to compulsory type that needs to
come in the first one being email not
enum email and that email is going to be
type of string if I can write that
email yeah that's correct
and let's just say h at the rate h.com
and then there is a name as well which
will come up as a dash uh so let me go
ahead and word wrap this first so word
wrap there we go
so we've got this really basic one which
is coming up and the most important part
is since this is a Constructor you don't
have to say actually this name and email
so this is something that you don't have
to do you just have to provide uh the
string the two strings that you can have
and really we can just go ahead remove
this one and this part as well and this
will be all happy now there we go so
really simple absolute Basics that's how
you do it now I will come back on to
couple of stuff but first I want to show
you the index.js so this is how the
index.js this produces almost the same
code and we can see in the typescript uh
right now it's not reloading the browser
but yeah typescript is watching the file
save and if I save this one again not
here if I save this one it watches that
and just produce the code so we can see
that almost same kind of code is being
produced here there is nothing magical
and it's working exactly same but in the
typescript world this is something which
is preventing some of the off usage of
the thing it always says that hey there
should always be a string and we
guarantee that this is all going to come
up as a string this is already a string
and that's why you are able to pass this
up here so that's really really nice
okay couple of more things that can come
up maybe there is more parameter like
for example there is a city and that
city is going to be a string
but you are not taking string come on
string there we go and now notice here
this city is giving you a problem that
hey a user.city string has no
initializer so obviously if you are
making a city and you're marking this up
as a string then it needs an initializer
because it's not a field we are taking
in constructory I can mark this as
totally empty now if you pass it on
that's great if you don't pass it on it
will not be worrying about that you can
definitely go ahead and access that so I
can go ahead and say user not user
actually
hitesh dot City and I can just access
that it will have a value here but again
I don't have to worry and also it also
prevents me to add something like 2 into
this one that hey you cannot actually
add a 2 into the city because it's a
string so that's a little bit of the
avoidance which actually doesn't happen
at the case of JavaScript so if I go
ahead and add that as my city so let's
just say I add Jaipur as my city then
obviously you can go ahead and work on
with that but but there is nothing which
is stopping me to come on here and if I
go ahead and reload that there's nothing
right now but I can go ahead and say uh
not user actually hitesh dot City and I
can go ahead and point it as three so
yes that's really bad I shouldn't be
doing that but uh in the test script uh
there is in the JavaScript there is no
control I can even come up here and can
change it to something like uh hitesh
dot City and I can make it four there is
nothing which is stopping me but as soon
as I save this this will be overwritten
as soon as I save my typescript so
that's a safety concern I come up here
save this and probably I need to write
some lines so maybe I'll just change it
to Delhi because the entire file is
being produced so if I save this uh yep
as you can see this is gone now so
whatever overwritten things that I've
done in the typescript they actually
produce and render a new JavaScript and
new this typescript helps me to avoid
any things like that okay apart from
this uh maybe you want to get a city as
probably read only then obviously it
will not allow you to change the city
always and always going to be blank or
maybe you want it or to be always as
Jaipur great City but obviously some
people might want to change it so in
this case it says Ah nope we are not
allowed to do so because it's a
read-only and that is the property we
have already studied it in the past so
again if I save this notice here uh
nothing stopping me because the
configuration is there that's why I'm
allowed to serve but typescript's
stopping me and you can configure it
using tsconfig that if there is
something wrong or there is something
error don't even produce the JavaScript
code so that is what the powerful thing
is but again you get the idea I'll
comment this out you get the idea how it
is really easy to write typescript
classes uh pretty easy nothing too much
of a heavy Centric load here and let's
discuss a little bit more about the
classes but in the next video let's
catch up there hit that subscribe
hey there everyone face here back again
with another video and welcome to the
classic Studio again and we're gonna
continue our typescript Series in this
video so the traveling is going to be
less so expect more videos and we're
gonna continue the typescript series
already we have covered a great in depth
of the typescript now only a few topics
are left which are mostly used and that
is something which is likely little bit
common in the JavaScript world as well
as we have some shortcuts and some
tricks with the typescript with some
type safety as well so we have already
gone through till the classes we have
gone through with the basic overview of
it in this video I'll show you some of
the modifier keywords especially we're
going to be focusing two out of the
three which is public and private yes
there is a one more we're gonna discuss
about that later on and we're going to
discuss some of the shortcuts that
you're gonna find in other people's code
one of the best way to learn programming
is to look at the source code what other
people has written in the same language
and to understand how is it happening
it's not about understanding the logic
behind it it's more about understanding
the syntax and the shortcuts and the
file structure that they have followed
so that is a good practice so anyways
let's get started and let's talk
something about the classes and the type
modifiers in the typescript so let me
walk you through so this is the example
in case you have followed along with the
series this is the example that we have
been taking around and we have the
typescript in our watch mode so that is
also we have discussed quite in depth so
this is a user class we have email and
the name and we also learned about some
of the modifiers like read only which
can only be read and you cannot actually
set them up this actually gave us a bit
of an error so if I go ahead and
uncomment this this gives us as squiggly
line it says you cannot assign that
we've already gone through with these
modifiers really easy now one of the
strange syntax that we have studied is
the Constructor
in the Constructor we have these emails
and name and we have to say this dot
emails so that we can have already some
of the emails being marked and these
values can go up there now there are a
couple of more things that we can
actually go ahead now for example some
reason you want this city to be not
accessible here at all like right now if
I want to access I can go ahead and
remove this and I'm totally allowed to
access it I'm not allowed to set it
because it's read only but I'm allowed
to access it for some reason you don't
want it to be accessible to anyone so
there we can go ahead and say we can
have it as private and once you have
this private it is marked as hey you
cannot use because it's a private mod
and it's only accessible within the
class so for example if I want to access
it some somewhat like here I can go
ahead and do it so I can go ahead and
say this dot City I'm totally allowed to
use that here because it's in the class
and this class could be into a separate
file list itself that is totally allowed
for you now this also makes a conclusion
that we also have an other keyword lying
around which is public so all these
things which you haven't marked
including name are automatically marked
in the typescript world as public there
is one more modifier we're going to talk
about them in later on video right now
we want to focus on this only now this
is the basic you should always remember
everything that you don't Mark is public
and if you really want to mark this this
is a private now one of the strange
thing that comes around with the private
is let me just go ahead and remove this
private from here and Mark it up here
you can mark it on anyone that's no
problem at all but the problem is that
this public and private thing is
actually available in JavaScript as well
so let me go ahead and say name it's not
accessible but you could have also done
that by simply saying something like
this and this is a classic JavaScript
and say there's this is declared but
never being read so this is something we
already have as a private and there is a
great debate in the typescript world
that should be used this syntax or we
should use uh private something like
that I found that the keyword private
makes much more sense because it's much
more clear much more easier to
understand I prefer this way and in fact
all the code that I have written is
personally also has this modifier
keyword instead of that hash the only
difference is the hash is actually a
JavaScript world and the private is a
typescript world there is no such thing
as private in the JavaScript world so
that is one thing you should always
remember and should be aware of it now
one more shortcut I would like to
mention here uh because you should know
about it now this whole thing is really
clumsy and really big and the production
grade code you will find less of these
classes being declared like that I'll
show you a shortcut way I'll duplicate
this one and I'm going to go ahead and
comment this out so what you're going to
see that most of the professional people
who write this code don't go like that
maybe let's just go ahead and remove
this they actually go ahead and use
these modifiers and actually use them up
here so what you can do is you can mark
them as public you can make them public
private whether ever you like I want to
make all of them public so I'm going to
go ahead and say public and this
actually produces the same code so that
is why you'll see a lot of professional
people actually write it this way and
sometimes they actually write it like
this and this so it's it means it's same
just a syntactic highlighting syntactic
sugar is there so yes a lot of people
does that and you can see that this
actually produces the same code
this dot email and this thought a lot of
people who write JavaScript hate
actually to write these things this dot
that this dot that so they love
typescript because of the simple reason
like this and you can actually if you
have to make something read only then
this is the syntax but maybe there's
something more in the private you can go
ahead and do that as private as well so
we're going to say private and what else
is maybe user ID that is going to be of
type string so you can go ahead and do
that as soon as I save this you'll
notice that this user ID is there but
since there is nothing which we are
marking it as private or something we
are totally allowed to use that so
that's the basics and again there is a
syntax it says Constructor you need to
pass on user ID as well if I go ahead
and comment this out this is all happy
now so you get the idea there is one
more keyword there are a couple of more
things we have to learn about this
private method so that we are going to
talk about in the next video let's catch
up hey there everyone fish here back
again with another video and in this
video we're going to talk about Getters
and Setters and and they're almost
exactly same as we see them in the
JavaScript world in the typescript world
they are also same but with some of the
interesting thing and these interesting
things are usually being asked in
interviews When you mention that yes I
do have an expertise in typescript as
well so let's take an example let's move
on to the system take an example of that
and nothing too much to be worried about
it's really easy so we already got this
uh City so something like that and there
could be a lot of use cases of these
Getters and Setters one common let's
just try out and again these are some of
the basic examples that I'm going
through let's just see how to design a
method which says get Apple email so
maybe you're designing a software for
apple and it doesn't throw away the
email directly it gives you the random
email or some email based on that so you
can go ahead and provide a Getters like
that so get Apple email in case you want
to make a getter of that you just
annotate it with a get keyword and
that's it it you make it as a getter and
that's all now this get app email is
going to return a string and we're going
to go ahead and annotate that so it
doesn't do automatically things for us
and notice here right now it says a
getter accessor must return a value so
let's go ahead and return a value we're
going to go ahead and say Hey I want to
return a simple string and that string
is going to say something like apple and
then we're going to use a dollar sign
like that and we're going to say this
dot email so you just append the
existing email with the Apple keyword in
front of it maybe you don't want to do
this maybe you want to generate a
completely random email for that totally
up to you totally your decision just
wanted to make sure that this is now a
getter and let's also do some Setter
example and show you something really
interesting which is a kind of a gotcha
movement for all the people who are
getting started with the typescript so
for example let's just say I come here
and I design a private
property here so this private property
is going to be something like uh let's
just say a course count so we're going
to go ahead and say underscore course
count and we're going to get started
with a course count of one so whenever a
user registered on your website he
always gets at least one course maybe an
introductory course on JavaScript or
whatever that courses we always get
started with that now this is already
private that means I cannot access this
outside of this class we have seen that
already in the last video so that is all
but you also want to design some Getters
and Setters for this property so that if
anybody wants to access this they are
allowed to access it but not directly
via that method which is a getter and
also if somebody wants to manipulate
that method it doesn't allow it to
directly set that value we want to have
some Setters for it so let's go ahead
and try and see that how we can actually
do this really simple first and foremost
we're going to design a simple getter
for that so if somebody wants to access
a course count we're going to provide a
method just like that and we're going to
say that this is going to return you a
number okay all right really simple and
all we're going to do in this one is
we're going to say this dot underscore
course count now this is a really basic
getter that we have designed but there
could be a more complex logic involved
at for example you might want to check
whether there's a unique ID or token is
there in the user session and then only
we are going to return him back the
course count there could be a lot more
complex logic we are not worried about
that we are focusing on the syntax in
the series and all the hidden details
similarly just like we have a getter we
could have a Setter as well and
something interesting about the setter
of course obviously it starts with the
set keyword and then we're going to go
ahead and say that this is going to a
course count but this time obviously you
want to update it with some value so
somebody is going to give you a course
number and here comes the interesting
part now this is not going to return
anything so I'll say that hey this is a
void and just like that
and notice here this says pop-up that a
Setter accessor cannot have a return
type of annotation so this is something
which is an interview question that
whenever you are making a Setters you
cannot actually make it a void you
cannot make it other data type as well
like number or anything no this is not
allowed typescript simply wants you to
have nothing here so this is a perfect
Setter okay because Setter is accessing
this property or whatever the property
are mentioning it and setting some
values on that so for example somebody
is giving you so you might want to have
a simple if and else check statement so
that if the course num is less than or
equal to one we don't want to do
anything because that's a default value
so in that case maybe you want to throw
a new error uh something like that
and you want to say something like this
give him an error that course count
should be more than one so that's a
basic error otherwise if that's not the
case you might want to do more check or
something but we all we're going to do
is in this case is simply this dot
underscore course count is going to get
updated with whatever the course number
you're designing so this could be any
logic as complex as you want maybe you
also want to check whether the user who
is updating the course count has
purchased or not whatever that use case
is what we are worried about is simply
to have a getter SunSetter important
part is in the Setters there should be
nothing that is the return type that is
the basic now also one more thing which
we didn't discuss in the last video we
saw that there could be private
properties similar to that there could
be private methods as well it is very
obvious but still wanted to cover this
topic so let's just say you want to have
a private method let's just call this as
delete token
so let's just say we have a delete token
right now it does nothing but maybe for
some reason we'll have a console log and
it says uh token deleted
so for some reason you want to only
access this method via the class only so
now if you go at here and try to access
this method which is very obvious that
if I want to say delete
delete token this is not allowed because
this is a private property and only
accessible within the class very obvious
we already know this one so this was
just basic now this is a really basic
let me summarize this Getters and
Setters are pretty common just like you
use them in JavaScript get is used to
get any property it doesn't mean that
you always have to get a private
property maybe you want to get a public
property via some method by adding some
additional logic that is also totally
valid and you can actually use that but
in most use cases these properties are
being accessed or these Getters and
Setters are designed so that any private
method can be exposed outside but with
some additional logic or additional you
can say some restrictions that you want
to put up so that is why it is being
used and it doesn't really mean that
always there should be a getter that
needs to be a Setter as well sometimes
maybe you want to just have an exposed
property don't want anybody to set it up
that is also the case so there could be
one there could be both and in the
Setters the most important part is that
there is no return type even if you try
to put up something like y it JavaScript
a typescript will yell at you and you
should not be doing that in case
somebody asks you in the interview yep
that is the case that is how typescript
is designed so that is all your Getters
and Setters uh in the typescript really
easy very accessible and let's go ahead
and catch up in the next video hey there
everyone fish here back again with
another video and in the last video we
saw about the public and private which
are access modifiers yes there could be
a lot of fancy names about keywords and
stuff but the real reason why we call
them as public private and there is
another one which we are going to
discuss in this video These are access
modified they limit your ability that
can you access those properties or how
you can access them maybe yes maybe no
or maybe why a restricted base and
that's why we call them as access
modifier so we've already seen that
there is an access modifier so we have
gone through with this one so there is a
private one had a lot of discussion
around it and when there is nothing
written it that means by default it will
be public you can explicitly mention
that to get more clarity on the code but
there is one more use case so what we're
going to do is we're going to shrink
down all these methods we are not
worried about them so let's just say we
I can actually shrink the Constructor as
well okay now we can see that this is
all good now there is a lot of time use
cases about inheritance you have
declared a class but you also want to
use these classes as a parent for
another class because a lot of
functionality is already written and you
want to just add a tiny bit of
functionality into those classes in such
cases inheritance is used so how do we
do that in the typescript it's really
simple let's just say we have a class of
user and we want to create a sub user
from that maybe there is a family member
in the user who also use your course
access so something like that so we can
go ahead and say this is going to be a
sub user and since you have already
defined all the functionality all you
can do is use the keyword which is
extends and this is going to inherit the
parent class so you just mentioned the
parent class so in in this case that's a
user so by default whenever you're going
to create a object or instantiate the
object with the sub user it actually
acquires all the properties here but
there is a problem it cannot acquire the
property which is mentioned as private
because remember in the last video we
discussed that private When you mention
the keyword private it can only be
accessed within the class not outside
the class so public is accessible in
this class as well as outside or
creating an object there is it is also
accessible so what we can do here is
we can go ahead and create something
like is family so let's just say a
family is also using this so this is
going to be a simple Boolean and we're
going to mark this as true so now we
have a new property which is is family
and that can also be accessed let's just
you define a method which is going to
manipulate this underscore course count
so we're going to go ahead and work on
with that so let's go ahead and try this
out we're going to go ahead and say uh
what should we name this one as change
course
course count there we go and this is
going to be a really simple method all
it does is anybody calls that it just
changes the course count so we can go
ahead and say this dot underscore
course count and we change it to four
for some reason I don't know what's the
reason we are able to change that now
notice here it says a property
underscore course count is private and
only accessible within the class I am a
big fan of how these errors actually
comes on the vs code especially with the
typescript no match for that and the
moment we change it up from private to
uh another keyword we can actually go
ahead and we have the public we have a
private and we have a protected so we're
going to go ahead and say protected the
moment I say protected this simply means
that this wherever you place it in this
property or wherever this will be
accessible in this class as well as in
any class which inherits this class it
will not still be available outside of
this you cannot access it directly like
hitesh dot something like that you
cannot do that but here now it is
accessible and yes that is your
protected another type of access
modifier there is no need to go and dig
dip it further just remember whenever
there is marked as protected it can be
used in the same class as well as any
class which inherits tasks that's all
that's all you need to know let's go
ahead and catch up in next video hey
there everyone face here back again with
another video and in this video I want
to bring your attention towards
interface again now that we have classes
we can actually talk about interfaces
now especially for the web developers it
is little bit tricky to understand
interfaces and they seem like why they
do even exist there is no implementation
of that there is no advantage of that
but let me tell you something from my
experience into working of iOS
development now this is exactly the same
concept they kind of borrowed it from
the Swift or probably objectives
Objective C as well this is similar
concept now in the world of IOS app
development there are a lot of protocols
we the interface we call them in the
typescript but in the world of iOS
development we call them as protocols
now these protocols don't have the
definitions they have just some
protocols that if you want to do certain
things you have to do this way and that
is the only way you want to do it now
these kinds of things are similar in
interfaces so let me tell you the same
example we are building a mobile app
which uses the camera just Theory again
which uses a camera and we want to
implement that kind of a scenario in our
application so let me walk you through
with the same example of iOS development
into the world of typescript and it is
so much easier to understand this way so
let me walk you through so moving on to
our uh I have created a new file which
is second dot TS I'm going to go ahead
and remove this one up here still in the
watch mode so that's fine so let's just
go ahead and say we want to Define an
interface now this interface says that
just go ahead and take photo okay that's
same now in this while taking the photo
I think that there should be a couple of
things that should be defined for
example there should be a camera mode
and this camera mode could be a string
maybe there's a front camera maybe
there's a back camera but whoever is
designing a class that you can take a
photo from your web application should
always Implement that these are the bare
minimum Basics We'll add couple of more
properties similar to this for example
we'll have a filter this filter is also
going to be a string and maybe there is
a burst mode uh burst mode or just
bursts photo bursts and we're gonna say
this should be number and this is not it
there could be more methods or functions
and there could be a lot more right now
we're going to get started with this
much only so this is the interface
now in your entire application no matter
how or who is building it if anybody
wants to create a feature of taking
photos should always and always follow
this interface how about that so let's
just say an application comes up and
it's an open source project that you're
building up you have design and
everything is being worked out and let's
just say somebody is building a
fictitious Instagram so we're gonna go
ahead and say Instagram now as soon as
Instagram says that I want to implement
a protocol or an interface of take photo
now notice here what happens this is the
reason why interface exists it gives me
an error and the errors are also precise
that it is incorrectly implementing the
interface that means hey if you want to
take photo there are certain number of
things that should always be there so if
you are inheriting me not inheriting me
it's basically implementing my protocol
or my interfaces that means hey this is
missing all these properties this should
be there to take photos so let's go
ahead and do that so how we can do that
we can simply design in a Constructor
and we can take all these properties
just like that so there we go
Constructor is there now here I'm going
to go ahead and say I'll take all of
them in public you can take them in
private as well no such big deal but
I'll say that hey I want to have a
camera mode and that camera mode is
going to be a string and we'll also take
one more which is again going to be
public the next one is filter
that is also going to be a string and
I'll also take one more so we're going
to go ahead and say public and this one
is a bus so we are taking five photos
ten photo in just a click how how much
that is now if I go ahead and say this
one is also a string notice it
implements that hey you shouldn't be
doing that burst is always a number it
needs to be a number so as soon as I do
this there we go now you're perfectly
following a protocol to take the photo
now what you do with those photos or how
you take the photos that is not defined
in my interface interface is something
which never involves the definition it
always influence that these are must
have things in order to have it let me
go ahead and show you one more thing
another class comes up and that class is
YouTube it also wants to take photos
it's going to come up with implements
and we're going to say that hey we also
want to take photo there we go now again
same error same problem I'm gonna go
ahead and copy this Constructor here as
well but in the world of YouTube I'm not
happy with this I want to have more
information for example I want to take a
simple public and I'm going to go ahead
and say you know what we also upload
short which is a type of string so you
can go ahead and use this it's not going
to complain that if you are doing more
than what is necessary that is allowed
but you cannot do less than what is
necessary up there so this is basic now
let's just say another interface comes
up and it says interface and stories are
getting popular everywhere so we are
implementing an interface that says
story whoever wants to utilize a story
in their application should have a
method that says create a story just
like that and it should return something
maybe a string maybe a number maybe void
whatever makes sense to you you can go
ahead and return that now the thing is
that if YouTube wants to implement take
photo as well as wants to implement a
story it cannot do it directly it has to
adhere with the rules that are being
provided so here it says hey you need to
create this method so this actually
needs to have a method with exact same
name create story so we're going to go
ahead and say create story now what this
great story does we really don't care it
can simply go ahead and log the values
that story
was created or whatever that is now you
can Define it much more better that it
can return some like photos or something
if the for if the story is being created
or maybe a video needs to be returned
yes we can go ahead and Implement that
but this is the main how you provide an
interface a guideline is provided in the
typescript that if you want to do
certain things this needs to and if you
go ahead and change this like for
example if this is a great story this
gives a problem no no you cannot do this
this brings consistency entirety in your
code and that's what typescript is all
about getting less error having more
consistency in the JavaScript and that's
why we use it I hope this class was
interesting and if this was interesting
hit that subscribe button and I'm gonna
catch you up in the next video
hey there everyone they share back again
with another video and in this video
we're going to talk about abstract
classes in typescript I hope you are
enjoying the typescript series if you
are enjoying that go ahead share this
out hit that like button subscribe in
case this is something you want to
consider and please uh do show your
support because these content videos
gets already very less attention it's
your help that can help me to get more
attention to these content videos which
actually delivers some knowledge rather
than just meta videos videos about
videos anyways let's go ahead and talk
about abstract classes in these in this
particular video in order to understand
abstract classes it is important that
you understand interface first so by any
chance the last video got skipped out
from you about the interfaces go ahead
watch that first then come back again
now we will have a small comparison
because in the typescript world and in
the interviews as well interviews love
to ask you about hey what's the use of
these abstract classes if the interface
is available and they are very very
similar we're gonna not only understand
the difference but we'll have a very
basic easier use case and just like you
always know it's going to be super easy
to understand there's just one classic
difference you point that out you
absolutely nail it down also we're going
to understand the use case so let's go
ahead and move on to the computer I'm
going to go ahead and comment out the
second dot TS because we actually worked
on this already I've created a new file
abstract class dot TS it's absolutely
empty just created it so that we can
save some time about it and let's go
ahead and try this out so what we're
going to do is in the last one we
actually worked on the interface and
then the interface was implemented by
any class remember the word implements
this is only used for interface and the
easier way to remember is interface
Implement so both start with PSI so yeah
that's the easy way to remember now
let's go ahead and try to create an
abstract class and see how does it work
so we're going to go ahead and create a
class and we're going to call this one
as take photo just like the same class
that we created earlier so this is
really simple I cannot go ahead and
create something like this I cannot go
ahead and copy this piece of code and
just place it up here this is not a
valid code so you notice it already in
the very first this is not really an
interface so this is not allowed I
cannot have just the mention of these
properties in order to mention them
obviously you know that I need to have a
Constructor we're going to go ahead and
have a Constructor just like this this
time we'll use only the two of the
properties that's easier one and we'll
be using the shortcut for that so we'll
be saying hey public give me a camera
mode that is going to be a string and
apart from this also hey public give me
uh what should I have filter yeah filter
is fine that is also a string
string so this is okay completely okay
as a class now let's just say if I want
to
use this class into my sum another class
so what I'll I'll be doing uh I'll be
saying something like this class and
let's just say Instagram is now it does
it cannot implement it but it can extend
it so this is the first difference
between the keywords this is like having
an inheritance here all right let's go
ahead and use this take photo and we can
go ahead and do this no problem at all
now for a moment I would like to comment
this out and first since we have created
a class let's create an object from it
so I can go ahead and say const uh I can
go ahead and name it as hitesh that is
going to be having a new and we can go
ahead and say take photo this is
completely valid and let's go ahead why
is it having an issue cannot re-declare
blocks hitesh okay all right I need to
change my name I'll call myself as HC
that would be great and uh it says take
photo
let me go ahead and save this why is it
having an issue with the take photo okay
all right camera mode was not provided I
get that so I'll be saying uh providing
two strings into this one so the first
one is going to be let's just say test
second one is also going to be test and
now it is all happy so this is
completely allowed completely valid the
problem actually starts the moment you
declare this class as abstract the
moment you declare it abstract now no
new object can be created from this
class and obviously it makes sense it
makes no sense that hey we are creating
a class we are not able to create any
object from it so what's the point of
having a class and that's exactly what
the abstract classes is known for in the
world of abstract classes
these are almost like blueprint yes we
have a blueprint like interface but in
the abstract classes they are exactly
the blueprint you cannot create an
object from it it's the responsibility
of the class who is extending it uh it's
the responsibility that hey create
object from this class so if I go ahead
and move this code here to make easier
we can go ahead and use Instagram here
and that is totally valid you can create
object from the class who is inheriting
it but that's the whole idea okay that's
the first difference I think you got
this one but this is not all there is a
lot a little bit more to it we have also
seen that in the interface we can create
these method definitions so let's go
ahead and try to create a method
definition in fact I'll just copy this
and we'll have this one or let's just
have a different one we want to have a
different method where you want to call
it as get Sapia
Sapia did I wrote it correct nope yeah
this is what this one is correct so we
want to have a simple get save here and
I'll just say that hey this doesn't
return anything this is just a white
now notice here I say that hey this is
get Sapia it says function
implementation is missing or not
immediately followed this can be done if
you just go ahead and call this one as
abstract you can go ahead and say that
hey this is the abstract method that
means I'm not going to provide you
definition this is just a method I don't
know how anybody is going to implement
it but they need to implement it
otherwise they are not following this
abstract class so I have to go ahead and
follow this one first I'll just go ahead
and show you one more common way you're
going to see a lot of code just like
that so just like this and here while
creating the Constructor I'll just
comment this out for a minute so that
you can see what's happening so in the
Constructor I'll take couple of
properties so I'll say hey public
I want to take a camera mode
camera mode that is going to come up as
string let's have a comma move to the
next line
and this one also much more readable
I'll also take public I'll be saying hey
give me a filter as well which is going
to be a string and since this is a
additional or advanced class inherited
class this also takes burst photo
so we're going to go ahead and say burst
which is going to be a number
number this is going to create a problem
in your case because if you want to take
a Constructor like this you have to
actually use a keyword super
in which you have to pass on all the
required values so required values are
camera mode so let's go ahead and pass
on this camera mode directly here and
I'll also pass on filter so this is a
common syntax you're going to see that's
why I have introduced this to you all
right so this is all good now let's come
back on to the part where we were
discussing about these abstract so sepia
obviously not implemented so you have to
implement it so all I have to come up
here and say hey I am implementing a get
Sapia I don't know what this is doing
this don't have to return anything so
we're going to just do a console log and
I'll say uh Sapia okay uh sapiya
there we go so you saw that how we can
do it now you might have noticed that in
the interface also we can Define these
things so what's the point of having
these abstract classes in addition to
that what you can do is let's just say
these days reels are really really
popular they are getting very popular so
I want to say uh get real
time I want to define the method and
this method is going to return you a
number and then further down we will do
some complex
uh calculation
and after doing a lot of calculation
we're going to go ahead and say hey we
are returning uh eight or whatever the
number is you get the idea how we are
doing it so notice here this doesn't
give me any problem here this is the
power of abstract classes and this is
something that makes them still in the
in the realm of typescript otherwise
everything else is being done by the
implements and the uh this interfaces so
this is what may it makes something new
I can go ahead and create an object just
like this and that is fine it needs
another value the value is let's just
say three
and now I can go ahead and say Hey Etsy
wants to get uh real time I can go ahead
and use this and that's totally allowed
and valid and in fact I can go ahead and
override this method as well if I want
to uh so that is totally allowed as well
because it's just a class and it has
that feature so this is what something
that makes abstract classes so again uh
going through with the summary of it you
can make abstract classes abstract
classes cannot create their object on
their own but they help to define the
class who are inheriting them get a
better structure of their classes and
some compulsory thing that you have to
put if you want to put up some method
that are compulsory linked to there you
can make those Methods at abstract as
well in case you want to give them some
feature by default by giving them the
methods you can go ahead and do that
these classes can actually override
these methods as well but if you want
them that hey this should be like this
only always then use the abstract method
so I hope you got this one a pretty
interesting discussion about the
abstract classes I hope you have enjoyed
this if you have enjoyed this hit the
Subscribe button and I'm gonna catch you
up in the next video hey there everyone
thanks here back again with another
video and in this video we're continuing
our typescript series and we are moving
ahead on to one of the another really
important topic which is known as
generics I personally love genetics when
I'm writing a lot of production level
code because genetics is one such thing
which makes your components reusable and
by the term component I mean to say all
of your functions even your arrays are
genetics behind the scene so it is
really important that you understand
also it is also important that you don't
pick up the word whenever I say
component it doesn't means it always has
to be a react component or Tailwind
component component is a broader term it
simply means there is a chunk of
something it can be a Tailwind chunk it
can be a reaction it can be just a
function so understand that point now
let's go ahead and move forward into
understanding the genetics I'll first
walk you through with the documentation
part because it's important that we all
learn how to read the documentation and
find out some of the example which
floats around all the web but these
examples actually come from the
documentation and after that we'll
understand a bit of the array and we'll
design a couple of these genetic methods
and we'll understand what kind of
problem they are trying trying to solve
so without further Ado let's go ahead
and move on to the documentation part so
here I'm on to the web page of the
typescript where official documentation
happens and on the left we can easily
find the genetics really easy to find
there is nothing much you can see just
the type manipulation genetics just
there so as we can see up here genetics
are a major part and also notice the
vocabulary that they also use is
building components that not only have
well-defined and consistent apis but are
reusable and again apis is something
that you can ignore right now which is
just an example they're trying to give
here so component is something which is
capable of doing something more than it
was original design and almost all
languages have them C sharp Java so if
there is a lot of languages which
actually support these genetics so
pretty common thing these days but it
was such a groundbreaking at the earlier
days now there is a nice example we'll
recreate these example but notice here
what they are trying to show you in
these examples so it says without
genetics we would either have have to
give identify identity function a
specific type so what they're doing here
is they have created an identity
function and they're providing an
argument which is a type of number and
which also returns a number when you do
a return of ARG which is whatever you're
passing into that method it returns you
the number so this is obvious we have
been doing this but if we want to design
this function such a way that if it
takes string it also returns a string so
we have to say that Arc string then the
return type is a string and when you
return the string so we have to define
the function for each data type Boolean
string number and if you want to bypass
that you want to design a function such
a way that whatever the data type you
actually send it it also returns that
data type so one way or one common thing
which comes to mind is always hey let's
use any which is not a good idea always
it's such a breakthrough that you always
want to get away from the things using
any here we can definitely use any but
it actually removes some of the
information from the from the argument
that you're passing for example I I can
accept any argument and return any but
what if I give you input as number and
you return me back as a string it will
still work so this is not something that
we want so in that case this type
actually comes up which has these
angular brackets and this is something
which denotes the generic type and there
is a lot that we can discuss about
generic we'll come back onto the
documentation a little bit uh later but
right now let's go ahead and open up vs
code
so here is my vs code
and let's go ahead and create a new file
into the source and we're going to call
this one as my generics dot TS of course
and let's go ahead and see that what
kind of problem we are facing and how
actually this problem is not really big
and already being solved by something so
let's just say if I go ahead and create
an array and notice here there are a
couple of ways how you can create array
we have already seen it once but this is
a common way of creating array but we
have also seen that you can go ahead and
create an array like this and then using
these angular brackets you can mention
that this array is going to have a value
number and we can store this into
anything like for example this could be
a score of any game that you are playing
so this is code like this and not that
there we go and we have defined its type
and now we can say that this is right
now empty but eventually uh things will
come out into the definition so this is
one of the way and again we can actually
go ahead and further improve it we can
go ahead and design the arrays something
like this so you get the idea there is a
string as well and we can go ahead and
store this into let's just say we are
going to have some names so these values
can be also like this
so you get the idea that genetics is not
something that we are designing in the
language they are already in the
language in fact most of the language do
support arrays with different numbers
and different strings so yes this was
already existing there we just didn't
talked about it now we're going to go
ahead and talk about it and we're going
to design the method version by version
so that we can reach there and
understand what is the use case of that
so I'll keep them here so that you can
have just for the reference so let's use
the same example we're going to have
identity
identity and we're going to call this
one as identity one because we're going
to create multiple identities here so
let's first understand what is the
challenge that let's just say I want to
create an identity such that it accepts
either a number or maybe a Boolean as
well so we have already seen that we can
go ahead and do this we can go ahead and
Define the type as let's just say
Boolean is there and we can use this or
and we can go ahead and say you might be
having a number as well and in the
return type also we can go ahead and say
that we can have something like uh we
are going to return a Boolean
or that can return as a number or a
string whatever you like so this is
perfectly a valid code and I can go
ahead and say return a Val now there's a
lot of confusion here so if I go ahead
and say return well it can be either a
number or it can either be a Boolean I
can go ahead and do the check whether
the type of the value is Boolean then go
ahead return a Boolean if the type of
num of value is a number go ahead return
a number we have seen that kind of
example in the past but this doesn't
actually cut through the problem that we
are facing it doesn't work for string
surely we can go ahead and use R and how
many hours you are going to use there
now we saw in the documentation that we
have identity uh two let's just say and
here we saw that we can take in value
and that can be any which is really a
horrible keyword it is there for
escaping some of the tricky situation
but it shouldn't be used much and we can
go ahead and use any and we can go ahead
and say Hey I want to return this Val
now again the problem remains since uh
typescript has no idea what the value is
comprised of and the definition or the
information about the type is gone in
this case so we can go ahead and see
that yeah this identity 2 is e also not
working so let's move on to the version
which actually is the topic so which is
going to be identity three
and in the identity 3 what we're doing
is we first go ahead and put angular
bracket now this is super important for
the syntax and we go ahead and Define a
type here now once we Define a type here
into the identity 3 then we can go ahead
and take the parameter and this is a
little bit weird syntax I'll give you on
that no escape from that part no sugar
coating there and we can go ahead and
say this value is going to be of a
certain type and the return is going to
be also off type okay now interestingly
what is going to happen after this one
is now you can go ahead and return and
return this value
now the difference between the one where
we said value of any is this could be
anything and this also could be anything
so we can take any type of value return
any type of value take number as input
return as a string not that big not a
good idea now but when you say mention
the type it actually says hey this is
almost like any I am ready to accept
numbers I am ready to accept string
whatever you like so how's it different
from any because once you actually pass
on anything that value type is logged
yes for the reference or understanding
purpose this is easier to understand so
whenever I give number as an input this
is hey the number is the input type that
is coming up so the value you are
accepting is going to be of number but
the return type automatically becomes a
number so that is the advantage of using
this for example if I go ahead and say
Hey I want to use identity 3 and while
the identity 3 I'm going to go ahead and
pass on a number three here now notice
here
as I say it says Hey the value that you
are giving me is 3 and it is going to
return as 3 value but if I go ahead and
wrap this up as a string it
automatically converts that hey you are
taking 3 as an input but I'll return you
as 3 as a string so that is the
advantage of it if I go ahead and say
hey this is going to be hitesh then you
go ahead and check it out by hovering it
says hey it is giving me a string I'll
return your string not only that you can
go ahead and say that hey I want to go
ahead and give you a true value and it
is going to give you a Boolean as a back
so you're locking that value that is the
most important aspect of it and this is
something that you're going to see less
this function definition type like this
how most people like to Define it is a
bit of a shortcut one so I'm going to go
ahead and say hey this is identity 4.
and then you go ahead and see angular
bracket a t Capital version and then
whatever the parameter you take for
example value you go ahead and Define
the type as T and then the return type
is also going to be T and we're going to
go ahead and say hey let's just return a
t
not t a vowel there we go now this again
is exactly same as line number 12 to 14
this is exactly a replica of line number
18 to 20. the only difference is calling
it as identity 3 or 4. now this is
shortcut it doesn't mean it always have
to be types or t you can call it as
simply as H every place is that's also
totally valid but it needs to be
referenced the same letter that you're
using or a word that you are using so
this is really basic you're going to see
them a lot being there now the advantage
of this identity 4 or something like
this having this data type is you can
actually Define your own types and can
pass on into this one it's generic
anything can be passed onto it this one
so for example let's just say we Define
an interface of this bottle so we're
going to go ahead and say hey bottle
interface bottle there we go and your
bottle can have anything that you want
for example it will it is going to have
a brand which is going to be a string
and also let's just say type there are a
lot of types of bottle this is a gym
bottle so type is gym and not gym
actually this is again let's just say a
number I don't know why the type should
be anything like that but this is it now
you can go ahead and use this function
exactly like this so we can say hey I
want to use identity
4 and I'm going to go ahead and pass you
a type of bottle so I can go ahead and
say that hey just like I was able to use
and pass on this three I'm I can go
ahead and say hey I'll be using a bottle
and then I'll pass you on the UN object
like that so this is totally valid of
course I'm not passing an object which
is missing the parameters of bottle and
brand and type which you can actually do
that if you're following around the
series but this is a way this is a
syntax how I can pass on now the data
types that we saw here are actually the
default ones like the old-fashioned uh
numbers string you can directly pass on
them but if you are trying to create
your own then you have to use this
syntax this is really little bit weird
but yeah eventually you'll get a get a
hold of it and this is so as you can see
genetics actually solves a great deal
and is really reusable and we can use
them a lot let's go back up here on to
the documentation so this is exactly
what they have mentioned in the
documentation that you can have the
identity and can pass on my string up
here and working with the generic type
variables this is how they actually go
ahead and work on with that we have
already gone through with these and
we'll definitely discuss a little bit
more about the generic but to be honest
this is only the Meat part of genetic as
you work through with the react or
angular you'll find that we use them a
lot and sometimes methods are defined
this way so let's keep this short I hope
you have understood the basic core
concept why genetics exist and how we
can use them and let's go ahead and
catch up in next video
hey there everyone stay here back again
with another video and in this video I
would like to discuss and extend the
discussion about the generics in the
typescript now generics are really
simple but for a beginner who have never
seen them especially in the typescript
the syntax with different data types can
be little bit confusing especially when
it comes to array and how the array
return type works so I would like to
bring you on to the documentation of
typescript we'll give you some reference
example from here and then we'll move on
to the code part and we'll walk you
through that how the arrays works as
well as a small brief introduction about
how the arrow functions can be used so
far we have been creating functions in
the typescript just using the function
keyword but that's not all you can
actually go ahead and use your arrow
functions and I'll show you the Syntax
for that in case for those people who
are confused about it so moving back on
to the documentation we opened it up in
the last video as well we see that just
above here we can see that this is all
what we have discussed that the property
length and all of that so this is all
good now here are the examples in the
documentation are referring that that
you cannot just use a DOT length on any
of the parameter because it's not a
guarantee that it's always going to be
an array it could be string it could be
just a number and on number we don't
have the property of dot length so this
is all what it is saying now interesting
part comes up here on this part where we
are taking an input parameter as an
array so this is one type how we can
take input parameter as an array and
this is also a type how you can take
input parameter now both of them are
exactly same we have seen that in the
last video that there are a couple of
ways how we can Define arrays and the
second one is also a type and the first
one is also a type but when you actually
go ahead and try to build this it can be
a little bit confusing at some of the
situations let me walk you through with
it so let me take you to the code part
and we are going to define the almost
exactly same this example up here so let
me move to the code part all right so
first what we're going to do is we're
going to learn that how we can create or
take an input as an array and what could
be the possible cases of when we are
returning some values so let's just say
we are going to create a method which
says get search products
any you're searching a product doing an
API call and through that things are
coming in so we are going to Define this
as a genetic so obviously this is the
first part of how you Define genetic
this is a template this is how you write
it just like you write arrays with the
square brackets this is how you define
genetics so far we haven't defined what
types of input we are taking what type
of return type we are taking this is
just Basics this is how you define it
with an angular bracket and T then comes
up is the parenthesis and in this you
define that what data type you are
expecting in this one so let's just say
somebody is giving us a products or a
list of IDs whatever you want to take
that's that's totally just a generic
name and then I'm going to go ahead and
say that hey I am taking t as an input
but this is not an ordinary input I'm
taking array as input now if I go back
on to the documentation part we have
seen that this is how you take types as
an array but I can also go ahead and use
this array type as well so both are
exactly same now here's the interesting
part the return type is also T and let's
go ahead and try to return something now
there could be many cases that what you
want to return maybe this is a search
result you want to return the search
index so in that case I would love to
return a 3 which is not correct in this
case because remember I told you this
actually locks the value whatever the
value you are taking as an input so if I
return that same type of value as an
output this is not correct if you want
to do something like this you obviously
should have done something like the
return value is going to be number which
is an index but in the case where you
want to have the T then you have to
return the product itself and again
remember this is an array so I have to
say that hey whatever the products are
coming up into that one value should be
there there could be now three values so
you're returning the third index which
is fourth value so this is totally valid
and totally fine but remember you have
to think from a broader perspective this
could be easier for a lot of experienced
programmer but this could be little
tricky for somebody who is just getting
started with typescript so remember the
return type is the value that you're
taking is an array of T types so the
return value here I'm mentioning is T so
that should be one of the value from
that array okay got it okay let's go
ahead and make this a little bit better
so what we're going to do is we do some
uh do some database operations
and then we go ahead and Define a value
so we go ahead and say my index is three
maybe after returning a lot of complex
operations a method calling this comes
up so we go ahead and call this one as
my index so you get the idea how this is
being designed so this part is all clear
now how we can convert this exact same
function into an arrow function because
this is where the syntax comes up and
this is where when you see or read other
people's code on the GitHub you might
find some things confusing so let's go
ahead and clear that up so what we're
going to do is we're going to call this
one as simply const and we're going to
call this one as get uh more mode get
more
search products yes you can pick up any
name that you like now here we go ahead
and Define this so what is the Syntax
for defining a genetics in an arrow
function method it's really simple you
first go ahead and Define your T just
like this remember this is an indication
that this is going to come up as a
genetic so just like here we did the
generic this is exactly what we do here
after that we put a parenthesis any
arguments are there or not then we
provide a return type and then we go
ahead and write our definition so before
the definition this goes like this there
we go so this is the basic syntax of how
we Define the arrow function this is
little bit new otherwise if I go ahead
and remove this this is a classic Arrow
function we have seen this many many
times so in this case we are going to go
ahead and say that hey this is a generic
Arrow method this is where we take the
reference and after the colon we Define
the data type and then we go ahead and
put an arrow function and the definition
really simple nothing much so here also
we want to Define exactly same so we're
going to go ahead and say hey product
and we want to take products as an array
so this can be of any type of array and
the return type is going to be T it
could be number but in this case I want
to replicate the exact examples so we go
ahead and do that we go ahead and say uh
do some
database operations
and then we go ahead and say my index
and this time the index is going to be
let's just say 4 where we are feeling
very creative there and we go ahead and
say return and then we go ahead and say
hey products this time we're going to be
returning my index again so get the idea
this is easier but you have to look
through the big picture up here so again
if I go ahead and remove this one this
is a regular function it could take
number so I can go ahead and say hey
this is a numbers array and I'm going to
return a number obviously I have to
tweak the definition according to that
but you get the point at how this is
being done so really simple you have to
look through the genetics as like yes
this is also a data type and this which
is a strange looking thing is a
syntactical sugar okay so this is the
basics what they have tried to Define
and once you are taking the input as an
array then obviously through the
arguments you can use the array
properties which are available to them
like length and all these things so
further down we have generic types as
well so they also walk you through that
how you can create generic types which
we've already seen and all of that so
we'll talk about that a little bit later
but this is the most important thing now
one last thing before we close this
video you're going to see a lot of code
bases like this and this is not going to
produce any error now this comma is
there to mention that this is not an
ordinary tag like H1 tag or a P tag this
is a generic and this is a common syntax
you're going to find this a lot
especially people who are working with
react they like to use these genetics
and they put this a comma here to
mention that this is not a jsx syntax
but rather a Syntax for genetics so keep
that in mind you'll see this comma quite
a lot in the code basis if you're
reading other people's code so that's it
for this video if you're enjoying this
series hit that subscribe share the
series this is really important when the
value content comes up we need
motivation that people are sharing the
entire playlist and Series so that we
can come up with more that's it for this
one let's catch up in next one
hey there everyone they share back again
with another video and this is one more
video in the generics topic now yes
generic is a bit longer of a topic as
well as it is being used a lot and kind
of a new for a lot of JavaScript
developers that's why I'm taking my time
to explain this all in depth and we can
find out all the nuisance that it can
probably create while understanding it
if you are watching this video directly
go ahead and watch last two videos
because that are foundational base of
the generics this video will not make
much more sense if you haven't watched
them so moving further so we have a
small topic remaining up which is
definitely one of the major one is
classes that we are going to cover in
this video but we'll cover more over the
syntax part of it and some of the use
cases of it but rather one more part
that is being shown up here let me walk
you through with the documentation it
says using the type parameters in
generic constraint this is something
really important you need to understand
the mindset behind this instead of just
focusing on the syntax or memorizing it
or something just understand why does it
actually belong here on the very first
place so let's try to understand the
confusing documentation first and then
I'll give you a simpler and easier
example onto this one so it says you can
declare a type parameter that is
constrained by another type parameter
okay got it for example we hear we'd
like to get a property from an object
given its name we like to ensure that we
are not accidentally grabbing a property
that doesn't exist on object so this
time the developer is little bit
panicked that I really want to have
objects and nothing which looks like
object or is not an actual object so
here we say is get property and it's
having a type
and the key extends to the key of type
so what this is doing so we can actually
use an extends keyword and you can make
sure the extents allows you to have a
specific type of this one as this data
as well now yes there could be a
question that if we are that much Panic
why can we just say that this value that
is coming up we can mention the type as
object yeah actually you can do that
there are a lot of ways of doing the
things and this is what makes people a
lot of confusing so instead of going
through with the confusing documentation
let me take you on to the code screen
and show you that how this could be
achieved so coming back on to our first
example that we discussed that we want
to create something like this where
there is a function which takes two
values that could be any values Boolean
number or anything we don't want to use
this syntax so that's where generics
actually helps us so let's go ahead and
say that this is another function
uh feel free to name it anything much
better than what I'm trying to do up
here but we want to create a generic
this time we'll take two inputs so you
guessed it right this can be T and this
could be U so u v n number of values
that you can provide us as many as you
wish to have now further this this is my
type where I'll take the parameter and
this is my return type so I'll say that
uh what return type we want to have a
return type of uh maybe an object
so I'll just say an object just like
this
so right now I'm returning not returning
any object that is fine but important
part is what I'm taking as an input so
this is my T as a generic and I'll take
just U so right now I'm not doing
anything and all I'm doing here is I
want to return this so how I'm returning
this I'm going ahead say that this is
going to be my value one so I'm going to
go ahead and say Val 1 which is of type
t
and I'm also going to go ahead and say
Val 2 2 which is going to be of Type U
and at the time of return I'm returning
this object don't know why but I'm
actually returning them both of them so
value 1 separated by comma and value 2.
so this is something which is a syntax
you have learned new that there could be
T there could be U there could be V as
many as you would like to take as an
input this is fine but there is
something in this that let's just say
for example you want to use this method
so I'll just say that this is a function
another function sorry this is another
function and in another function I want
to say that hey this could be 3 and this
could be a 4 but in a string format this
is now expecting uh the values and it is
taking them widely that's why the
generic values exist but there could be
a situation where you can go ahead and
say hey this is going to be extends and
we're going to go ahead and extend the
number now it gives us a problem that
hey strings are not allowed this could
be a number or any type of number if I
go ahead and say that hey this could be
3 or this could be 4.6 yes this is
allowed because this is a number but
again this defeats the point of having
the genetic yes you agree I would agree
on that part but where this could be
used first I hope you got this much and
then I'll show you a real world use case
scenario where this extents actually
matters a lot so I go ahead back on to
the documentation and I see that yes
this is what exactly they are trying to
do with the help of extends keyword but
this is a bit of a complex example so
it's not easier to understand so this is
exactly I hope now by looking at this
one you see that this is making a little
bit sense not much baby but this is
making a little bit sense okay let's go
back onto the code part and show you
something more interesting now let's
just say this method is defined and
there is an interface so let's define
the interface let's call this one as
database and this is a database
interface there is a connection string
into it which is a type of string
and string if I can write that and there
is also a username which is also a
string there is also a password that is
also a string so maybe you're defining a
custom method in which you want to take
that you could be anything but it should
be a type of database so in that case
you can actually rely that hey anything
could come up here or I want to define a
generic which actually go ahead and say
extends uh database so in that ways you
are although defining very generic but
you are still restricting it that it
should be a type of database uh yes
there could be another way of handling
this exact same situation but since
typescript offers us a lot of options I
want to show you all the options and now
obviously I have to go up here provide
an object this object needs to have all
the values uh like connection username
and password you get the idea and yes
you get also the idea that we could have
directly said that this value should be
of type database yep that also exists
that can be there I just wanted to show
you couple of use cases maybe this might
be useful in the complex thing that you
are designing so wanted to introduce you
with all the situations okay now there
is one more thing up here which I wanted
to First discuss in the documentation
which is the last topic we'll be
discussing about generic surely there
could be more but you can also Define
class types in genetics so notice this
year they are creating a couple of
functions here just like that it it's
fine but there is a class here which
says beekeeper then there is a zookeeper
then there is the animal which B extends
the animal there's a there's a lot going
on in this example and what they're
trying to do is create an instance on
all of that so yeah a lot of stuff not a
really great example what they could
have given in the classes and I'm pretty
sure somebody might have written a
better blog onto this one let me take
you on to this one so here what we're
going to do is we're going to take an
example of selling a courses and quizzes
so these are two sellable items that you
can sell and you want to create a class
in which there could be a quiz there
could be a course and you want to create
some methods which work for both of them
because both of them are sellable so
let's go ahead and try this out so let's
just say there is an interface and let's
call this one as quiz
now quiz is not that much complex it has
a name which is a type of string
and maybe there is a type as well there
are a lot of types of queries quizzes
for IIT quizzes for coding there could
be a lot so this is one syllable there
could be another interface where we
could have the course
and course is a little bit more complex
maybe there is a name obviously there is
also a author involved in the course
just like books these days courses are
authored and there is also a subject
don't know why but there is a subject in
the course not in the quiz and now you
want to create a class which is not
going to be one shot all it's not going
to be class which will solve all of your
problems but there could be a case where
I can create a class which can handle
some of these common cases Let Me Show
You by an example so I go ahead and say
call this one as a class which is going
to be sellable
yeah if that is correct as a spelling I
want to take that in this class I am
creating a generic class the moment you
see generic function or anything like
that these Square Brack these angular
brackets and the T or any keyword there
is a sign that this is a genetic class
this is a generic function and in that
class you can take uh any type of values
up here for example I just go ahead and
say Hey I want to create a public
cart which is available to everyone this
is going to take the same type but an
array of that and will initialize it
with an empty one you get you see where
I'm going with this one so now I have
this card which is a type of T whatever
the T I'm taking and it's an array of
that so I'm not saying that this is
going to be a class which handles all
the courses array or all the quizzes
array or maybe later on you decide to
have bundles as well so whatever you are
thinking it can actually go ahead and
work on with that now it's not a one
shot all but you can Define some method
like add to cart and this method may be
may take a lot of products so we are
going to call this one as products
products come on if I can write that and
these products are going to be of type T
you get the point and now I'm going to
add these products so I'll just say this
dot cart dot push and inside that we are
pushing up this product so let's go
ahead and say products our product would
be better product
you get the idea
so this is a generic class which can
handle any type of object that you can
pass it on and can do operations on that
remember in this class we are taking t
as generic here so it's not limited to
just quiz and courses there could be
more or you can design more and I'm not
with this you should take this statement
that I'm not saying that this class is
going to be one rocket for all this is
not a bullet this is not a silver bullet
which will handle all the cases but
maybe maybe you can Define certain
classes which handles quizzes nicely
certain classes which handles courses
nicely but there could be could be one
of the generic class which might handle
the common use cases in both of them and
maybe also a future proof where you add
more products which are sellable can
handle those things as well so yes it
actually helps you to write bigger code
for a bigger project in a much smoother
way and much organized way so yes
there's a lot of things we have learned
about genetics I hope you have enjoyed
this one if you've enjoyed this hit that
subscribe button and I'm gonna show only
catch you up in the next video hey there
everyone face here back again with
another video and in this video we are
going to take a little bit of a
different approach now whenever we are
learning about programming or maybe
building any stuff we usually think
about the topics as these are the
problem this is how we are going to get
solution for example in the arrays we
cannot store multiple values in variable
so we use arrays in order to Loop
through the values we use Loops but
there are some examples with which are
business case Logics and there is no
problem or solution kind of approach in
them these are General cautionary stuff
that you should know about it and I'll
walk you through with some of the
documentation and some of the use case
example we'll be referencing directly
from the documentation so that in case
you need further information you can
refer to these documentations so without
a further Ado let's go ahead and get
started with that so we'll start with
the typescript documentation directly
from here and here if you closely look
at this we have almost covered a lot
here in fact almost all chunk has been
covered the base every day but there is
also one thing known as narrowing this
is mugged here because there's a key
important difference and this is
something which is useful quite a lot if
you click on this now this is where uh
you try to narrow down what kind of type
or data type you are having in your
variable for example it could be number
it could be string there could be lot
more the problem actually comes up is
finding out the type of the variables so
let me just go ahead and show you by
clicking on the inspect and it's not a
problem uh for typescript it's actually
a classic JavaScript issues and yes even
on their website also sometimes these
stuffs happen so no worries so if I go
ahead and use off use this type off and
I just go ahead and say I want to type
off one I know that this is a number if
I go ahead and use a string I go ahead
and it simply shows me that this is a
string the problem actually comes up
when you try to give it an array so if I
go ahead and give it an array of numbers
it gives me an object which can be a
little bit troublesome and problematic
in that matter of case now also you'll
notice that this type of is actually
challenging in programming if you go
ahead and use the empty string then also
it gives you a string but again the
literal null values are also objects so
yes there is a little bit trick involved
in the JavaScript and this is not
something which is problem this is
something that is the behavior of
JavaScript and you should be aware of it
and why we are talking about this so
much up here let me show you with a code
example that will actually make much
more sense so in the detection dot TS we
are going to be learning about some of
the cases where you might want to be
extra cautious and that's the whole
video is all about so let's just go
ahead and say hey this is my function
I'm going to go ahead and say detect
types
and type would be great and I'm saying
that the value comes up now this value
could be a number or it could be a
string
now based on this if I go ahead and say
Hey I want to return the val dot to
lowercase
I'm not allowed to do so because right
now there is no mechanism to 100
guarantee that this is an actual string
where I can use this method this could
be any right now because it could be a
number it could be a string so right now
the Val is in kind of a state where it
could be anything but again we can go
ahead and write cases in fact we have
learned about these cases that I can go
ahead and use the statement that if the
type of
type of Val is actually a number
then I can go ahead or maybe let's just
say we are going to go ahead and stick
with the same example if it is a string
then I can go ahead and say well dot to
a lowercase so this is the value I want
to use in this case this there is no
problem the problem actually starts to
come that you have checked the type and
you have also checked you have said that
hey this is going to return uh let's
just say val dot uh value of there is
not too much of the number so but I can
go ahead and say a plus 3. so this is
also totally valid uh so right now
cannot be applied to a string uh because
if it is here it should be number but
still this is saying that hey we haven't
checked it so probably you want to check
it out
we have to make a similar case
and we can go ahead and say return and
then we can go ahead and say if this
comes up here we can go ahead and say
well plus three this should be all good
now it is returning so it will reach to
this point of code only and only the
case when it is 100 sure it is number
but there could be more things there
could be more things you have checked
for this one but what about the case
where it could be a number array so that
is where the problem actually comes to
start so I'll just not do it here but
this is not something where you have to
keep on checking for each one of them
you have to be very cautious in writing
the business case that there could be a
number of arrays but we cannot go ahead
and check that as an array we have to
check that as an object so this is the
most important case now there is also a
similar case I'll just create another
function and again these are all
cautionary tales so make sure you pay
attention on the caution not what could
be the solution there could be a lot of
Business Solution so for example this is
a common case uh where we say provide ID
provide
ID why are you having issues uh
implementation is missing okay no
problem where somebody gives you an ID
and that ID is a type of string
and we go ahead and write the definition
and we go ahead and say that if
the ID is there or not so this is a
common example where we want to find
certain elements from the database and
maybe there is no ID being provided in
that method so in that case this could
be a string but this could also be a
null and again this is a cautionary tale
so this is something that you might be
doing quite a lot of time in your
regular code so you can go ahead and say
if there is no ID that means it is null
so in that case we can go ahead and say
something like a console log that says
Please provide
ID and we can go ahead and return the
method here and if this is all good then
we can go ahead and say that hey we did
some classic database operation and
after that we are returning ID with two
lowercase or something like that you get
the idea that how this is being done now
this is something not magical and this
is not something which is related to
typescript this is a simple code that
you have been writing quite a lot in
JavaScript but this is a code which is
appreciated and even being highly
considered that you should be writing
because here this could be null and this
could be string the reason for showing
this is just like you're considering
this as a null and you get extra
cautious similar to here you should be
extra cautious about the data type that
is multiple in the format so make sure
you treat null as anything like as a
string or a number and you provide extra
cautious here now there is one great
example in the documentation let me show
you that so where is that example and
let me go ahead yeah here it is so
notice here they give you a lot of
similar example that it could be string
and numbers and whatnot and you could
also use the type of and all these
things the thing which will catch your
attention is notice they call this typef
as a type guard so yes another fancy
name for interviews but it is nothing
more than that if you'll read the entire
documentation which I have gone through
line by line this is all they are saying
just use the type of for making an extra
guard about what type of variable is
coming up instead of calling it as type
of they call it as type guard another
fancy name nothing more than that so
this is all what we have now they also
provide this one example here which you
should also attention and this is all
same JavaScript in case you have watched
my videos these are truthy values and
false C values they are not literal
false but they produce the result now
there is this example here I would like
to actually borrow this example
and we'll show you that so we'll copy
this and we'll study this example this
is something really interesting
everybody should pay attention to this
one so uh don't do this uh yes we are
aware of that now notice here let's
understand this example so it says print
all where strings could be a string
could be a string array and could be
null also so three cases are there and
we are checking that if the strings are
there that means it is not null that
means yeah obviously so this case is
being taken care of and if the type of
the string is an object when we just saw
that array also results into as a type
of object so okay that part is also
covered and We're looping through it so
no big deal else if the type is just as
a general string then we just console
log it and you might be saying yeah
that's okay we have covered for the
string we have covered for the string as
an array and we have covered for the
null that's great but what is the case
that we haven't covered is is an empty
string an empty string is a little bit
cautionary thing notice here this is the
empty string and and these are truthy
and falsy values so this is exactly what
they're mentioning here that the strings
is truthy this at least prevents us from
The Dread errors like this but we
haven't covered all the cases we haven't
covered where the cases are that uh when
the value is nothing and this is not
gonna break our code but this is kind of
a business case where you should be
covering the case if the string value is
totally empty so this is all they want
to show you in the documentation again
reading and understanding from the
documentation could be a little bit
boring but this is what is going to make
your foundation absolutely amazing in
the world of typescript there's a little
bit more to this uh narrowing and there
is nothing much like too much you
haven't seen anything this is just a
general discussion in which I think you
should take part in it but in case this
sounds boring to you welcome to the
programming and reading from the
documentation so that's it for this
video let's catch up in the next one hey
there everyone fish here back again with
another video and in this video we're
still continuing the topic of type
narrowing still in our typescript series
these and as we saw in the last video
there are a couple of ways how we can
specifically find the types but there
are a couple of use cases mentioned in
the documentation which are specifically
meant for the flow that you actually
follow in the typescript let me walk you
through because the documentation has
one such great example so we are still
in the narrowing which we studied in the
last uh video so you can see there is an
equality of narrowing there is an
inoperator narrowing and quite bunch of
them now this in operator is not
something which is exclusive to
typescript only it's easily available in
typescript as well in fact we use this
quite a lot now they mentioned this
quite a number of times that the
inoperator typescript take this into
account as a way to narrow down the
potential type and we can use this not
just with the basics of objects because
in the all JavaScript example you're
going to see that this is being used to
find out whether that property or key
value pair in the key is available in
that object or not so this is usually
the use case we go ahead and check this
out if swim in animals so we can see
that this if it is available in animal
or not but I'll give you a more better
example that is actually make that makes
sense in the typescript for example so
let me show you uh as a really simple
interface if you're working in
typescript you'll be using like hundreds
of interface left and right let's just
say we have an interface of user and the
user obviously is going to have a name
and then you are also going to have an
email which is also going to be a string
all right this is a really basic
interface then we go ahead and create
another interface and this is admin
interface now we also know that admin
interface is almost same as the user it
has this name it has an email which is
also going to be a string but it has
another Boolean property which is is
admin which is a simple Boolean now this
is really basic and somehow you're
creating a function so let's just say
there is a function and you check out
whether is admin or not now in this case
let's just say a value is being passed
on or an account is being passed on and
you know that this account can be of
type user or can be of type admin so
there could be both of them and now all
you got to do is check this whether this
is admin or not now this is something
really really tricky as of now because I
cannot go ahead and say that hey this
account if it is having a property of
dot is admin it's not going to allow me
to return this I cannot go ahead and go
ahead and say hey return this because
right now it says Hey property is admin
doesn't exist on user it only exists on
admin so I have to make sure that
hundred percent this is admin and if
this is admin I can actually verify that
using pretty easily by the same operator
we studied here so let me walk you
through 0 so notice here the in operator
it actually helps you to narrow down
which interface it is it could be used
for the regular objects as well but in
the world of typescript you're going to
see that this is more use case scenario
for such interface let me walk you
through with the code remaining the code
I'm pretty sure you have already walked
through with that which is really simple
so I can go ahead and check whether this
is admin which is a property only
available in that so I can just go ahead
and say in and I can check whether is
the same is admin is available in the
admin so I'm going to go ahead and say
admin
is in account
so
there we go if this property
exist in this account then only we are
going to go ahead and say return and
we're going to go ahead and say is admin
so this is going to return us the
property if it is true or not and all of
that and we cannot actually go ahead and
append that account dot is admin that
would be better
okay
and otherwise we can return just a false
so this is a much better code and if it
has reached here notice here the count
automatically changes that it is 100
admin because we are going to only
follow or fall through into this if if
statement only because of this in
statement which actually verifies
whether this property and remember I
should actually change this name here uh
is admin
or
is admin account something would be
better because otherwise it would be
really confusing okay so this is a
function which says is admin account and
the account comes up as an interface and
this could be any type of interface can
be a user could be an admin and we are
narrowing it using the in property and
there is nothing too much to discuss
there and if we are 100 narrowing it
then we are making sure because this
property is admin only exists if the
interface type is of admin so this
actually validates and further boils
downs and narrows down the things onto
that so let me walk you through so this
is exactly what the examples are saying
up the example that we have taken up is
much more precise and clear but that's
it that's all it is there to discuss
about the in operator narrowing let's
catch up in the next video hey there
everyone here back again with another
video and in this video we're going to
be talking about the two more topics
which are again belongs to the same
category of type narrowing and the first
one is easy the second one takes a
couple of minutes to actually adjust but
it's also easy not to worry I'm here
everything is going to be easy so not to
worry on that part I hope you are
enjoying the series if yes do share it
up with all of your friends and hit that
subscribe in case you want to okay let's
go ahead and talk about the two more
type of how we can narrow down the type
this entire portion of the series is
about how we can go into the more
preciseness of the type so that we can
take better action and that's what the
typescript is all about getting the
types all narrowed down so let me walk
you through with the documentation again
and these all examples that we'll be
talking through some portion of these
examples come from the documentation but
I've modified them a little bit for the
easier understanding but yes the source
is always documentation so the next in
the line is the instance off so this is
how further down you can narrow down the
things and they just do mention the
Prototype and all of that but the idea
is the focus of your attention should be
on anything that is or that can be
constructed with the new keyword that's
where this instance of actually comes
into the picture so this is a common
keyword it's something that is obviously
there so you can just go ahead and check
out anything is X is an instant of date
so anything just you can use new keyword
like we create a lot of classes we can
also create arrays with the new keyword
we can create objects with a new keyword
all of that that can be find out I'll
just borrow this code into the code
reader so I can just show you a little
bit more so we have gone through with
this one so this is an instance off now
again in the value there says hey this
is a parameter and all that we'll just
get rid of that because we don't need
this parameter we don't need this part
let's uh let's adjust this code a little
bit so it's easier to understand
and there we go
all right so what this function is doing
it's a log value now notice here this x
can be a date or can be a string so how
can we find a date because remember date
can be easily created any type of
variable can be created just by saying
new and then we create a date just like
that a new date is being created similar
to that you can actually go ahead and
create an array like this so anything
that uses this queue new keyword is uh
there and this keyword instance of is
almost like not literally but almost
like type of type of checks you for the
default types instance of check you
whether this object was an instance of
some class or maybe some uh something
like that so here we checked whether the
x is an instance of date so it just
returns it true if that returns it true
we are able to further narrow it down
now notice here if I come up here we are
100 sure that X is going to be date in
this case and in the other case it's
going to be a string so yes this is also
a valuable keyword where the type of
doesn't really cut through there you can
check whether this is instance off and
again remember from the docs it can only
be used where there is a new keyword
that there is a potential of having a
new keyword so this is the easy part now
coming up on the part which is a little
bit tricky which is the type predicates
okay uh this is where typescript has
nothing to do it's a bit of a logical
flaw not flaw I wouldn't say but a
logical uh kind of a flow that goes
through and which sometimes matches and
it introduces a new set of keyword let
me show you and again we're going to be
using the same example that is given up
here pet fish and all of that so we'll
just gonna literally line by line write
this keyword but then we're only going
to write this much and then to
understand it we are going to use our
own functions okay but first let's go
ahead and use this one so we're gonna go
ahead and say function
and this function there we go in this
function we're going to say get food
there we go and before we actually go
ahead and Define this get food and stuff
we need to actually have a fish so again
this is all coming up from the
documentation not making anything up so
there we go so this is a fish and we're
defining a type of it which is going to
be like this and we're going to say that
hey you are going to have a method of
swim and this is going to be a method
like that this is not going to return
anything so we're going to go ahead and
say wide so this is really simple we're
going to go ahead and put a semicolon
duplicate that this is not a fish this
is a bird and bird don't swim they
actually fly so we're going to have a
fly method now we have two types just
like we had interface we could have type
again both the same values and based on
this now we can use an example that was
given to us in documentation so we're
going to go ahead and create a method
which says is fish so obviously just
like we had method like is admin this is
a method which is going to validate
whether the input value was given is a
fish or not really simple it could be
any variable well whatever you want to
say it could be either a fish or it
could be a bird so these are two values
now what we want that this function
should return as a true or false value
now how they do it in the documentation
is little bit of a typecasting pet ass
fish and all of that so let me walk you
through so what they do is first they
say that pet let's cast this as fish so
just like that let's wrap this up inside
a parenthesis once you actually do this
then they try to check the method so
fish has a method of dot swim and if
that method exists that means it cannot
be unidentified so we're going to say if
that is not equal to
undefined did I say it unidentified I
mean to say undefined okay so what we're
going to do is we're gonna simply go
ahead and say return there all right so
really simple yet a little bit more of
the code that is involved but here we
are saying pet is a fish if it has a
method of dot swim that is not undefined
then true it is a fish so that is
exactly what they are doing and they are
exactly saying like this but things
actually change a little bit so let's
try to use this this much so far we have
got the code from the documentation but
let's try to implement that so further
down the road I try to get some food for
the fish so let's go ahead and get some
food for the fish and I know that the
food is different for fish and for birds
so Pat is going to be type of either
fish that might come or it could be a
bird
all right now since I have the access of
this method which is is fish I can use
an if and else condition here I can go
ahead and simply say is fish which is a
method available to me and I can pass on
this pet here okay so far no problem and
if that is the case then here if I go on
to line 66 I'm 100 sure that whatever
the value of the pet comes up that has
already been identified for true for the
fish case now let's go ahead and say
that if this is the case then we are
going to return as a fish food and if
not then obviously it is a bird so we're
going to go ahead and return this is a
bird food I don't know what to call
fission but I'll also say this pet here
now in theory if we have defined it so
well and we have done this so much this
is coming up directly from the
documentation by the time we reach line
66 the pet should be identified as truly
as fish and on the line 69 it should be
identified truly as bird but that is not
the case if I hover over this pet it is
still confused typescript is still
confused whether this is a fish or a
bird here also goes same that it is a
fish or a bird so still the value or the
type of the value is not being
identified although it is not giving us
any error it will still work as it is
fine but this method is truly not
behaving because what this method is
returning is a true and false value
which is a Boolean in this in the case
so returning a Boolean that is fine
notice here it is returning a Boolean it
is not returning me a type of fish or a
bird okay so what does the documentation
says documentation says that you can use
pet is fish so you can instead of
returning a Boolean you can use the
syntax of pet is fish that means you are
typecasting it as a particular type for
example I can come up here since here on
the line number 60. I'm 100 sure that if
this returns as true then I'm sure the
return type is fish and again you have
to use a colon here my bad there we go
so this is a bit of a new syntax but now
you get the idea the True Value
returning Boolean is not going to cut
through in this special case but if you
go ahead and return the type which could
be fish or anything else in your case is
now a guarantee that we are returning
truly not as true but actually as a fish
when I come here now we are identifying
that we are returning a fish or we are
returning a bird I guess this is a
little bit of a weird syntax but this is
fantastic how they have implemented it
mind boggling but really really I
absolutely love that how they have
defined it yes the documentation is also
almost like that but I have just tried
to break it down this one is not so
great explanatory I've just modified
this example but again everything is
coming from the documentation we don't
learn anything from elsewhere it's just
documentation so I hope you have enjoyed
this one I'm super happy that you are
hit that subscribe button and let's
catch up in the next one
hey there everyone face here back again
with another video and in this video
we're gonna talk about the final the
final steps of the type narrowing now
this final step is broken down into two
steps the first one which is absolutely
bad I don't like it I don't appreciate
it the second one is really it's
something that makes sense so we're
gonna refer through the documentation we
will be using the code example from the
documentation but I have modified them
again a little bit because it's easier
when I am actually modifying them the
Code that is written here it's making
sense it's great but I can make it a
little bit easier so why not why do you
wait for it so let me walk you through
that how this actually works so the two
we are going to talk about actually they
are mentioned as three in the
documentation but these are actually
just the two topic the first one is
discriminated unions really mouthful and
the second one is actually in a mix the
never type and exhaustive checkness they
actually kind of make sense when you
talk about them uh together uh talking
about them separately is not gonna make
sense so let's first see what is this
discriminated unit men so they're making
a lot of examples so notice here only
thing you should mention or notice here
is that they are using shapes circles
and square we are also going to use that
but not like this I have made a better
example and then we are going to go
through with that I will take you back
on to this never type in case you
remember I briefly touched about the
types when we're discussing that yes
there is a never type as well you never
want to use that this is the place where
you want to use it but never want to be
available to you in any code so this is
the point where we actually talk about
them and then this exhaustive checking
we will come on to this exact same
example almost same example up here so
let's start with discriminated Union
just forget about it even exists I'll
show you the concept that is actually
much better and let me open up vs code
here it is all right so this is all we
can actually just talk about this in the
detection only so we're going to go
ahead and get started so what this first
discriminated Union really bad word uh
what they are talking about is let's
just say we have an interface we call
this one as Circle
and we actually kind of find out that in
order to use any other way we have to
actually know these interfaces well in
advance for example in this interface I
have to know all the properties to find
out whether it's a user or not I also
need to be well aware of the properties
available in admin that there is an is
admin so that I can check whether is in
or instance of or something like that so
what they are saying in the
documentation is you can mention a
property as the name as kind and you can
name this as literal Circle just like
that and similarly you can have an
interface and we can have a square and
here also you can mention the exact same
property and you can mention this as a
square you get that where this is going
on so have the property exact same name
in all of your interface and then you
can check that whether this is dot kind
of square or dot kind of circle so not a
big fan kind of a hacky way this could
be a best practice at the best but have
having them in the documentation that
doesn't feel really good so let's
continue with this one
so let's just say we are having the
circles obviously Circle will have a
radius or radii whatever you like to
call that that will be a number but in
the case of a square it will have a side
which will be a number now with this I
would also like to declare another
interface which will be let's just call
this one as rectangle
rectangle there we go okay in the
rectangle obviously they mentioned that
hey this is a good practice if you
mention a kind of rectangle rectangle
there would be and rectangle will have
two sides so let's call this one as
length which will be a number and will
also have width
which will also be a number so so far so
good no problem at all and yes we kind
of forget it that we can have a mention
of kind in each one of them by the way
it's not really compulsory that you say
it kind you can say that a property
finder whatever makes sense to you and
that's that is it that is it my friend
that is it your discriminated unions
they say that hey use the kind here the
example here is actually a little bit
shaky in this but you get the idea with
my example I think it's much more easier
that you can have a kind for all of them
so yeah that's basically it that's your
first topic yes and let's try to use
this otherwise it will not make much
sense so let's just say we are having
first let's have a type here otherwise
what we are going to check along so
we're going to say that hey I am
creating a shape that shape is going to
be either a circle
or is going to be S Square
there we go
now we can create a function we're going
to call this one as get true shape and
the arbitrary name is a good one here
okay in this one we're going to say that
hey a shape is going to come in which is
going to be of type shape just like that
and we can evaluate so the way how the
first method says that you should be
evaluating is by simply taking this
shape and we know that each of the shape
is going to have a value of kind and we
can match it for anything for example I
can match it for Circle notice how well
the auto suggestion now comes up because
of this kind which is kind of a good we
can go ahead and return a
math dot pi
so Pi R square is the formula so we can
go ahead and say shape now we are very
sure that this is actually shape is a
circle so notice here and I can go ahead
and find out the radius and I can Pi our
Square there we go so that's basically
it and if this is not the case then I am
sure that if I move to line number 97
then it is a square so I can go ahead
and return uh simply
shape and notice here as I say dot it
says side
so side shape dot side whatever formula
works for you so this is the
implementation of the first method that
we have used but there's also one more
thing if you read the documentation this
never type an exhaustive check so what
does it do and how does it work so the
basic idea is let's just say you are
creating a function and this one is
going to be get area
and this also takes a shape which will
be of type shape there we go now the
idea is you do a exhaustive switch and
case check for this one so you can use a
statement of switch yes that's available
and I can just check the shape dot kind
just like we do for the ratings we've
built a lot of applications together in
the courses so rating dot five star two
star one star all of that similar kind
of stuff so let's just say we have a
case where this is a circle so we can go
ahead and say I want to return I'll
borrow some code don't want to write
this again all right
so there we go and this is it so we're
going to go ahead and return this let's
go ahead and say I am having a case of
square
and this should be indented a bit
there we go and if that is the case I'm
going to go ahead and return again we'll
borrow a little bit of the code copy
this and paste it up here okay this is
good this is fine but what there could
be some more cases so for example we are
doing an exhaustive check here and that
is working absolutely fine because we
are having only two cases now this next
step is a precautionary step for making
sure that your code is future proof if
you remember we defined a rectangle as
well but we only checked for square and
circle but there could be a case in
future where now this is available for
rectangle as well now this you can
relate to something let's just say you
have defined uh you are working with the
payment gateways for stripe or maybe a
razor pay or wherever you like now there
are couple of status in the payments uh
maybe uh it has been captured it has
been refunded it has been initiated but
there is also a payment status which
later on was introduced known as
authorized you didn't worked out for
that now you have created an interface
for for it and you have make sure this
is it now if you go up here you'll
notice that hey what this is this is
obviously falling apart so this
particular code is not working out and
also on top of this this here seems like
we are working through it but there is
now another thing another case where we
should be checking which we are not
checking so I'm going to go ahead and
comment this out for a minute now this
is working out but we need an extra case
for this one let me show you what the
documentation says about it it says that
you should always have a default case
which should be of type never on to
whatever the shape you are defining and
you should return that now since this is
made as a type of never which should
never be used that is why this is
important and trivial to have this is
known as the never type so yeah this is
all exactly they are mentioning up here
so they are saying that hey you also
have a case of defaults okay not case
it's actually default
there we go so in the default what we're
going to do is we're going to create a
constant it could be any name so this
could be uh default for shape it doesn't
really mean this variable could be
anything because it's a type of never so
technically it should never be used and
we're going to go ahead and Define a
shape on that and then we're going to go
ahead and say return underscore default
for shape and why are you yelling it's
not assignable to type never so that is
exactly why this is meant and right now
this is giving me a problem because I'm
not checking for all the exhaustive
cases and this is exactly what you want
because if a new type or interface is
being defined and that is also being
used you want your code to yell at you
that hey you're doing something wrong
there should be something where you
should be checking so for example if I
come up here and if I go ahead and do a
check of the case now notice here I
check for a rectangle case and I return
foreign
shape dot length multiplied by shape dot
width and notice here now this code is
not running not acting and that is why
the type never is never going to be
assigned as a shape so that is why it is
all happy and yes this is all a good
practice so this is what I liked the
discriminator type yeah okay ish but
this never type is a really good check I
can directly see the use cases not just
for the payment Gateway but for a lot of
variety of checks because code always
keeps on evolving you have new types
keeps on coming new situations keep on
coming and this makes me always happy
that there is a default method which
should never supposed to be running
instead of just relying hey it will
never run this is a nice Checker I like
this much so this is the end of all the
values all the narrowing time that we
can have so all the important ones I
have discussed more you have now learned
that how we can read from documentation
so you can go ahead and do it so hit
that subscribe button and that's it for
this one let's go ahead and catch up in
next one
hey there everyone atheish here back
again with another video and welcome to
the final official end of the typescript
series it is very important that you
start a series but is it it is equally
important that you end up a series as
well start of the journey is important
so is the end otherwise it's all just a
tutorial hell now you have enough
knowledge with yourself with this
typescript series that you can go ahead
and Implement typescript in any
production grade application or can
start playing around with that in react
angular or anything like that if you
have reached so far I'm pretty sure you
have learned this the typescript is not
associated with angular or react or
anything else it just is a strong sense
of writing production grade JavaScript
which is probably less error prone and
give you more strong types so that the
chances of creating the errors are
minimized that's all the typescript is
now apart from this let me walk you
through I have also added the GitHub
repository here on this so that anybody
who is watching can actually go ahead
and just learn the this one and this is
the official page typescript YouTube 22
so this is entirely it probably I
mistyped it let me just go ahead and
correct that so this is no it's all
correct uh it was just showing me half
of that so this is all the link that you
should have otherwise just go on to my
GitHub repository and you can just find
it pretty easily it's super easy just go
on to the repos and you can search for
it and you'll find it at the top all the
source code are mentioned up here now
with this let me also mention this that
there are probably a couple of topics
that I might not have covered might have
slipped out here and there in the crack
but the most important part is if you
have watched the concept of this entire
series it was not just to teach about
the typescript but also to introduce you
how to learn from the documentation I
have explicitly chosen those examples
which are from the documentation so that
you get an idea and sense of how to read
from documentation so that if some topic
is missing you can directly go ahead and
read from there otherwise just let me
know on my Instagram and I'm super
active there and I'll try my best to add
those topics into this series if they
are sounding a little tough for you but
how long you're going to be keep on
asking for the videos go ahead and try
it out on the documentation first and if
it doesn't work out let me know I'm
always here to help you out with that
now go ahead and build some amazing
stuff that is the most important part of
brushing up your typescript I'll try my
best in the future so that I can come up
with some projects that include
typescript and together we can brush up
some of our knowledge as well as I can
teach you some of the production grade
stuff of how to use typescript this was
all it was an amazing ride I learned us
so much about the typescript as well as
bit more about the foundation of
teaching as well as creating better
thumbnails that's the one thing I
learned from the entirety of the Cities
now one small request from my side that
please go ahead if possible share the
series the tutorial Series where we
teach something don't get that much of
attention we don't get that much of the
views and again it's it takes a little
bit stress on the channel as well that
we are pushing the series which are not
taking much views so your small share or
from your colleague from your college
friends in your WhatsApp group in your
Discord channel in your telegram channel
would be super helpful if that is
possible from your side otherwise uh
fantastic series I learned a lot about
it I hope you have enjoyed a lot in that
keep on supporting me I'll try to push
more series like this and yes this was
really fun thank you so much and we're
gonna surely catch up in another such
series